welcome to the Gateway of Endless
Possibilities in the realm of social
media marketing get ready to unlock the
secrets propelling your online questions
to dazzling Heights in this captivating
tutorial we'll embark on a journey
through social media marketing
fundamentals equipping you with the
Essential Knowledge and strategies to
Captivate engage and convert your
audience like never before from creating
irresistible content to leveraging the
power of data driven insights will
Empower you to navigate the
ever-evolving landscape of social media
with confidence and fineness so whether
you're a budding entrepreneur a
passionate content creator or an
ambitious marketer join us as we unravel
the key principles and Unleash Your
Potential for digital success so are you
ready to take your social media game to
the next level if yes then have a look
at this amazing certification in digital
marketing which is postgraduate program
in digital marketing with this
certification you will be benefited with
a detailed understanding of search
engine optimization content marketing
web analytics keyword management and
research website management and
optimization URL management search
psychology keyword organization and
match types keyword research Advanced ad
feature and more not only these skills
but you will also learn a number of
tools like SC ranking HootSuite Facebook
Instagram LinkedIn YouTube Twitter
Google ads Keyword Planner and much more
so don't miss out on this incredible
opportunity take action today and enroll
in our course to unlock the secrets of
digital marketing success accelerate
your career and gain the skills you need
to thrive in the industry ready to get
started click the link in the
description box and embark on your
professional growth and achievement
Journey Harry spots are filling up fast
listen to what our Learners say about
our courses in their own words
I successfully changed my career from
software development to digital
marketing and simply learned present at
the perfect route hi I'm rimajraf from
Dubai and I have completed the pgp in
digital marketing from Simply learn with
Purdue University even though the
journey wasn't easy the pgp in digital
marketing with Purdue University acted
as not only a catalyst but a game
changer for my career change simply
learn because of its tremendously High
waiting to be rated as one of the best
Education portal online worldwide is
surely promising working for a few years
in the same company as a digital
marketing executive I switched to a new
role as a digital marketing manager keep
learning so without any further Ado
let's get started by overviewing what is
social media marketing over to our
tutors
welcome to Simply learned YouTube
channel and in today's video we're going
to talk about social media marketing for
those people that are not really
familiar with what social media can do
for you and for your business this is
the course that you want to want to
watch so we're going to talk about what
it is what you need to know where is
social media going how do you felt do
how do you develop your own social media
strategy and we will also do a quick
rundown of the most important social
media channels but before we start let
me introduce myself I am Mark kempman I
am your digital navigator for this video
and if you like today's video why don't
you like the video by clicking below and
also if you want to subscribe to our
Channel click on the Subscribe button
below we would love you to be part of
our community so let's get started are
you ready for this let's check out the
topics that we will be discussing in a
bit more detail
yep we're going to be starting with
discussing the trends in social media
what is happening where is it going what
are the most social media networking
platforms and what do we see happening
in the future we will also look at the
definition of social media marketing it
is important that you understand what
social media marketing is and what it
can do for you yeah and we look at what
they see the importance for your
business and you will also learn why you
basically can't go without social media
marketing these days yep so that's what
we will be looking out and next we will
be looking at how to develop your social
media marketing strategy yeah we're
going to look at a very simple five-step
process that you can follow to develop
your social media marketing strategy for
your business or for your personal brand
next we will be looking at the different
social media marketing platforms we will
be looking at Facebook at Twitter at
Instagram LinkedIn Pinterest
Etc and we're going to look at where are
they where are they what people are
using the platforms and I'll maybe cover
some of the cool features of the various
social media platforms that you can use
as a business
we will close this with looking at the
pros and the cons of social media
marketing there's lots of benefits you
can get from it but hey of course there
are some negatives to it as well and
then I will close with giving you some
answers to questions that I get asked a
lot when I run this social media
marketing introduction so that will give
you a full overview of what social media
marketing is and how you can benefit
from it for your own business or when
you are a um a freelancer for your
clients business or for yourself as a
social media expert or any expert that
you um that you are positioning yourself
as so that's the introduction let's get
going into the action so let me start
with a simple question
out of these four social networking apps
which one do you think is the odd one
out yeah we need to get Facebook
Instagram YouTube and WhatsApp which one
is the odd one out from a social media
networking app perspective
yep and the right answer of course is
WhatsApp because WhatsApp is a messaging
platform yeah and what is a messaging
platform do in between social media
platforms like Facebook Instagram and
YouTube well very simple the answer is
that WhatsApp and messenger Facebook
Messenger for instance nowadays are
considered social media apps as well
yeah so in WhatsApp you can communicate
and engage with your friends and with
groups you can promote your business in
there so they are fully blown social
media networks yeah just a little trivia
to get the the juices going so there we
have it so what I always do when I talk
about social media marketing yeah I've
um I'm talking about Trends from a from
a quite a generic perspective
I've been in digital marketing social
media from the very early days yeah I
was one of the first to demo the
internet when I worked in Silicon Valley
in 1995. yeah we call when the web was
launched in 1995 we talked about a
presentational web yeah you created a
website for your business to present
your business and that was what the web
was it was very much like one way you
could go on the web and you could find
any information that you like yep and
that you need it now in the early 2000s
we saw Web 2.0 emerging which is the
conversational web
it happened in the conversational web we
saw social media coming the episode was
Facebook was Twitter there were some
um some other social media networks that
no longer exist but it was all about
getting into conversations with your
clients or with um with other people
that share similar interests so that was
the conversational web and that led to
the growth the phenomenal growth of
social media
and then nowadays today we're talking
about web 3.0
yep and web 3.0 is what we call the
virtual reality web
Facebook bets heavily on the virtual
reality web through the metaverse it's
that important for Facebook that they
even change their name as a company they
are now called meta as a company so the
meta first is Mark Zuckerberg's Vision
to actually meet people in a virtual
world and you can see each other in this
virtual world currently probably still
with virtual reality glasses or a
virtual reality headset but where will
the future go yeah so instead of typing
text or sharing photos in your news feed
you're stepping into a virtual world
where you can meet your friends anytime
anywhere
so really exciting still a long way to
go but consider that web 3.3.0
and social being interaction engagement
is a core part for that yes social media
although social media website social
media platforms may come and go the
basic concepts of social media they are
here to stay
yeah social media has led to a
fundamental change in the Way businesses
engage with their clients yeah and how
they interact with their clients and
we'll get deeper into that when we go
into the definition of social media
marketing for now let's look at where we
are today with the social media networks
and I always use this slide for that it
is the most popular social media
networks worldwide by monthly active
users
and I want to emphasize the monthly
active users because that is what is of
Interest
I'm not interested in how many people
have subscribed to a network there may
be robots that have subscribed to it
yeah what I am interested in is that how
many people are actually using it on a
monthly basis
and you can very clearly see yeah
Facebook of course is the biggest social
media Network platform but if I look at
this slide I see three major trends
the first Trend I see is the sheer size
of Facebook
yeah because Facebook is not just number
one when it comes to social media
networks worldwide but there is also
WhatsApp on number three there is
Instagram on number four and there is
Messenger
um as well yes so you see the sheer size
of Facebook is enormous and they are
driving the changes in social media lens
although some of the Innovation may come
from other social media Networks
yeah the
um the big Drive is
from Facebook
the second Trend that I see here is if I
look at number two which is YouTube
yeah to me that says
video is one of the most important types
of content being used in social media
these days if I combine that with the
importance that Facebook gives to video
yeah there's no doubt that video is the
preferred type of communication on
social media networks and let's look at
ourselves yeah we prefer to watch a
video then read a lengthy article yep
with about a particular topic so if you
are not on a video in your social media
marketing strategy you're really missing
out on a tremendous opportunity
yep so that's Trend number two the
importance of video and the third Trend
I see is the importance of messaging AUC
number three is Messenger you see number
five is
um there is Facebook Messenger there's
also WeChat from China yeah so it is
very important these days to understand
that messenger is considered a key
social media platform and that
businesses use messenger in their
communication and the power of using
messaging in your marketing Outreach is
that it allows you to have one-on-one
conversations with your customers you
can reach an audience yeah you can reach
a big audience through Messenger but
once they respond you get into
personalized conversations
and that is how Facebook is seeing
messenger yeah as we're in messenger you
have your one-to-one communication with
your best sort of friends where on
Facebook platform itself you more have
like Community title style conversations
okay so another few things that you see
in this slide is to do of course the
emergence of the tick tock yeah you see
the presence of
um Snapchat of Twitter of Pinterest but
the main thing that I miss here actually
is where is LinkedIn on this chart
and if I look at the original graphic of
this charge you see that LinkedIn is in
there and remember LinkedIn May probably
have more than 300 million subscribers
but not all subscribers are actively
engaging and using the platform on a
monthly basis so from a monthly active
users perspective LinkedIn does not
feature on this chart and that is one of
the biggest challenges that LinkedIn has
yeah to get people to engage with the
platform
welcome back to all these social media
networks later where I'm going to give
you a quick overview of what it what it
is and what it does
okay so let's have a look at what social
media marketing actually means what is
it yeah and we got to put this in the
context of the definition of marketing
yeah I studied Marketing in the very
early days in the 80s and um my main
sort of Guru in marketing was Philip
kotler and over the years marketing has
sort of developed from traditional
marketing to online marketing but to
basic concept has not changed if you
look at the definition of marketing it's
the activity of creating
communicating
delivering and exchanging offerings
have value for customers
yeah so you supply you deliver you
exchange products or services that have
a value for your customers
so two very important aspects here there
is value and there is customer and that
is what we capture in the marketing
concept you put the customer at the core
of what you do
yeah because when you do that you
automatically will look at what value
are we giving to the customer
yep so take social media marketing in
that context
then the second part of the social media
marketing
sort of term is the word social media
what is social media when I explain
social media I'm using the three C's the
three C's of social media marketing and
they are content they're community and
campaigns
content is the fuel of your social media
content is the
um the currency of social media if you
have really good content that you can
share on the internet
you're using various multiple multiple
social media channels like Facebook like
YouTube or like video or like Instagram
or blogging you name it yeah people will
engage with your content
and then when people start engaging with
your content they may come back for more
content that you supply and they will
then become part of your community so
Community is a very important aspect of
your social media definition
with really good content you can create
communities
and then you can push that process by
running campaigns
yeah and a campaign makes it relevant
for businesses
because when you run a campaign you have
a goal for your campaign you have an
objective you have a start date you have
an end date
yep and that is what social media
marketing is it's all about running
campaigns
to develop your communities with really
exciting content
and then you put it into the marketing
context you do that if it's a customer
that in the core of what you do
yes so if I then take that to a
definition of social media marketing
is
very basic it says the use of social
media to develop a company's brand
increase website traffic and boost sales
that is what we call social media
marketing
yeah the most important aspect here is
that you need to have an outcome you
need to have a result which is customer
related
and that is where the sales element
comes in you do this to get the customer
to do something and in the end that is
buying your product or your service
yeah so social media marketing is not
the technical
combination of your social media
networks you had to
um to reach as many people that needs to
be a goal to it and when we talk about
marketing it comes down to selling your
product or service with a value
yeah so that HD
um kind of the call to action as it were
that comes out of your social media
marketing so keep that in mind
everything you do with your social media
marketing in the end comes down to
reaching your goals or achieving your
objectives of developing your company's
brand increasing website traffic or
growing your sales
now a big benefit that you're getting
these days in digital marketing and
social media marketing is data
is intelligence
is knowledge
in the early days of marketing the
biggest problem has always been how to
measure the success of your marketing
campaigns if I ran adverts in a magazine
how do I measure the effectiveness
if I do a PR campaign and they write
about me in the newspaper how do I
measure the effectiveness of that how
can I track that when somebody buys a
product it actually is as a result of
the pr campaign that I ran
so in the early pre-internet days yeah
we the only way to measure
customer engagement as it were were
through Loyalty cards or credit cards
yeah it was a loyalty card you had some
basic customer data through credit cards
you could track transactions but it's
very difficult to relate it to your
marketing then the internet emerged and
all of a sudden I could track traffic to
my website
yeah I could see how many people visit
my website are these people that visit
my website for the first time are they
returning visitors what are the most
popular pages that they see how long do
they stay on my website and are they
actually buying my products
yeah so that was a major advancement of
marketing in the early 2000s and then
when social media emerged it all of a
sudden became possible to measure
engagement
how many people are having conversations
with us I could even measure sentiments
are people positive about my brand are
they negative about my Brands I could
track the effectiveness of my marketing
campaigns
I could measure the effectiveness of my
advertising campaigns that I ran online
so today's reality is that we can
measure everything
we can measure clicks we can measure
transactions we can measure engagements
we can measure return on investments
yeah and we can now even take that a
step further through artificial
intelligence that we can actually start
making predictions how people may
respond to campaigns that we're going to
be running
so it's a very important aspect of your
digital uh your social media marketing
so as I mentioned earlier social media
is a completely new way for businesses
to engage with their customers
yeah you can no longer go without it
it's a new channel to Market it is a new
channel for engagement with your
customers it is a new channel to learn
it's a new channel to listen to find out
what's happening in the market so it's
now it's it's it's there in every aspect
of your business
and not only for the marketing
department it's there for the sales
department it's there for Logistics it's
there for the customer service
department it's there for the HR
department using social media for your
recruitment is a very important element
of social media marketing
yes so keep that in mind that social
media marketing is no not a fad it is
there and it's there to stay and it
touches every aspect of your business
now to summarize this there are three
areas where social media has changed
The Way businesses operate
first of all there is the connection
social media is a new way to connect
with your stakeholders
yeah and stakeholders in this case can
be customers they can be prospects
influencers your own employees using
social media for internal
and not only on a local scale this
happens nowadays on the global scale the
internet allows you to sell locally to a
global audience if you want to yeah so
you can you can
cover the world you can Target specific
audiences wherever they are so the
connection aspect the targeting aspect
yeah the the markets where you want to
sell your product is opened up through
social media and that is a big benefit
for business
the second area where social media has
changed businesses fundamentally it's in
the interaction site
it's not just about connecting with your
stakeholders you can also interact with
them and they can interact with you on
their terms on their preferred platform
and remember in social media land the
customer is in the driving seat if
you're not interacting with them on
their terms you're going to miss the
train
it's not about you don't liking Facebook
or LinkedIn
yeah as long as your customers are on
Facebook you better be on Facebook
otherwise you're going to miss the boat
yeah because if you don't interact with
them they will move on to your
competitors who are very likely engaging
with them
yep so it's the connection aspect it's
the interaction aspect and then the
third part is the customer data aspect
all of this yeah what we talked about
can be done and you can track every
aspect of your social media marketing at
a customer level
and it gives you the key performance
indicators like conversion ratios sales
ratios customer satisfaction ratios and
ultimately return on investment
and there are tools nowaday that let you
manage and track all these areas in one
conglomerated system
your HubSpot is for instance a tool that
you can use for that and they integrate
all your marketing and customer data and
campaigns in one system that you can use
for that
so now Having learned about these sort
of fundamentals of social media
marketing let's now have a look at how
do you put together your social media
marketing strategy how do you set it up
how do you develop it now with my over
40 years of experience in marketing
digital marketing and social media I
developed a simple five-step methodology
to set your business or to set up
yourself for social media and it's
called flirt
yeah and flirt is an acronym
flirt the first letter the f is for
focus
yeah and in the focus phase what you do
you look at various things the first
thing you do in developing your social
media marketing strategy is look at what
is your niche
what Market are you targeting
and the more you focus in your Market
your targeting your Niche the easier it
will be to reach them
yes so it's very important that you
focus on a very particular niche
once you've identified that Niche you
look at your positioning
why should they buy from you what is
your unique value proposition remember
the definition of marketing yeah the
value for your customer is key in this
and you put it in what we call a
positioning statement
you also look at your customers you
create customer personas
where you look at your customers and you
kind of map their interests their pain
points the typical questions that they
would ask so you get a good
understanding of your your customers
yes or you look at your Niche you look
at your positioning you look at your
focus or sorry you look at your
customers
yep and then you're going to ask
yourself why am I going to use social
media
yeah am I going to use it to build
awareness am I going to use it to drive
traffic to my website
am I going to use it to generate sales
am I going to use it to improve customer
service
am I going to use it to recruit new
staff am I going to use it to
communicate with my
um my employees
yeah so lots of reasons why you could
use social media and it's your challenge
to identify one or two objectives for
your social media
and then a very important aspect of your
social media marketing strategy even
your overall digital marketing strategy
what are the key words that you will be
focusing on
in other words what are the key words
that you want to be recognized
recognized for Google wants to know
Facebook wants to know LinkedIn wants to
know and it's all about repetition the
more often you use those keywords the
more those social media platforms and
Google will associate you with those
keywords when people search for them
they will then show you how you're up in
the search results we call this search
engine optimization or search engine
marketing
yeah so keywords is like a whole course
in itself
but it's very important part of your
social media marketing strategy in the
focus phase
so that is the F for Focus think about
your Niche your positioning who is your
customers why are you on social media
and what are your main keywords
the next is the L for listen
is so important
yeah we tend to talk too much
yeah where social media
can give you fantastic
listening opportunities
and when I say listen I mean read
articles online
listen on Facebook and on Twitter on
LinkedIn listen on Google
yeah watch videos listen to podcasts
there's dozens of ways that you can
listen online because when you listen
you learn
and when you learn you get better and
you develop
so what does that mean from you some
practical tips when it comes to
listening first you need to listen to
where your customers hang out
are your customers on Facebook are they
on Twitter are they on LinkedIn and
later in this session when we go through
the various social media platforms I'll
give you an overview of what type of
people are on the various social media
platforms
the next thing that you want to know
when you listen is who are your top 10
bloggers
or influencers in your Niche do you know
your top 10 bloggers do you know your
top Instagram influences
because you want to learn from them but
you may also want to build relation with
them
to use them in your marketing Outreach
you also want to look at the trends in
your Niche Google Trends is a really
useful tool that you can check to find
out what are the trends in your niche
and you're looking at your competitors
and your customers what are they doing
what are they talking about
yes so a very important stage and if
you're doing it properly you would
actually set up a social media listening
dashboard where you bring all your
listening channels together in one
dashboard
and then instead of having to go to all
those social media networks or websites
you let them come to you Inno reader is
a very good dashboard online dashboard a
free dashboard that you can use for this
we're then looking at the eye for
integration
yeah so you know your strategy you know
where your customers are you know which
social media Networks you're going to
focus on then you're going to integrate
them you're going to set up your social
media Networks you're going to make sure
the branding and the profiles are
consistent you're using your keywords
you're going to create your content
calendar
and you're going to set up your blog
blogging is very important in social
media marketing because it is the
easiest way to start creating content on
your website
and to start sharing that content
through your social media channels that
will then drive people back to your
website
yes so that is part of the integration
stage and then once you've got that all
set up you're then going to reach out
it's very important that you reach out
because if you're not reaching out then
people won't find you people won't see
you yeah the whole essence of social
media marketing is that you create as
many touch points as possible on the
internet for people to find you
know where they start engaging with your
content going back to your website want
to know more about you want to know more
about your content and you start
building a relationship that may then
turn into a sale
so reaching out you're going to start
sharing your content you're going to
repurpose your content so turn your blog
post into a video or into a carousel or
turn your video into a podcast or what
have you
yeah you're going to share other
people's content there's nothing wrong
with sharing content from other people
and you're going to run
campaigns
campaigns to push your content in the
channels
yeah and campaigns nowadays are no
longer sort of just posts on social
media it is a combination of organic
posts yeah where you just share your
post on social media could be paid like
pay-per-click advertising or it could be
influencer marketing style
um reaching out yeah so very important
is the reaching out stage and then of
course tracking is the icing on the cake
as it were when you track you measure
your online reputation you measure your
conversions you measure your social
media activity and engagement you're
meshing your Roi and you plan for your
next quarter
okay time to talk about the social media
marketing platforms let's have a look at
some of the most relevant ones out there
now but before that let's make sure that
you understand the essence of the social
media marketing platforms how do they
work very simple they all work according
the same concept what you do you create
an account on the social platform like
of Facebook for instance you fill in
your profile
on Facebook you put in a lot of data
about yourself on Twitter a little yeah
so you fill in your profile and once
your profile is ready you're going to
connect with friends or follow and be
followed
there are some platforms when you send
somebody a connection request or a
friend request request when they accept
your mutually connected like Facebook
and like LinkedIn other platforms like
Twitter and like Instagram when you
follow somebody doesn't mean that that
person follows you
yeah so we're talking about followers
and following as it were
yep and then when you've got that you're
going to start sharing updates
and you're going to check your news feed
where you will see the updates from your
friends
now as a business every platform enables
you to create a Facebook page or to
create a page
yeah and what you want to do you create
your page you put in your company
information you brand it to your company
branding guidelines and then you get
people to follow or like your Facebook
page
or your LinkedIn page yep and then you
start sharing updates and people that
liked your page they may see your
company updates in their feeds
and this is what we call organic reach
so you do a post as a business and then
the people that follow you will see your
posts on their personal news feed
now in the early days of social media
this organic reach could be 40 to 50
percent
which means that if you have ten
thousand
followers on Facebook so 10 000 people
liked your Facebook page five thousand
of those people would see your update on
their personal news feed which is
fantastic
and that was in the early days for
social media many Brands they spend lots
of marketing building huge communities
because it was a fantastic free way of
reaching out to your Market
nowadays things have changed
Facebook has been driving this yeah
Facebook wants you to advertise on
Facebook all these social media and
platforms they have to make money so
they have advertising sort of on their
platform and they want you to use
advertising so over the years Facebook
has lowered organic reach to less than
three percent
so again if you have 10 000 people that
like your Facebook page fewer than 300
people may see your updates in their
feed
and Facebook says hey that's the way it
is we offer you a fantastic marketing
environment and we need to make money as
well so hey yeah start advertise on
Facebook to reach your entire audience
and businesses Now understand that they
now know that social media is pay to
play
to reach your audience it's no longer
relying on organic reach you have to pay
to use pay-per-click advertising or PPC
but we're going to talk about that in
the next videos
all right so it's very important that
you understand this concept of how
social media marketing platforms work
so let's start with the first one the
biggest one Facebook with 1.9 billion
active users worldwide
fact is that over the years the younger
generation has left Facebook
yeah why have they left Facebook because
it's not cool anymore
yeah and their parents are on it
yeah so if you want to reach the young
teens
uh late teens early twenties don't go to
Facebook you want to be on social
networks like Snapchat or Tick Tock if
that's available in your markets now
there's still markets where Facebook is
enormous
yes so they are the leading social media
Network in your Market if that is the
case then of course you have to be on
Facebook but in general we can say that
the audience for Facebook is now a
slightly older audience Generation X or
Millennials it's still a really good
Network to reach these people
particularly when you talk about
consumer type products
now what does Facebook offer you as a
business to use Facebook has the
Facebook page that you can create to
reach your audience
nowadays Facebook really would like you
to use Facebook groups
Facebook groups is a fantastic area in
Facebook where you can get really good
engagement
and as a business you can offer a group
to your customers as a VIP area or a
product knowledge area or a pre-launch
area or just for your customers yeah
lots of reasons lots of areas where you
can use a group to reach your customers
then there's Facebook Messenger of
course that you can use for your
business where you can set up Bots yeah
so you can have sort of automated
conversations with your customers on
Facebook messenger and there is Facebook
live
don't ignore Facebook live Facebook
loves you to use Facebook live
the beauty about using the Facebook live
it gives you sort of Buzz and engagement
before the event during the event and
after the event
yeah we call this tent poll marketing
you can build up excitement leading up
to the event and after the event as well
and then finally of course Facebook is
betting heavily on the metaphors yes so
it's Mark Zuckerberg's Vision that
instead of engaging with your friends in
the news feed you engage with them in a
virtual world now the verdict is out if
this is going to work but fact is that
although we've been talking about
virtual and augmented reality for years
it is here now
yeah there's more and more apps becoming
available on your mobile on your desktop
that use augmented reality
and virtual reality I can now download
Ikea place I think it's called where you
just open up the app you pick a product
from the catalog like a table and then
you can just position the table in your
living room
yeah and then you can move it change the
color of it or whatever you're using
augmented reality through your um your
camera
okay so that is Facebook let's look at
the next one Instagram I love Instagram
yeah a lot of users from Facebook have
gone to Instagram
why because it is a visual social media
platform and it has
inherently higher engagement than
Facebook it's easier to reach the
audience not just your friends
yeah so lots of cool features in
Instagram one of the coolest features is
the Instagram stories
yep and people now spend more time on
the stories than on the the timeline
where they see the posts so Instagram
started as a photo sharing app very
simple you made a photo you put a filter
on top of it which almost felt like
you're a photographer and then you share
it with hashtags and you saw immediately
the likes coming in and people loved it
for its simplicity
and now it has grown to a fully featured
social media Network that businesses can
use to make their brand come to life via
photos and Via stories
the audience is slightly younger than
the Facebook
um audience but a more and more mature
audience is coming on there as well and
it's it initially it had very much a
business to Consumer Focus but nowadays
it's not just photos that you can share
you can share visuals I can turn a blog
post into a carousel of five visuals
yep and
um in that way share really good content
so very powerful and very useful for
businesses to reach the audience that
hangs out on on Instagram
all right so that is Instagram let's
look at the next one and that is YouTube
now YouTube of course is not just for
watching video YouTube is a fantastic
social media platform to build an
audience of followers
yeah it's a great platform to monetize
your video as well by enabling
advertising to be shown before or during
your videos a lot of video creators they
do that yeah and your YouTube has a
program for that if you qualify by a
number of views that you have on your
video a number of uh and then the size
of your audience you can participate in
this program and it is a really good way
to make money on you for many content
creators now check out our earlier check
out our earlier video on how to create a
YouTube channel to find out how you can
set up a YouTube channel and how you can
use YouTube as a social media platform
YouTube is great for brand awareness and
since it's owned by Google it's also
really helpful for your search rankings
both on YouTube and on Google Google
and there's lots of different videos of
course that you can make you have videos
that do well are typical videos like
how-to videos unpacking videos
Vlogs video blogs we call them review
videos live videos lots and lots of ways
to reach the video your audience yeah on
with video on YouTube
so the typical audience that uses
YouTube are basically everybody from
young to old but very important to
understand with YouTube that people are
there for a reason they search for
something they may search for
entertainment they may also search for
answers to their questions
which is different than the videos you
would have on Facebook for instance yeah
so Facebook is very good for brand
awareness where YouTube videos are very
good for
um for lead generation for instance and
for building relationship with your your
audience
good and very interesting social media
platform that emerged around 10 years
ago is Snapchat
they have around 300 plus million daily
active users
and let me tell you a bit about the
history of Snapchat Snapchat was a
response to Facebook's problems about 10
years ago in privacy
and not being cool anymore and
particularly the Privacy issue where in
those days a lot of people said who is
owning my photos on on Facebook yeah
um is it Facebook or is it myself so a
lot of people and that there's always
been a gray area
yeah combined with Facebook not being
cool anymore and you know how important
being cool is for the younger generation
yep so fata so two guys who came up with
the idea of doing something radically
different and they came up with a social
media platform Snapchat where posts
would delete themselves within 24 hours
they built a a user interface around
this which was fairly difficult to use
yeah but that was for a reason
gets they love to explain to each other
how it works and if it's complicated
enough then their parents won't be able
to get on it
yeah so kids love that idea it's too
complicated to use for my parents so I
really have my own social media worlds
yeah in Snapchat that nobody else has
access to so particularly the teens the
generations that was very uh keen and
they were very hot on the uh on Snapchat
so it was that new place for Facebook
users to go to and they grew ever since
steadily not huge but they are there and
they are a very powerful social network
particularly when you want to Target the
younger generation
now there are two major features that
they sort of drove into social media
lens which was the stories
and second the vertical videos
so you all know the concept of the story
itself deletes in 24 hours but it turned
um social media instead of sort of
scrolling through your news feed you
swipe from story to story much more
visual much more fun much more engaging
yep and you would swipe those stories
vertically and that automatically led to
using vertical video
and vertical video is a major Trend in
social media content yeah which is
picked up by
um by Tech talk as the main format for
uh for videos on Tick Tock YouTube have
short so all social media now networks
they now have stories and they have
vertical video as a key element yeah so
vertical video particularly for short 10
12 second videos which we call snackable
content is very important why would you
tilt your phone to watch a video why not
just use it vertical which is also a
quite an interesting
um sort of form factor to get a good
engagement on your videos
finally Snapchat has very Innovative
advertising features
yeah they have lenses they have stories
they have filters you can put a filter
over your face BMW had a really good
campaign to launch a new car where you
could place the car through a lens
anywhere that you liked in augmented
reality and you could actually put a
filter where you gave yourself a golden
face yeah so very powerful advertising I
think the the WhatsApp advertising
platforms is one of the best advertising
platforms out there it's also probably
one of the most expensive
advertising platforms of all social
media Networks
right so let's look at Twitter
I call Twitter SMS on steroids yeah it
was one of the first besides Facebook
one of the first social media platforms
that came out and it was a very exciting
platform when it launched
and Twitter relied heavily on celeb
celebrities using it to drive acceptance
on a global scale yeah but many music
stars rock stars actors they started
using Twitter and that drove the global
adoption of the uh the platform now what
makes Twitter so powerful there are
three aspects on Twitter first of all
you can retweet a tweet
yeah so when you send a tweet and I
follow you I receive your Tweet if I
just click on retweet it'll go to all my
followers yeah if somebody in my
follower base retweets that tweet your
Tweet can go viral without uh in in in
in minutes
yep and there's various examples of
tweets that went viral within minutes
yeah like the um which was it a selfie
tweet during the Oscar ceremony a few
years ago
yes so it is sort of retweeting is very
powerful
it also makes it instant yeah because of
this retweeting aspect news goes on in
on Twitter instantly and it shares to a
global audience instantly so that makes
it very very
powerful for news agencies as well and
for businesses a very powerful feature
of Twitter is the Twitter search
each tweet is indexed and you can search
in all the tweets you can search for the
very first tweet that was ever sent
yeah so that makes it a very powerful
for Brands to find content so Twitter is
really good for finding jobs for
instance because lots of businesses they
tweet about I'm looking for a marketing
manager or a web developer so if I
search for web developer hashtag jobs
that tweet will show up in my search
results
[Music]
had is that they did not keep up with
the developments in social media
platform functionality yeah so most
celebrities went to Instagram because
Instagram was much more visual much
better place for celebrities to engage
with their their fans so Twitter lagged
behind and in the last few years it
clearly repositioned itself
so it now is seen as a great way for
businesses to use as a communication and
service Channel with their customers and
for media companies to share the latest
news
so if you want to find out what is
happening in the world now or what
businesses are doing now or if you have
a problem with a product from a business
Twitter is the best place to be
and for you individual as I always say
you don't need to be on Twitter to tweet
but you must be on Twitter to find great
content to search
whether you want to search for jobs or
whether you're searching for
opportunities if you're a photographer
yeah and you in London for instance and
you go to Twitter and you search for
looking for wedding photographer London
you get a list of tweets of people who
are tweeting I'm looking for a wedding
photographer does anybody know anybody
yeah so extremely powerful to uh to use
for lead generation
right so what about Pinterest
Pinterest is a visual bookmarking
platform
it's very cool the concept is simple you
see a photo on the website that you like
yeah but you can then do you can pin
that photo on Pinterest in a board
yeah and you're not copying the photo
you're just copying the link in your
board so by doing that you can build
fantastic collections of visuals that
you like and want to organize
so I bought a house in Marrakesh a
number of years ago in Morocco and we
needed to design the interior so we had
a board with Morocco design we had a
board with Morocco riyads we had a board
with
um a tiling and what have you and we
just build up a whole collection of
ideas that we liked and then we got the
people that helped us in making the
things that we wanted and we could just
share them the links on Pinterest of the
ideas that we had worked really well
now because you can save those Boards of
course you can then share them as well
yeah so everybody can access your boards
which means that it becomes a great tool
for getting ideas and Inspirations from
boards from other people
so if you want ideas for home design or
your wedding or fashion Pinterest is a
fantastic place to get inspiration
another major benefit for businesses is
that you can put your product catalog on
Pinterest as visuals organized in boards
yep and then when people
find those products on in on Pinterest
and they click on them it will take them
to the catalog of your website where
they can buy your product so it's a
great way to drive additional traffic to
your website if you want to see a good
example for that go to the IKEA UK
Pinterest page and look at their boards
you see boards for small living room
ideas back to school Christmas holiday
celebrations and then you get lots of
ideas with um for instance for small
living rooms and then you click on some
of the products that you see and that
takes you to the
page on the Ikea catalog website where
you can buy the product
now Pinterest is very popular amongst
women amongst Millennials and it also
has very powerful advertising features
and then LinkedIn LinkedIn is serious
yeah I call LinkedIn Facebook with a tie
where Facebook is fun LinkedIn is
serious in Facebook you can get away
with a funny profile photo in LinkedIn
your photo needs to be professional
now if you go to linkedin.com
forward slash sales forward slash SSI
you get your Social selling index
and that is a score between 1 and 100 of
how good you are on LinkedIn
and you will see in the score in the
summary that our four components that
contribute to your SSI score or four
components that contribute to how well
you do on LinkedIn
so those four are your profile
yeah your activity level in connecting
with people
how much content you share and your
activity a level in building
relationships with people
yes so the better you do in those four
areas the higher your score your profile
of course is very important make sure
that your LinkedIn profile is as
complete as possible
now linkedin's biggest challenge as I
mentioned earlier is to get people to
engage and share content
so how does LinkedIn make money very
simple there are four areas where they
make money first of all they allow
people to upgrade their LinkedIn account
to a premium account where they get more
features
there is a whole section in LinkedIn
specifically for recruiters
yeah so a recruiting version of LinkedIn
there is a whole area for sales we call
this sales Navigator
yeah if you run a sales team that use
LinkedIn of course you want to keep the
customer data so you're getting a sort
of customer relationship management
system within LinkedIn when you sign up
for sales Navigator and then there is
LinkedIn advertising
LinkedIn of course is best for business
to business and it's really good for
developing your personal online profile
as long as you share content through
publishing articles and sharing uh
sharing posts
so I've been operational on LinkedIn
from the very beginning and I shared
lots and lots of content and articles on
LinkedIn and I got lots of business
coming in through Linkedin
yeah we're talking about serious amounts
of business that I did by being on
LinkedIn so you've got to be on LinkedIn
if you are in business
right now one thing that I will not talk
about here is a stick talk yeah we
haven't got a slide for that but bear in
mind Tick Tock although it's not
available in India
um Tick Tock is a very important social
media Network these days which derives a
whole new format of uh of engaging and
communication but more about that that
later
right so let's look at the pros and cons
of social media what is good and what is
bad about it the biggest the biggest
advantage of social media marketing is
that it can lead you to new audiences
yeah wherever they are in the world
whatever type of business you are you
can reach them through organic paid or
influencer Outreach
yeah influencer Outreach has become a
very powerful element of your social
media marketing strategy it is about
collaborating with for instance
Instagram users with many followers to
Market your products or services
so there's the pros out there and they
are far better than the than the cons
but there are cons it's not all positive
you need to be aware that when you are
on social media you are opening yourself
up as a business people can see what you
do they can see how you do it and they
can also see when you're doing things
wrongly yeah when you're doing things
not the way it should be done it's okay
when things go well but it can be
disastrous when things go bad as we say
it takes years to build a brand
but on social media you can ruin it
overnight
yeah there's lots of examples of that
um a really
big example was that you remember the
Chinese passenger that was dragged off
of a United Airlines plane
YouTube and Twitter were bombarded with
negative and cynical posts towards
United Airlines how they dealt with that
situation
but hey those are the cons and there's
in any marketing channel that you use
there are cons but the pros far outweigh
the cons that are there it is there it
is a fantastic channel to reach new
audiences yeah and it is only going to
get bigger
right so to close here are a few answers
to questions that I get often asked in
my social media classes
so let me start with giving you a list
of the questions and then we'll do
um the answer so what is viral marketing
All About Now marketing is considered
viral when it reaches the point where
it's being shared by the public
at large rather than just its target
audience
yes so when the
um you reach more people than you intend
to reach
yeah that could be through word of mouth
or through social sharing it means your
content has gone viral
yeah and particularly on YouTube you see
when you are running a campaign for a
particular Market but then the video is
so good that it goes well beyond your
target audience
yeah that is what we call viral
marketing what is earned media earned
media refers to positive reviews or
mentions in Industry Media or user
generated content and guest posts on
third-party websites
so it is basically when other people
talk about you
other people share your content
that is what we call earned media
what are some examples of social media
marketing strategies there is one famous
one which I can highly recommend you
have a look at it is from a company
called Blendtec yeah Blendtec sells
professional blenders if you go to
Starbucks and you order a frappuccino
they blend the ice cubes with Blendtec
blenders they are industrial grade
blenders they need to be very powerful
now nobody talks about blenders online
so they came up with a um an Innovative
campaign called will it blend
yep so where they created a series of
videos where they blend everything you
want them to blend like an iPhone
comparing that with the Samsung which
one Blends the fastest
they had a Facebook page with it a
website with it campaigns with it
through that campaign they managed to
grow their revenue with over 500 percent
a very powerful campaign the Dollar
Shave Club is another good example how a
small company an online company started
to challenge the big shaving companies
yeah who charge lots and lots of money
for shaving blades they challenged it
hey come to us and you'll
um buy shaving blades for one dollar so
really Innovative campaign how they did
that so how do you get started in social
media marketing
remember my flirt methodology
yeah Focus that is where you start think
about your niche what makes you unique
think about your customers think about
your targeting have a look at this
amazing certification in digital
marketing which is postgraduate program
in digital marketing so don't miss out
on this incredible opportunity take
action today and enroll in our course to
unlock the secrets of digital marketing
success click the link in the
description box and embark on your
professional growth and achievement
Journey now we talk about social media
marketing what are the channels used for
social media marketing how can we use
them it's really social media marketing
is a channel in itself so let's take a
look at the platforms involved with
social media marketing now there are
some really popular platforms so if you
can't tell just buy these logos then you
probably have not used social media
marking or or social media platforms
before or Taken part in social media at
all but you know one would like to think
that the majority of your users out
there today know what Facebook is what
the logo looks like what it does same
with Instagram which is owned by
Facebook LinkedIn B2B platform it's
YouTube great very popular video sharing
platform and then Twitter which is
considered microblogging but still
social media so these are the most
popular popular platforms out there but
there are hundreds of social media
Platforms in fact when we talk about
social media marketing it can be
anything from microblogging to video
sharing like YouTube to B2B networks
like LinkedIn to say bookmarking sites
like stumbled upon content sharing sites
like Reddit q a sites like quora so
there's plenty of different types of
social media platforms out there in fact
if you folks have any popular or you
think valid social media platforms that
these listeners here should really get
to know and understand and use then go
ahead and put that in the comments
section underneath this video I'm always
interested in knowing what social media
platforms are out there and what people
are using how platforms are trending
what's popular what's not and ideally as
a digital marketer where my target
audience is so these are the most common
but there are hundreds out there
hundreds so let's talk about the most
popular social media platform and that's
Facebook so Facebook has an average of
2.27 billion monthly active users now
that number is fluctuating because we're
talking about billions billions billions
of monthly active users and that
number's probably trending up 88 of all
users are on mobile so what does that
tell you that tells you that Facebook
has an app and the app is very popular
in fact I tend to use the app more than
I use the web page for Facebook okay so
I don't necessarily log on via the
Internet on my laptop I go right to the
app it's just easier easier to
disseminate information easier to add
friends comment respond Etc so it's no
surprise that 88 of all users use mobile
now 66 percent of mobile monthly users
use Facebook daily so a lot of recurring
users going back on a day-to-day basis
two-thirds so it's an addiction more
than it is anything else because what
Facebook is is really you're getting
information from the people you trust
care about like work with share a group
with share common interest with partake
in the same organization maybe have the
same running group same passions I mean
that's what Facebook is it's a
commonality amongst people and if you
build up a network of that commonality
it's going to be addicting to take part
in that you know the closest Network you
can ever get to is your family so if
your family's on Facebook then likely
you're going to be on Facebook
communicating with your family via this
platform especially if you don't live
close to your family or especially if
you don't live close to your friends I
know in the United States you know
people move a lot for work or people
travel a lot for work and so Facebook
bridges that gap between distance and
you you know you do feel like you're
part of somebody's life on a daily basis
being on Facebook so that's what makes
it The Addictive part so if you think
about it from an end user's perspective
it makes total sense now if you wear
your digital marketing hat you're
thinking hey two-thirds of monthly users
are using it daily and there's billions
of active users then whoever I'm
targeting has to be on Facebook now if
we look closer at the demographics we
could see that a lot more seniors age 65
plus are using Facebook so 60 plus
percent of seniors are using Facebook so
Facebook is trending older however 35 of
the audience is below the age of 25 so
it's not just trending up it's also
trending down so a lot of young people
are still using Facebook and then
Facebook you know is pretty evenly
matched between males and emails now if
I'm either slowly and old feeling older
or skewing younger on my target audience
and half female half as male then I know
somewhere in there whoever I'm targeting
is going to be on Facebook just based on
these numbers here so your demographic
is likely going to be on Facebook again
depending on your industry depending on
your product or service but considering
the number of people and how it's
skewing older and younger and everybody
in between Facebook has something for
everyone now Facebook allows for video
content so you could post videos all day
long so if you have YouTube videos you
can share those YouTube videos on
Facebook in fact video just like on most
platforms tends to provide better
engagement and the industries that can
really capitalize on Facebook tend to be
food and beverage news and media and
e-commerce meaning you're selling a
product Facebook has as you know plugins
and that allow you to really accentuate
what you're trying to sell when I say
that accentuate I mean really
incorporate an opportunity for people to
use the Facebook platform to not only
just engage not only to share but to buy
taking that process a step further so if
you're selling a product you can more or
less set up a a Facebook shop if you
will and sell your product there so
that's why it benefits those that are
are in the e-commerce industry selling a
particular product or in the food and
beverage industry now some of the most
like pages on Facebook spans across many
many Brands but let's just take a look
at Coca-Cola for example in Coca-Cola
just pretty much pinpoints everything
great about what you can do on Facebook
I mean you could see here they have
their opening page is a video and so you
can see they're posting different
content about you know this is is about
a grant how they're helping the city of
Atlanta you know they're talking about
recycling so to me these are
community-based posts so they're not
necessarily just pushing out their
product per se they're trying to use
Facebook to build up brand awareness so
a huge Fortune 500 company like
Coca-Cola is not necessarily just using
Facebook just to push e-commerce to push
a product they're out there you know
pushing what they're doing for the
community so this is a good example of
you know how you can really leverage
Facebook taking advantage of everything
Facebook has to offer and that means
brand awareness Community Building
you're sharing you know updated
information not only about the company
but in this case Coca-Cola is situated
in Atlanta Georgia in the United States
so you know what are they doing with the
community okay so this is a good example
of course it's a big example because
Coca-Cola is a big company they're
worldwide but the great thing about
Facebook is you can always take a peek
at what other companies are doing
whether you have a million plus people
liking your page or a hundred plus
people like in your page you can always
get ideas as to how they're leveraging
Facebook now if you do have a company
you can create a Facebook page for your
business just like Coca-Cola so you want
to be able to separate out your business
from your personal page and like
everything you do whether that's writing
a blog or creating a video you want to
have original content that's relevant to
your audience you want to use Facebook
for some promotion but every post
doesn't necessarily need to be promoting
your product or service you saw what we
just witnessed on the Coca-Cola page it
was about what they were doing to you
know benefit the Earth with recycling or
what they're doing in conjunction with
the with the city of Atlanta so they're
more community-based posts and so to me
that's original content positive content
that isn't necessarily pushing their
product per se now you could argue hey
it's Coca-Cola they have the biggest
brand in the world and that's true but
just think about your product and
service think about your brand if you're
trying to build brand awareness what
does your brand stand for and if your
brand stands for say the the globe the
ecosystem the environment then you
probably want to be pushing out posts in
that direction if that's what you stand
for as a brand then you want people to
know that because like-minded people are
on Facebook and those like-minded people
are going to be the ones who like your
page who engage with your content and
tell other people about it so you always
want to go original you always want to
be true to yourself and true to your
brand and then you could take advantage
of user generated content like sharing a
user's experience of using your products
so in other words if somebody's engaging
with you or they've posted something
about your brand and product you can
reciprocate and you can certainly post
something that is similar to what
somebody is doing with your product or
brand so that's a good way to create
some original content by taking
advantage of what the users have
generated so these are just some
examples of how to take advantage of
Facebook I mean there's lots of things
you can do on Facebook plenty of things
if we float back to Coca-Cola page you
know you can see they have you know
careers they have different videos they
have reviews they have community so
nowhere in here do I see an e-commerce
platform now if you are selling T-shirts
then hey you can put something in there
to help you sell that t-shirt but
Coca-Cola's strategy is hey what can we
do to help build up our community what
can we do to fundraise so if we click on
fundraise you can see they have you know
an N AIDS campaign here if you look at
simply learn just as another example you
can see what simply learns done as well
you could see they have information
about us they have different events they
have a community link as well and so you
can see what they're posting as well and
there you can see they're posting
visitor photos so there's lots you can
do on Facebook you can post polls you
can put your Instagram feed in there you
can add testimonials so there's a lot
you can do on your page you just gotta
get creative and take advantage of
everything Facebook has to offer be true
to yourself and before you know it I
mean you're gonna have you know a number
of likes on your business page as well
so some other tips about Facebook when
it comes to content you want to schedule
your content okay you don't want to just
continue to post back to back to back to
back you want to space your content out
and the another great advantage to
Facebook as I already mentioned about
social media marketing that's
advertising so Facebook owns Instagram
they have a great tool for communicating
called Facebook messenger and so you can
advertise leveraging Facebook Messenger
you can leverage Instagram and what you
need to do is if you go to Facebook's ad
manager and you create a campaign when
you go to create a campaign you're going
to click on placements and depending on
what you're trying to do let's just say
you're trying to build brand awareness
you can actually hone in on you know
Facebook you can hone in on Instagram
you can do a number of different things
within Facebook you have different ads
available to you from single image ads
to video ads to Carousel so you have a
lot of options and the biggest option on
Facebook when it comes to advertising is
your audience who are you targeting so
remember Facebook has old young and
everybody in between between men and
women and so you can specifically Target
interest you can specifically Target
gender and age a location so Facebook
really allows you to hone in on who your
audience is if you're advertising and so
that's the great thing about Facebook
they have a lot of users and you're you
have an opportunity you to hone in on a
segment of that user base now Facebook
also has metrics that you can look at to
really understand how people are
interacting with your ads how inner
people are interacting with your post so
let's take a look at that so if we go to
Facebook when you go to your page you
can click on insights and you can
actually see some insights on posts that
have been posted on your page you can
get insights into how many people viewed
it how many people liked it how many
people engaged how many people you
reached with your post can you have
information about videos followers
Facebook provides recommendations so
this is all part of Facebook insights so
if you're posting on Facebook Facebook
will give you feedback as to how you're
supposed to perform it now if you're
running ads on Facebook you can simply
just view metrics related to how your
ads are performing so you could see how
many people clicked on an ad how many
people the ad reached how much you've
spent okay you can look at it by
demographic you can even see cost per
result so you can get a lot of good
insights into how your ads are
performing as well so if you're running
a campaign targeting a specific audience
on Facebook you can look at the you know
stats and metrics surrounding that
campaign and again for your Facebook
page you have Facebook insights so if
you have any questions you know feel
free we have a video called Facebook
advertising tips and tricks so feel free
to you know take a look at this video on
simply learns YouTube channel for more
information about Facebook and if again
if you have any comments to share about
Facebook feel free to put them under the
comments section okay let's turn our
attention to one of the platforms
Facebook actually owns Instagram so
Instagram is a place where you can
actually promote your brand product or
service through the power of imagery or
video and so the average number of
monthly users on Instagram reaches 1
billion and 32 percent of all internet
users are on Instagram so a lot of users
using it it's very easy platform to use
you just the only prerequisite you'd
need your mobile phone so you open up
that app it's as simple as just
uploading uploading an image that's why
Instagram is so popular because it's
just a simple tool to use to go ahead
and just post an image with some
hashtags so 68 of all Instagram users
are women so unlike Facebook it does
tend to slant more on the female side
and 59 of the audience is a bit younger
between age 18 to 29 so Slants more
women and Slims more younger and so if
these particular demographic and age
groups tend to fit your target audience
then Instagram is a play I should
probably want to be for social media
marketing so as I mentioned content that
works best are photos or videos I would
always slant towards videos if you have
them available but photos you know the
rule of thumb is photos always tell a
thousand words a thousand stories a
thousand interpretations images are just
always the best way to go as well I mean
if you don't have the videos hey nothing
to be sad about if you fall back on
imagery so you can really put your brand
in a good perspective and a good light
by posting images and as you can imagine
if 18 to 29 year old women are on
Instagram you know that's skewing
towards a certain demographic but in
terms of Industry it is open to most
Industries but the ones that tend to be
most successful are Beauty food and
beverage and e-commerce now food and
beverage always tends to work well when
you have video and imagery like why is
beauty but e-commerce if you're selling
that t-shirt or shoe you know Instagram
allows the platform to work in a way
where people can purchase that product
right within the platform so that's why
it tends to work well with e-commerce
okay there are lots of channels just
like on Facebook lots of channels on
Instagram I mean some of the most
followed brands are Chanel Starbucks
Nike I mean if you have a product or
service that you want to push out there
then Instagram is the way to go just for
brand awareness if you're selling shoes
then why not take images of and photos
of those shoes and get them posted on
Instagram like I said it's very simple
to use all you need some hashtags to go
along with that photo of a shoe or photo
of that cup of coffee and Instagram kind
of takes care of itself I mean photos do
accentuate the product if you have them
so leverage Instagram if you're really
trying to build up some brand awareness
for a particular product some best
practices here on Instagram is you know
have a compelling bio a good profile
picture you know add a link to a landing
page and you know leverage emojis if you
have to so set yourself up nicely on
Instagram you know if you're in a
particular industry like food and
beverage follow other food and beverage
Brands like Coca-Cola like Starbucks
depends on what it is you really want to
be related to so just make sure they're
relevant get hashtags can't stress that
enough you know when you post a photo
there's some hashtags in there you could
see what other people are hashtagging on
Instagram and you can ride that wave of
what's trending or you can create your
own unique hashtag I'd probably have two
to three hashtags per photo and don't be
afraid to use both photos and videos
videos do tend to work well on pretty
much any platform they tend to work well
on websites and blogs so why not use
them on social media where people can
engage okay so videos and imageries both
work well on Instagram okay you can also
get shout outs from other influencers
you know plenty of influencers on
Instagram especially in Beauty
especially in food and beverage fashion
tends to be another industry that has a
lot of influencers so feel free to reach
out to them reciprocate see how you can
work together where they can actually
you know give you a shout out on your
particular product you want to keep your
Instagram account updated and you can
update those with Instagram stories it's
basically you showing off a particular
product you know over a span of a few
seconds or even a minute that's an
Instagram story they're very popular uh
easy to use you can even run contests to
boost engagement so for example if your
particular product is a particular food
like a hamburger you know hey post a
contest about you know allowing your
followers to post the best good looking
tasty you know Hamburger as an example
or it could be something else in terms
of fashion hey what's your best outfit
on a Friday night before you go out for
the evening you know there's always
things you can do to Spur engagement
especially on a platform like Instagram
where people like to post photos and
then I mentioned this earlier with
Facebook ads you can run Instagram ads
to give a particular post a boost so if
we take a little snapshot of what we
have available in Facebook ads manager
you can choose Instagram as the
particular platform so if you just want
to advertise on Instagram when you go to
your placements you could choose just
Instagram either the feed or the stories
okay so you can choose one of these two
options if you want to want to boost
your posts get some more eyeballs on
that it's a cost per click platform so
anytime somebody clicks it's gonna cost
you but you know just like Facebook you
know the cost per click tends to slant a
little bit lower it really depends on
what you're trying to post when you're
trying to post post it who else is
posting but hey the Instagram feed and
the stories could be a good option if
you're really trying to draw attention
to a particular product okay let's turn
our attention now to the bdb platform
called LinkedIn linkedin's a very
powerful popular business to business
platform okay it has 260 million active
users monthly and unlike Instagram where
Instagram Slants more towards women
LinkedIn Slants more towards men 57 so a
majority of the users are men but still
you have a lot of women involved in on
LinkedIn so a nice you know nice mix
between both genders 38 of the user base
are millennials you know a lot of young
people older people a nice mix from a
business lots of different business
segments different levels of business
different business Industries and
verticals are on LinkedIn so don't be
you know shying away from uh LinkedIn if
your demographic or target audience
tends to be older just because 38 are
millennials doesn't mean anything it
means that everybody's using it just
that means that hey you know more than
one-third of the users are millennials
are younger now LinkedIn is a B2B
platform so if you're in the business of
generating business leads then LinkedIn
is the place for you to go there's
opportunities for you to advertise on
LinkedIn okay there's also opportunities
for you to post lots of different
content on LinkedIn so content that
works on LinkedIn could be a Blog it
could be you know particular news
article you know tips and best practices
I've posted videos on LinkedIn you know
it's good for jobs there's a lot of
content on LinkedIn so if we take a
sneak peek at LinkedIn if I just go to
LinkedIn here you know and I just go to
my home uh the start news page you know
I could see the types of content that's
been posted so somebody just post tested
something with an image you know then
you got an article down here okay you
got you know an influencer like Richard
Branson posting so you got a lot of
different types of posts that you'll be
able to see and you know leverage if you
want to meaning when I say leverage if
you see somebody like Richard Branson
posting something hey stay fit and
healthy you know that's an image that's
something about not about business per
se but you know something interesting
and unique so you can see all sorts of
different types of content based on who
you're following on LinkedIn and who
you're connected to some things about
LinkedIn you always want to create an
engaging profile when I say engaging
first things first make sure it's
complete I mean there's lots of
opportunities to if you sneak over to my
profile here you want to be able to post
a lot of information about yourself so
about what you're affiliated with what
jobs you've held what groups you're
associated with what you're interest are
what certifications you have so you want
to be able to you know complete your
total profile you can create a company
page for your business so if we go back
to LinkedIn we can just do a search for
say simply learn and let's take a look
at you know their business page so if I
just do a search for simply learn here
so if I select their page you can see
just like your profile page if you have
a business page set up on LinkedIn you
want to make sure it's complete you want
to put information about the company
what jobs are available and you want
your company to associate with that
business page anybody who does you know
follow that particular business page
part of the organization is going to be
listed under people so and you want to
be able to post just like on your
personal profile if you have a business
page you want to be able to post unique
content I mean you can see here simply
learn is posting you know some of the
accolades that they have but they're
taking it a step further they're also
posting you know information about you
know upcoming events and webinars so
they're posting a mix of different
content and that's ideally what you want
to do on any social media platform is
mix it up and just like you can on
Facebook just like you can on Instagram
you can you know boost a post per se
okay so you can get that post in front
of some additional eyeballs now of
course you want to optimize your company
page for searches so it really does come
down to how many people are following
you but when you say when we say
optimize your company page just make
sure it's complete with some compelling
content and then increase the number of
followers you have so the great thing
about LinkedIn that I like the most is
that you know you can you know simply
look at other people if I go back to say
the home page you can actually see who's
following what and you know LinkedIn
does give you opportunities to connect
with people okay so if I go to your if
you go to your profile you'll be able to
see other people that have viewed your
particular page and you can connect with
them okay or connect with people who are
like-minded or similar or connected to
people that you know so LinkedIn does a
good job of presenting other people you
can connect with so it makes it easier
for you to increase the number of
followers so having an engaging profile
personal profile you know having an
engaging company page making sure both
your personal and the company page have
all the content necessary have all of it
completed and then increasing followers
posting unique content I mean that's
really the key to LinkedIn now again
with LinkedIn you can use different
media you can use videos SlideShare
presentation images and you can boost
content as I mentioned before you can
boost content on LinkedIn so if you want
to get that content in front of eyeballs
you can do that so let's take a look at
an example of a campaign and what you
could do on LinkedIn in terms of
sponsored content so if you go to
linkedin's campaign manager I mean you
have an opportunity put your ad in front
of a particular audience so really
depends on again on who you're trying to
Target just like Facebook which Slants
more towards personal linkedin's gonna
slant more towards business so with
LinkedIn you have an opportunity to
Target a particular industry a
particular company a particular job
title okay so you could Target
everything business related on LinkedIn
so you can go ahead and create an ad the
ads have imagery to support the ad and
so basically when you set up your ad you
set up your target you can choose your
placement you're going to be able to see
you know who it is you're actually
targeting and you can go ahead and great
thing about LinkedIn is you have
different ad formats and again you can
get really creative with who you want to
Target and just like Facebook you know
LinkedIn has you know some metrics that
you can measure and figure out how your
particular campaign performed by
Impressions by click click the rate even
conversions cost per conversions and how
many leads so LinkedIn has built-in
platform for measuring campaign success
and so the differentiation between
Facebook and Linkedin is really just the
type of demographics that you have to
choose from you know with LinkedIn you
do have you know different options
available based on business like your
job title or job level or industry or
vertical so you have a lot of examples
available a lot of options available to
you on LinkedIn in terms of advertising
okay let's talk about YouTube now so
YouTube has 1.9 billion active users if
it was a search engine it'd be the
second most popular search engine the
highest number of monthly active users
in decreasing order starts at the United
States Brazil Russia Japan and India all
big markets all like to use YouTube but
you teams popular across the world just
like Facebook where the app is popular
the app on for YouTube is very popular
so 70 of All Views are generated from
mobile so with YouTube being a video
platform you'd never definitely need
videos now there's a lot of Industries
on YouTube a lot of Industries in some
of the most successful brands on YouTube
you know range from logo to Coca-Cola
you know pretty much to every brand if
you're a brand you want to be on YouTube
because of the massive reach that
YouTube has to offer coupled with video
and how great video is in terms of
Engagement it's a just a great
combination okay so some best practices
here for YouTube you want to optimize
your video for SEO to get views and so
we have a video that we've created at
simply learn how to rank YouTube videos
so if you watch that video you'll get
some really good tips and strategies
about how to you know optimize your
video for YouTube the very least you
want to make sure that you know using
right the right keywords and the title
description and hashtags so that's a
start when we talk about optimizing your
videos you want to upload regularly and
fix the schedule for your videos because
if you're starting to get followers on
YouTube or subscribers they're going to
expect you to produce more video
especially if you're producing engaging
unique relevant content for that target
audience so we're not saying you have to
have a video once a day or once a week
start small and build up and get on a
regular schedule and then you can
organize your videos in the playlist so
you know if we look at simply learn you
know simply learn does a good job of
organizing their videos into a playlist
so all you have to do is go to phone
simply learns a YouTube channel and you
can see how it's broken down into
playlists now YouTube also has the
ability because it is global you do have
the ability to provide translations so
if your target audience is from another
country it probably wouldn't be a bad
idea like Facebook and Instagram or like
LinkedIn you can advertise on YouTube
you would just need to do that through
Google ads so with Google ads you're
going to say Google I want to advertise
on YouTube and you have plenty of
available options to available to you
anything from you know pre-roll to
showing up in the middle of a video to
showing up you know before or excuse me
at the end of a video all the way to
Native content marketing where you know
your ad is showing up next to a video so
you've plenty of options for advertising
on YouTube and then just like on
Instagram there are influencers on
YouTube you know feel free to reach out
to these influencers and see if you can
collaborate in some way where maybe you
post their video on your channel they
post your video on their Channel and
vice versa so you want to be able to
maybe collaborate somehow to get some
views on your video okay let's talk
about Twitter now so Twitter is a micro
blogging platform and so when I say
micro blogging I mean Limited in
characters Limited in how much you can
actually post but it's very popular it
has 326 million active users per month
and it does tend to slant a lot towards
Millennials a lot of young people use
Twitter and a lot of people use it to
get their news so no longer are the days
of grabbing that newspaper no longer the
days of going maybe to a media news site
online you can quickly go to Twitter and
get all your news right there in a feed
and easy feed let's take a peek at
Twitter here you know I can get
everything from you know somebody
posting something specific about their
dog you know all the way to a particular
job you know all the way to Industry
news you know all the way to basically
an advertisement all the way to a
specific news article so it's all here
on Twitter in your feed so Twitter does
offer videos so videos do work well so
if I go back here you could see you know
here's a video of Antonio Brown he's
posting a video of his news conference
and another promotional video so
industries that capitalize on Twitter as
you can guess if a lot of people go
there from their news you'll probably
see a lot of news in media and
entertainment on Twitter so that doesn't
necessarily mean that you can't use
Twitter for your brand it really comes
down to target audience some of the most
influential brands are slanting more
towards you know news and media but you
know you got Cosmetics you got gaming
companies you got everybody's on Twitter
okay it just comes down to does this
platform have your target audience and
given the nature of Twitter you know how
can you get your particular brand
product or service out there and so many
characters okay some other advantages
and best practices you could use on
Twitter so I would recommend
implementing Twitter cards and really
all Twitter cards does is allow you to
attach Rich photos or videos and
different media experiences to tweets so
when you can attach you know rich media
like videos and images to tweets it can
help Drive traffic and engagement to
your website all it's going to take is
just a few lines of markup to your web
page and then users who tweet links to
your content will have a quote-unquote
card added to the Tweet that's visible
to their followers so that's how it
works I would certainly look to get
Twitter cards implemented if you are
going to use Twitter as your platformer
choice for social media marketing so it
does enhance the experience for the end
user and because allows you as an
Advertiser or as somebody be leveraging
social media to really enhance your
Tweet and it just provides a better
experience for the end user who's
looking at your Tweet and so like
LinkedIn you can really take a look at
who's trending what's trending on
Twitter so Twitter makes it easy for you
to you know follow so here they'll list
a who to follow so these who to follow
are similar to what you've been posting
or similar to your industry and then
here you can look at Trends you can look
at what hashtags are trending and so if
you click on a particular hashtag you
can you know follow a particular you
know person who or an organization who
tweeted something so you always are
reminded in Twitter who to follow and so
it makes it easier for you to pick and
choose who to follow and build up your
following fairly quickly because Twitter
actually provides you with opportunities
on who to follow just like LinkedIn just
like YouTube just like Instagram gram
there are influencers out there people
who have a large number of followers who
tweet on a regular basis who tweet
original content who get high engagement
these are influencers and these are the
people you want to engage with so look
for those people on Twitter follow them
I mean the rule of thumb is if you
follow someone on Twitter you know
generally they're going to follow you
back so if you can engage and follow
influencers you have an opportunity to
see not only what they're tweeting but
the ability to communicate with them and
engage with them as an influencer so
maybe they can retweet one of your
tweets and get that tweet out in front
of their followers so you can advertise
on Twitter and the unique thing about
advertising on Twitter you can you know
promote your Tweet just like you promote
a post on Facebook or Instagram or
LinkedIn but more so I think than any
other platform is the use of hashtags
and so use appropriate relevant hashtags
I always tend to use a unique hashtag
but also depends on what you're tweeting
about if there's something that's
trending and again Twitter will tell you
what's trending in terms of hashtags if
it's something you're tweeting about
then go ahead and use that hashtag as
well you can have multiple hash tags in
a particular tweet and so don't be
afraid to use a unique hashtag along
with a hashtag that's trending because
the whole idea is you want your Tweet to
get noticed and then you can use tweet
chat or some there's some other tools
out there that are available to allow
you to find people to follow and these
people might be interested in your
product or service because you know they
could fit your target audience or you
can connect with like-minded folks who
are in the same industry or have similar
products or interest so tweet chat's
available for that reason and you want
to take advantage of these tools because
again with Twitter it's easy to build a
following but you want to build a
following that is going to engage with
your tweets so let's talk about what
tools are available for social media
marketing so when we talk about all
these platforms available to us okay we
talk about Facebook and Instagram and we
talked about LinkedIn and Twitter and
YouTube I mean those are popular
platforms but at the beginning of the
session I mentioned there's hundreds of
social media platforms out there and if
you're posting content on a number of
them you want to be able to organize
that content you want to be able to
organize it and schedule it you know
where it makes sense and when it makes
sense you want to stay organized and so
there are tools available to help you
stay organized tools like HootSuite
buffer or Sprout social okay some of
these tools are available you know at a
cost of a free trial or at a low cost
per month so regardless of whether using
a free version of one of these tools or
another tool not listed or you're
actually paying for it it's worth the
investment if you're going to partake in
social media mark marketing and even if
you're on one platform it's still worth
it to have a social media tool available
to help you schedule and not only do
these social media tools help you
schedule they do a lot of other things
too for example they help you measure
the engagement of your post so let's
take example of one of them like Sprout
social so if I go to sprout social here
I can see for a particular company I'm
able to see you know how my post and get
were engaged okay so I can see daily
engagements on particular platforms I
can also you know schedule my post so I
can go ahead and pick a time and date to
schedule them and so I can go ahead and
post something and put it in a queue to
be published for example tomorrow or
next week or whatever the case may be so
these tools do a lot for you I mean they
help you discover new followers they
give you in-depth reports they help you
stay organized and so to me it's worth
the investment to look at one of the the
toes listed here you know these are some
of the more popular ones to maybe even a
free version but regardless of how much
you pay and what tool you're using it's
still worth the investment just to make
sure you're scouting your post at the
appropriate time so you're not posting
something back to back as an example and
you're able to measure accordingly so
it's nice to be able to go into a tool
like Sprout social go to reports and
measure you know in one place you know
how Twitter's performing or how
Facebook's performing or how linkedin's
performing and so that's what's a lot of
these tools provide is nice reporting
options and nice scheduling options so
you can find more content you can create
by using these tools again you can
schedule efficiently analyze them and
you can use insights to improve your
campaign so a lot of these tools give
you nice insights to how the post was
actually engaged and you want to be able
to leverage that and some of these tools
if not all of them have so social
listening and social listening is
monitoring what's being posted out there
so what else is posted you can take a
look at and if it's something
interesting or relevant you can go ahead
and follow or take part in that
conversation okay so that's what social
listening allows you to do and a lot of
these platforms have that as a feature
when we think about the way that our
company or our brand or our organization
is represented to the world it's easy
for us to be focused in on things like
quality and credibility and whether or
not someone wants to buy from us but
it's also important to understand that
for a lot of consumers the very idea of
who you are is also important it's not
always just enough for people to know
the name of your company or product
they're interested in understanding what
the story is behind your brand and that
might be something like how you came to
be or why you exist or what your mission
is or it might be something about the
personality and sort of the lifestyle
that's represented by your individual
company now the story retelling movement
has been an area that we've really seen
a lot of growth and a lot of improvement
in the last several years in social
media with more and more Brands moving
towards this idea of sort of humanizing
their companies by telling the stories
that come out of the company itself out
of the use of the product or even out of
the consumer stories that you know share
how products benefit their lives or
again just what goes on in that
interaction and that dynamic between the
organization and between the customer
side of things now when it comes to
storytelling there's several different
ways in which this approach offers value
to a business and one of the key ones is
on the emotional side we've talked a lot
in the social sharing dynamic in some of
the other areas of you know the the
spread and the viral concept about how
emotion is one of the most powerful
things that impacts people's decision
making and engagement with a brand so
when it comes to creating that emotional
connection or leaving people with some
type of emotional response storytelling
is one of the most powerful ways to
impact that it gives you an opportunity
to sway the emotion of consumers in
terms of how they look at or view or are
receptive to your brand now another
thing that storytelling can really do
that adds a lot of value is the idea of
making you credible because a lot of
times the way we tell stories especially
when we're incorporating in true to life
examples or you know consumer stories
there's an implied credibility that
comes through that storytelling and
comes through those third-party
experiences that can help people feel
more secure about doing business with
you not just more emotionally positive
but actually feel that security of
trusting that what they think they're
going to get or what they're hoping to
get that there's going to be enough
follow-through and enough other people
have had a positive experience for them
to really trust that that's what's going
to happen now another area that
storytelling brings a lot of value into
a company is the in the idea of making
you memorable
because human beings are wired for
stories we are much more capable of
recalling broad ideas and Concepts and
emotions when they're communicated via a
story so if we give someone a list of
facts a list of selling points you know
a list of reasons why to do business
with you the ones that touch them
emotionally or that you know problem
solve those tend to stick with them but
a lot of the data gets lost but when we
put it in the format of a story and
someone is sharing what their experience
was our brains literally archive it and
categorize it differently and our recall
level goes up so again along with
building trust and along with creating
that that emotional impact the fact that
people are better able to recall the
information that's communicated to them
via that story helps make it a very
powerful marketing tool now in addition
to that it's important to keep in mind
that on average people tend to be
daydreamers in fact study after study
shows that if our minds aren't occupied
with an important task if we're not
truly focused on something we tend to
drift off and when we look at that
concept of daydreaming the average human
spends literally half of their waking
hours daydreaming we average 2 000
waking drifts per day with an average
length of about 14 seconds so you do the
math on that two thousand times times 14
seconds that's a pretty good portion of
our day where our brain is drifting off
but when they look at the brain's
ability to stay focused versus having
those drifts we stay focused during a
story if we're reading a book if we're
watching a movie if someone is telling
us an engaging Story We Are Better
equipped and better able to put those
drifts off and really stay focused on
what's Happening so that's one of the
other sort of scientific and concrete
reasons why that memorable Factor comes
into play when we present things via
stories now stories also allow us to
connect in one of the easiest ways
possible again because our brain is
going to be a little more focused on
being able to receive that message so by
using stories to spread your brand
message or to explain your offerings or
to demonstrate how they work you
increase the chance of keeping your
audience focused on you and giving them
enough recall that they can come back at
a later point to actually do some
business with you now think of
Storytelling from sort of the mindset of
how we meet and engage with other people
so in general when we're meeting up with
a prospective friend or a job prospect
maybe we're coming for an interview a
service workers even just a stranger on
the street any conversation that goes
past just hello how are you doing and
the cursory you know kind of polite
responses it tends to be a story this is
what we do when we meet we're naturally
wired to seek out insight and common
ground and information about who another
person is and in those those
interpersonal relationships the types of
questions we ask you know the words we
use they're indicative of the type of
relationship we want to build so clearly
if you know if you're single and you see
someone else that you know you hope
might be saying well that might be one
of the early questions you ask and then
based on whether you know there's a
romantic interest there you're probably
going to ask different questions than if
it's a interview Prospect for a job or
if you're meeting up with a you know
co-worker for the first time the
relationship that we're looking for
denotes the type of information we want
and that's one of the important things
for us to keep in mind when it comes to
storytelling is we also have the ability
to tailor our story to the audience so
we can put those different features up
front we can weave them in in a
different way if we're appealing to a
group of 60-something females that love
to sew versus a group of 20-something
Millennials that love whiskey tasting
it's a different message that gets put
together with different focuses and
features there's also different and
things that we're going to put forward
if we're proposing you know million
dollar contract versus a 25 impulse buy
that someone can you know click and
order online and have delivered the next
day now on the business side of this we
need to think about what the story that
we need is because a lot of times we get
so focused in business on getting the
conversion that we forget that sometimes
part of getting that conversion is
creating those emotions building that
credibility and trust you know helping
them have exposure to what's possible
and for a long time this has been done
through education we might put up videos
or articles that aim to educate and to
demonstrate the story side of it brings
that more social interaction and
environment into the mix and that's
something important for us to keep in
mind so a quote that I really love about
this concept that sort of lays the
foundation of why it's so important
comes from the chief content officer
over at digitas and he says the
challenge is clear by now intrusive
interruptive self-centered marketing no
longer works the way it once did and its
Effectiveness will only continue to
diminish in the social age because again
the way that we share information back
and forth with each other and the ways
that that messages spread it happens
differently in the social media age than
it did before when it was more
advertising focused and where marketing
really was more about you know pushing
the advertised pushing the message and
sort of the Don Draper style of you know
if you don't like the conversation
change the conversation and tell people
what you want them to hear because so
much marketing is now driven by
consumers through that conversation we
need to be able to approach it in a
different way now another side of that
is the idea there's a difference between
storytelling and story sharing and some
of it boils down to semantics but some
of it also does need to be kind of taken
into account when we look at how we
might put our message together because
semantically consider the difference
between telling and sharing so to tell
is to communicate information facts or
news to someone and spoken or written
word it's to order instruct or advise
someone to do something that second part
that I want you to keep in mind but to
share is to give a portion of something
to another to tell someone about
something especially something personal
it's a again it's a slight semantic
difference but it's a huge difference in
terms of our approach and I love this
Seth Godin quote that really pairs up
with that idea the best part of Show and
Tell has never been the telling part
it's been the showing letting someone
see and experience and inviting them
into that shared experience and that's
one of those things that makes the
social version of Storytelling really
more like story sharing especially if
you want to do it in a way that creates
that back and forth consumer engagement
story telling in its traditional sense
is more the stories that we've put into
commercials and advertising and there's
a place for that there's a place to put
that together in the social realm and
it's very important but the other area
that that we're just starting to kind of
merge into and that really needs some
exploration by Brands is that idea of
the social sharing where it really is
about engaging back and forth with your
audience and inviting them to be part of
an experience with you and with your
brand so ask yourself do you want to
tell your story to people or do you want
to share it with them and let them share
their story with you and how do you meld
those two together and what does that
look like within your particular company
or among your target audio
so now that we've laid the foundation of
why storytelling is so important and
sort of what type of impact it can have
the next thing we need to do is look at
the business side of telling your story
what does it look like to create a
narrative or something that's
representative of either your business's
story or sort of the lifestyle or
concept or ideas that you want to
promote to people now there's tons of
questions you could ask yourself to
start building your story but we can
focus in on a couple key areas as a
starting point to build from
and one of the first ones is the idea of
whether or not you have a Founder's
story now for a lot of Brands the story
of their founder is so interesting or
inspiring that it catches the eye and it
makes people take a second look at the
product so think of the companies that
are sort of iconic in terms of who their
their founder or their leader is so
whether that was Steve Jobs and the role
he played at Apple or Walt Disney and
the inspiration and the role he brought
to you know the entire Disney complex or
loads and loads of other businesses
there are lots of examples out there of
how the brand itself was so tied to the
person who was sort of leading the helm
that that became part of their story and
people were really interested in it now
we can find loads of examples of
different brands where the founder
really plays a critical role in
representing who they are now a great
example of this is Spanx the founder
Sarah Blakely has really embraced the
story but both of how she came up with
the idea which was basically she was
trying to fit into a pair of cream pants
for a party and they didn't fit quite
right and she knew that when she put her
pantyhose on everything seemed to lay
nicer so she literally cut the feet out
of a pair of pantyhose and put them on
and that's what launched the brand you
know she loves to sort of tell that
story but she also loves to tell the
story you know from her tagline of
putting her own butt on the line pays
off because the way that she made her
first sale to Neiman Marcus is that she
literally dragged the buyer into a
dressing room and she went in and she
put on a pair of white pants and came
out and said you know here's what I look
like without them and went back in and
put her pair of Spanx on under the white
pants and came back out and said now
here's what happens when I'm wearing
these and the buyer from Neiman Marcus
ended up placing a huge order and it was
the first major sale that she got that
put her in place somewhere so those
stories and sort of the yeah this is how
it happened you know this is literally
what a difference makes that becomes
part of the brand and sort of Sarah
blakely's Journey as an entrepreneur and
you know moving her way up into the you
know the Forbes list of uh you know
highest earning females in the United
States all of that plays a huge role in
how they promote the brand itself and in
sort of the
the storyline and the lifestyle line
that they want to promote to the people
that might buy the product
now on a completely differently themed
vein we have fast food chain Wendy's in
the US and Canada where Dave Thomas was
the founder and even though he's you
know passed away several years ago
he's still a critical part of the brand
and of the story because basically it
was the idea that A working class guy
makes good and continues to act like a
working class guy while building a
massive charity because it wasn't
uncommon even when he was CEO to see him
show up at a store somewhere and start
working behind the counter or sweeping
the floor somewhere he always played
that role that made it clear to his
employees that he wasn't above them that
he was one of them and part of them
and has a huge huge ongoing charity
effort for adoption because he was
adopted as a child and so all of that
plays Into The Narrative of Wendy's and
who they are and what their brand
message is and and the lifestyle that
they want to promote to customers in
fact if you if you go there now and you
buy a meal and you get your cup all of
the Cups have stories of kids when they
were finally adopted and what it meant
to them when they were adopted or you
know what their first experience was
having a new family so again that plays
into the story just because people are
interested in the start of where how it
came to be
so looking at you know what the stories
are from within your team and it doesn't
always have to be that founder story
sometimes it's just someone who works
there Post Cereal paired up with Burns
group and use real factory workers to
create a round of Honey Bunches of Oats
commercials and let's let's take a quick
look at what one of those actually look
like so you can kind of see the
storytelling in action here
I get out of
smell cookies as oh no you didn't smell
me I just got out of work that's honey
bunches oh that's all I said don't eat
me now
[Music]
another short simple easy stories
there's nothing complex to them they
more just make you smile and laugh but
they're the types of stories that come
from listening to the people who work at
your company from thinking about how
your company and their experience
impacts the world around them
now another question that we can look at
is does your company or group solve a
problem now this isn't about the reasons
you think you're great or the reasons
you think people should buy from you
it's about that unique way that you
solve an issue that consumers or on the
B2B side of things you know the the
buying agent is looking at that they're
trying to fix
now great example of this is Airbnb or
you could look at Uber or Lyft on a
similar vein allowing people to
experience travel
in a new and affordable way but also
letting you know owners or drivers earn
extra money
you know from something that might have
been sitting there empty anyways you
know that idea that when you're
traveling you don't have to stay in a
bland expensive hotel in fact when I
travel for business pretty much any
place I go I always book via Airbnb
because you know if I can have a bedroom
and a living room and a kitchen
especially for traveling as a family and
there can be you know separate bedrooms
as opposed to having my kids all stay in
the same room with my husband and I it
just makes sense but there's also the
story side of that of its different
experiences and that's one of the big
things that people talk about is how the
experience changes and even on the side
of trying to recruit people to put their
properties it becomes about the freedom
and the lifestyle that's enabled and
there's tons of examples on YouTube of
people sharing how you know leasing out
that you know their vacation property
the rest of the year when they're not
there you know pays for the vacation
property and more or you know the people
who now travel full-time because they're
able to lease out you know their
apartment or their home or something
else on Airbnb the story side comes from
the problems that are solved for people
now another great example of a company
that focuses on their story from that
side is Dollar Shave Club they basically
took a problem everyone complains about
and they made it go away you know the
idea that razors cost a ridiculous
amount of money that you always forget
to buy new ones until it's too late so
you're shaving with a dull Blazer and
it's just inconvenient so all of their
messaging focuses in on that idea of we
make it cheap we make it easy and you
know it shows up right at your house and
you don't ever have to think about it
anymore
and their commercials all tell the same
story with kind of a you know funny
modern Millennial focused way so let's
take a look at one of those as an
example as a founder of my own club I'd
love to know how does yours work Dollar
Shave Club presents what the fact it's
simple you choose from one of our three
great razors we'll give you a free
reusable handle and each month we'll
send you replacement cartridges for just
a few bucks that means you get to shave
with the fresh blood any time you want
which feels amazing
well I'd be locked into a contract no we
wouldn't lock you into anything that's a
relief how long for delivering I've got
a conjugal visit next week
well what if I don't have to shave that
often no problem after you sign up you
can choose to get replacement cartridges
every other month you sound like my mom
I like that
ew
what's this I hear about Dollar Shave
Club selling more than just razors you
heard right we make all our own high
quality grooming products like Dr cover
shea butter Boogie's hair gel and
big cloud daily face moisturizer with
sunscreen now you know what the fact is
up with Dollar Shave Club so join the
club today
[Music]
too many Brands tend to be so busy
putting content out on different
channels that they miss the need and the
value of having a centralized Hub and
what I mean by that is having one place
where all of the collateral that they're
creating for their social campaigns is
actually housed and accessible in one
centralized Hub and in general they do a
pretty good job with social media
they're active on Twitter they have a
YouTube channel they're on Facebook and
Pinterest and all sorts of different
places
so what happens is your target audience
can miss a lot because social media
efforts are scattered you know people
who find one type of content they don't
always know hey you also have a YouTube
channel hey you also have an Instagram
channel so they're not necessarily aware
of all the possibilities now if I
actually go into the Annie's website now
I'm going to find out about their grants
for Gardens program and I've been a fan
of Annie's for years but I had no idea
this program existed until I use them as
an example to go and pull screenshots
for this so it's important to keep in
mind that if you are utilizing your
social channels is a way to draw people
into deeper content on a site that you
own you have much more flexibility and
ability to pass them through different
types of content
now the other thing about having a home
base a place where your content on third
party channels points back to
is that then your social media efforts
help boost your overall marketing
efforts simply because of the way they
impact everything online so for example
if you're using your third-party
channels is a way to attract people into
deeper content on your site you're
pulling in traffic Focus traffic
potentially high volume traffic and
traffic that's emotionally invested
because if they've seen your content
somewhere and chosen to click into your
site they clearly have an interest it
also delivers links volume of links
topical links and credible links the
idea of social proofing so that has a
big potential benefit for you it can
deliver conversions it can be much
easier to get a conversion once you have
someone in an environment that you have
more control over than to get it out on
a third party Channel even as third
party channels are improving their
ability to get those instant conversions
you know when we look at things like
Twitter cards even while those exist you
still have more control over the overall
process and your ability to test and
refine it when it's happening on your
site and then finally this just a way to
deliver credibility because it lets you
get out on some of these channels and
demonstrate that knowledge and offer
that teaser content that says you're
here you're present and you have
something to offer
now one of social media's biggest Powers
is the concept of touch Point okay it's
important to understand that being able
to go and meet customers where they
already are and lead them back to you
that's where social channels truly have
their power yes it's also in the
connecting it's also in the ability to
drive engagement and get exposure but
those are your starting points to get
those conversions there's a lot of value
in inviting them back into a place where
they can engage with you on a deeper
level
the other thing to understand about
touch points is that the more times a
consumer sees your brand or campaign
mentioned the more likely they are to
engage with it again that's one of those
areas of true power in getting that
exposure through social media so if you
look at each of our little person icons
here and you look at the sort of ripple
effect circles that are spreading out
around them view each of those circles
as a post to a social media channel and
maybe the bigger circles are posted by
an influencer in a specific area and the
smaller circles are posted by you know a
friend or maybe a lesser known blogger
oh years ago with Candy Crush Saga which
was a huge huge mobile phenomenon here
in the United States most people didn't
know about it until a friend invited
them to play and most people probably
got half a dozen dozen maybe two or
three dozen invites before they took the
time to check it out it takes a lot of
exposure a lot of your friends sharing
the same video or linking to the same
news story before you finally cave and
go okay well if that many people think
it's worthwhile maybe I should take a
look at it so if you look at those
places where we have one person being
impacted by multiple Ripple effects
that's where we see the highest
likelihood of Engagement and that's
where having a good presence across
social media channels and good social
sharing across social media channels
gives you those touch points and those
ability to draw people into an
experience with your company
now most social media channels have
slightly different reasons for existing
again we mentioned earlier and we're
going to talk a little bit later about
the fact that it's important to
customize the way you put your content
out there so that it has the highest
likelihood of catching the attention and
being engaged with by consumers so if we
look at things like micrometias Twitter
and Tumblr it's a great place to sort of
connect and listen same thing with
forums but as we move down from say
forums to social networks now we're also
looking at building relationships and it
requires sort of a frequency of contact
and you can see that each of the
different forms of social channels has a
value to it and a specific thing that it
has the ability to accomplish now if
each of your social media efforts
connects back into your home base you
have the ability to pass consumers
through multiple support channels and
you can play each channel to their
strength to again create a better
experience where people can then come in
and engage with you on sort of your
owned media on the home base or the blog
or the area that you have created now a
great example of this of leveraging
touch points is a company called smarty
had a party it's a party planning site
they sell high-end disposable party
products you know plates and glasses and
things like that and they do an
excellent job of using blog content and
social channels to attract visits and
then leading buyers from the blog into
their sales process so for example you
can see here a Facebook post they put up
that talks about a new product that
they've just released they had a contest
that went with it and they gave free
product away for a couple people and
they linked into a blog post that they
put together that says here's how to use
this product to create favor or an
appetizer or something that you can use
at your next party now when you look at
the blog post they put up and you zoom
in a little bit you'll see that at the
bottom they had a link to go and buy the
product so they're using the Facebook
post and a teaser to draw people into
their website where they can give more
information get them more actively
engaged and then eventually push them
into that conversion funnel that's an
example of leveraging targeted touch
points on a specific social media
channel to draw someone into a home base
now let's see this approach in action
and how we can take one of the ways that
companies tend to use social media and
make a slight tweak but really make a
big difference in their ultimate impact
so an example here is Belvedere flowers
the small florist in the U.S that was
using YouTube to sell boxwood trees for
Christmas several years ago and they
ended up making a couple mistakes and
what's really interesting is I was
actually doing a webinar once where I
included them as an example and they
were actually on the call because it was
a florist webinar and they did end up
implementing some of these changes and
said it worked out really really great
so several years ago I was on Twitter
and I saw this tweet come by that said
boxwood trees are now available for
Philadelphia flower delivery your cat
will love them too it linked from
Twitter over to YouTube where there was
a little homemade YouTube video about
sort of the owner's grandson decorating
this little boxwood tree and then I
think they took it off to a relative
that might have been in a nursing
facility you know where they couldn't
have a full Christmas tree cute video
does a decent job of making me go hey
that might be really good for my
grandmother or my great aunt now there's
a couple challenges here
one of the big ones is that you have to
actually go and look for the links there
weren't there wasn't anything embedded
you know they didn't have the call outs
with the link starting to go buy the
product so you had to actually look
around and see if you could figure out
what the URL was or go back and Run a
search for it of course that's all
assuming you don't get distracted by all
of the you know up next or related
videos and run off down a rabbit trail
that you know 20 minutes later you find
yourself going oh my goodness why did I
even come to YouTube in the first place
we know that tends to happen there so
assuming you stayed focused and you
actually found that link and you clicked
into the site
when I clicked into the site there were
no boxwood trees and I looked all over
for boxwood trees I even used the search
function to look for boxwood trees and
most people don't tend to use the search
function they just go right back to
Google and they run a search again
but as I was clicking around I realized
that they actually had a Blog which
means they had the opportunity to write
a great post about the benefit of using
boxwood trees for aging relatives or in
small apartments and to embed that video
right there into the blog post because
by embedding it into the blog post now
they're removing some of the
distractions of being in that YouTube
environment and they're allowing me to
be in their blog environment where
they're controlling what the layout
looks like
on top of that they also have the
ability to put an image and an add to
cart and a call to action button right
there in the same blog post to lead me
into where I can purchase that boxwood
tree instead of making me hunt around
and look for it
now if you consider the difference of
making these slight changes and you look
at the before and after you'll see that
the way they had it set up I had to be
on Twitter
see that the tweet on Twitter click into
the video watch the video look around
for the URL to the site and you know
ignore all the other distractions on
YouTube click through to the site search
for the boxwood tree read all the
pricing and then click to order
now if you use this home base mentality
now when I'm on Twitter and I see this
link and I click I come into the blog
post and I can watch the video right
there on the blog post I can view the
pricing information right there on the
blog post and then I can click to order
that's two clicks instead of
seven different steps up in the first
one now if you know anything about
conversion optimization you know that
the fewer steps that you have the higher
the ultimate conversion rate so again
very very big difference and that's just
in the conversion process that doesn't
even count the inbound links the
potential for traffic traffic that might
click around to other areas of the site
and be interested in a purchase lots of
benefits to looking at it from this New
Perspective
now a final word of advice is that
social media provides an amazing
opportunity to make a connection with
customers it's great to get out there on
different channels and really engage but
you need to remember to invite them into
your conversion funnel and a lot of
times that's going to mean inviting them
into your site or inviting them into
some point of conversion activity that
gives you the ability to contact and
engage with them in the future greetings
everyone this is Rob Sanders with simply
learn and welcome to today's edition
today we're going to talk about digital
marketing through Facebook
so there's lots to cover so sit back
enjoy take some notes and feel free to
comment in the comment section
so let's start out with
Facebook itself
okay so Facebook obviously social
networking platform it's been around for
a few years but it's come a long way I
mean today on Facebook you can host 360
degree videos
uh you could sell products via chatbot
you could
basically be a News Network on Facebook
I mean we've all seen the results of
that over the past few years
internationally that's where people go
to get their news so it's really come a
long way in fact you know Facebook
basically has about 1.5 billion daily
active users that's a lot of people
engaging in the network
according to HubSpot the average user
spends about 60 minutes per day on
Facebook has an hour of 24
spent just on the social media platform
now a lot of people gravitate towards
Facebook a lot of different ages
demographics countries use Facebook for
again for various reasons but despite
all its use despite all this HubSpot is
reporting that only 48 percent of
marketers
think that their Facebook efforts are
effective only 48 percent is less than
half of marketers in other words are
frustrated with Facebook you know
there's a lot you can do with Facebook
and so that's what we're going to focus
today's session on all the things that
you should be doing on Facebook to
better engage with your users okay so
first thing we're going to talk about
is really setting up the perfect
Facebook page
okay so that's I think where a lot of
companies go wrong I think people are
just quick to jump onto Facebook as a
network just because their competitors
are on there somebody told them they had
to be on Facebook and then what happens
they get a you know 50 effort
output on the Facebook page with no
updated post no information no best
practices applied so
basically the old saying is garbage in
garbage out that's what you get when you
don't follow best practices or apply all
the best features Facebook says to offer
so really when it comes to setting up a
Facebook page you want to start with the
basics you want to have a good profile
picture first of all I mean if it's you
yes you want a picture of you but if
you're representing a company
organization you really got to give
second thought about what that profile
picture is going to be
you know obviously relevancy comes to
mind but you know is it in Good Taste is
it updated is it fit the brand
guidelines of the organization okay then
you wanna you know you can also
accompany that profile picture with a
cover photo so again
you ask yourself you know is the cover
photo outdated is it recent is it in
good taste
and I think this is where a lot of
people go wrong
and that's really adding a good
description not a dissertation by any
means but you know a short description
that just explains what the organization
or company is all about
you know just you know common sense but
you would think that uh adding a
description wouldn't be a big deal but
you know it is a big deal because you
want people to know what you're all
about
and you want to create a good username
for your page because that's a that's a
username people are going to hopefully
remember so you want to pick wisely
there you don't want something long
something that people aren't going to
remember or misspell when they try and
type it in
you could certainly add your page to
shortcuts and when you actually set up
your page you have several roles that
you can assign to people so my advice is
if you're going to operate a Facebook
page for your organization or company
add multiple people to the page to help
out you're not going to be able to do
everything on Facebook by yourself
unless that's your sole job 24 hours a
day because there's lots and lots and
lots of things you could be doing on
Facebook
so set up a role you can play the role
of admin but you have other roles that
you can assign to other people within
the organization you can assign editors
moderators
people to handle just the advertising or
you can hire just or assign an analyst
role to people who can go in and just
look at the results of your post
so you have various page roles that you
can assign on Facebook now the other
important feature when you're working
with a Facebook page is to customize the
notifications
okay you want to be notified when
somebody responds likes engages you want
to set up notifications for your ads if
you're running Facebook ads so there's
lots of notifications so make sure you
customize those so that you're in the
know on a daily basis okay and one of
their best practice that I don't
necessarily see all that often on a
Facebook page and that's adding a CTA or
call to action
so don't be afraid
to move people from the ecosystem of
Facebook to your website where likely
there's more information so add a good
call to action on the Facebook page you
can keep people within the environment
and ecosystem of Facebook or you can
move them to your website or blog or you
know somewhere else just add a CTA let
people do something when they're on your
page that's really the point of the CTA
so those are just some of the best
practices
for really setting up a Facebook page I
mean again there's lots of things you
can do we're going to talk about more of
those as we move forward but just doing
those basic things just making sure you
know you keep those photos and those
pictures up to date uh you know change
the description every once in a while
play around with the CTA you know just
continue to you know keep the page
vibrant it's like watering a plan if you
if you don't keep it updated it's gonna
die and people are going to recognize
that so you have your Facebook page you
do have an option
and if you want to reach more people on
Facebook you have the option of
advertising on Facebook
and so you have something called just
basically classic ads on Facebook so the
whole idea of advertising on Facebook is
again
if your goal is to generate more you
know likes on your page or maybe it's to
drive people directly to your website
that's basically what you can do that's
that's you have to pick what your
strategy is okay or your objective so
Facebook's going to guide you through
that process if you're interested in
advertising now the great thing I like
about Facebook advertising unlike say
paid search ads on Google is that you
can really hone in on your audience
you know it could be a specific
demographic or some a group of people
who have the same interests that you're
trying to promote
so the benefits of running advertising
on Facebook is you can really hone in on
who your audience is
you can also decide where to run your ad
I mean Facebook has an advertising
network if you will that includes
Facebook Messenger Instagram obviously
news feed uh email so there's a lot of
things that you can choose from with
Facebook so you want to be able to pick
and choose where you want to run those
ads
and Facebook advertising has multiple
types of AD formats anything from
yeah videos to to images
so you could pick your format test your
format you know the thing I also like
about Facebook advertising because
anybody who's seen my videos in the past
knows that I'm a big proponent of a b
testing So within Facebook ads manager
there are components to set up a b
testing on call to actions and so to me
that's a great feature of advertising
you always want to test what people
react to and so that's built into ads
manager
and of course when you're advertising on
Facebook you can control it all with a
budget so Facebook's going to let you
know you know basically based on who
your audience is where you're
advertising what your objective is
this is how many people you're going to
reach this is what they recommend on the
budget so you can go with a recommended
budget or you can just choose your own
budget the whole idea though Beyond
advertising on Facebook
is to really hone in on a strategy okay
why are we going to spend money on
Facebook
you know is it to generate leads again
is it just to generate more engagement
on our Facebook page so you really want
to give it some thought before you dive
in and start spending money when you do
make that dive and you do start
advertising again there's a lot of
things that you can take advantage of
with Facebook advertising
um
there's there's lead ads
you know basically allowing people to
submit a form right then and there
and there's video ads as I mentioned
video ads to me are probably going to be
the most effective and impactful of all
the forms of advertising because
that's what people want they want video
nowadays they want to be able to read
and listen and engage
you can run engagement ads you can
remarket on Facebook meaning Target
people who've already been to your
Facebook page or been to your website
you can do interest targeting meaning if
you have a group of people who have the
same interest as your organization maybe
that could be you know picking up
plastic from the ocean okay there are
probably a large amount of people on
Facebook who share that same interest
I know I do I have that interest so
there's always an interest out there to
be had and targeted
of course you have with Facebook you
have demographic targeting based on age
and gender and you have behavioral
targeting now behavioral targeting to me
is the Hidden Gem of Facebook so
for instance you could Target ads to
people who say purchased a piece of
clothing for you okay so if they
purchase you can retarget them based on
a previous behavior of purchasing a
piece of clothing I mean if you're
selling uh Health Products or beauty
products or pet products it doesn't
matter you know the behavior is all
going to be the same you can pick and
choose based on that behavior
so behavioral targeting to me is a a
good feature to take advantage of if
you're going to run Facebook ads
now another thing I like about Facebook
advertising is uh basically the use of
Carousel ads so Carousel ads are
basically multiple images or or videos
so instead of just running one video out
or one image ad you can put them
together and you can have I believe up
to 10. So within the same ad unit so you
can have a rotating
imagery if you will or Carousel of
images and so basically the what great
thing about this is It's interactive it
allows you to put more of your message
and more of your brand more of your
focus out front Okay and I found through
my experience at Carousel ads 10 along
with video ads tend to work really well
Okay so
just keep that in mind if you're going
to do Facebook advertising you know keep
some of these features in mind in terms
of Behavioral targeting demographic
targeting you know running lead ads or
Carousel ads
the other thing that you should know
about Facebook advertising is the use of
a Facebook pixel so what is that
Facebook pixel mean well it means that
if you want to drive traffic from your
advertising to your website you want to
be able to track that behavior and
that's what the Facebook pixel does it
allows you to basically track website
behavior when somebody comes from your
Facebook ad
so if you insert the Facebook pixel
directly on your website then Facebook
will be able to tell you in its own
reporting console what people have done
did they engage once they went to your
website did they convert meaning
download something fill out a form
submission purchase something okay so
keep that Facebook pixel in mind so if
you're going to run advertising on
Facebook
that's what you want to do you want to
be able to leverage that Facebook pixel
now let's switch over to some of the
other things that you can do on Facebook
and so if you have a large number of
followers a few are a popular brand or
even if you're trying to generate more
likes and more followers on your
Facebook page then you know a contest is
probably not a bad idea I mean who
doesn't like a contest so to me
you can run a Facebook contest right on
Facebook
you know very simple idea but you know
if you apply some of the best practices
it could really pay off for you so let
me just run through some of the best
practices and setting up a Facebook
contest
first things first you have to choose a
price so in my opinion
I think a gift card tends to work best
as a prize
um it could be for a specific store in
the United States you know targeted in
Walmart are always good or apple if you
want to really go higher end or just
something very generic uh maybe a 25 50
gift card to Amazon where you can allow
the winner to choose what they want
regardless of the specifics gift cards
are always flexible to use okay so it
ensures that entrance
of the contest have an interest in your
products okay which you know if they
have an interest then they're going to
be easier to convert into a sale so you
want to offer something that's going to
be of interest okay
the next thing you need to do is decide
what the users have to do to enter so in
my opinion you want to make it as simple
as possible but get what you need to get
so
do they need to submit a photo you know
I've run Facebook contests in the past
for some of my clients you know photos
always tend to work because that's what
people tend to do on Facebook anyway
they submit photos
okay so a little bit more behind the
photo is you want to capture something
along with that photo so to me an email
address you know tends to work that way
you have something of value along with
that photo that way you can leverage
that email later on down the road
whether you do email marketing or
Facebook lookalike or something of that
nature
okay so you have to decide what it is
you're going to ask users to do so keep
it easy but get something of value in
return so once you've made those
preliminary decisions build your
Facebook fills your Facebook contest
page so make the contest page simple but
exciting okay so that's the whole point
you want people to enter so you want to
have a tension grabbing titles you want
to use high quality images you want to
obviously enter in the prize information
and the contest information the this the
important dates when it starts when it
ends okay you want to have that
all-important submission form again that
goes back to what are you capturing or
your captions just name and email
address or you capture a name email
address City other information like
interest are you adding questions so
just be careful on the submission form
and then you want to be able to you know
have share buttons and allow Facebook
comments as well okay so
when you build your contest page then
you obviously want to promote your
contest I'd like to think that goes
without saying that you can use other
social platforms like Twitter LinkedIn
Instagram
Tick Tock to promote the contest on
Facebook you want to get people there
and participate yeah
another option could be running the
Facebook ads for the contest that's
probably not a bad idea so remember you
can use Carousel ads or or lead ads or
you know behavioral targeting or
interest targeting
you can use all those ad features I
mentioned a couple minutes ago to help
Drive traffic to that contest page and
get contestants so obviously you run the
contest you monitor the contest Facebook
has something called Facebook insights
built in right into Facebook's platform
so you'll be able to measure the results
of the contest
and then when the contest is all said
and done
well what do you want to do well you
want to profile the winner okay so you
wanna
let everybody know hey contest is over
so and so on and you want to share those
results on Facebook and other social
networks
I mean you can even create a video
showing the winner
to generate a little bit more excitement
you can send follow-up in fact I would
even recommend you send follow-up emails
to all the people who entered into the
contest okay thank them hey that gets
you closer to getting more sales okay
and then you could tease people with a
future contest
so
at the end of the day contests are
always a good idea
to generate more excitement more brand
more Buzz
um
now moving on from the contest another
thing that you could do on Facebook is
promote your post so if you're not doing
any paid advertising however you're
posting a lot on Facebook you have the
option to promote your post and so what
does that mean so basically it's a form
of advertising using some of your
organic posts and it just allows you to
allow that post to get more visibility
okay it allows you to Market it in the
news feed so more people can see it okay
so you choose your post you set a budget
and then the post is shared to a set
number of Facebook members okay and so
you could turn it on and off that
promoted post anytime you want okay now
from my experience
promoter posts are really good uh it's a
really inexpensive way to highlight a
specific post that you feel needs
attention so if you're posting a lot and
you feel that post is going to get
buried and doesn't get the visibility
that it deserves then consider promoting
it uh it's really in my opinion cost
effective now I know that's all relevant
but promoting a post definitely
generates a lot more awareness so if you
have really something important to say
and show then consider promoting it it's
it's really that simple it's just right
there with an opposed Facebook allows
you the option to go ahead and just
promote it with said budget the other
thing you can do on Facebook it's
sponsored stories
so really sponsor stories are just short
user photo and video collections that
can be viewed a few times and they
disappear after 24 hours it's it's
really similar to
users who operate on Snapchat
that's basically the concept behind it
it's just focused around Facebook's
in-app camera okay which you can overlay
with filters and lenses just like you
can on Snapchat
and you can add some visual effects and
tags and and also you can have fun with
it basically so a sponsor story is just
you know as allows you to manipulate
videos and photos to tell a more
complete story in a more fun way
basically so have fun with sponsored
stories on Facebook
another
thing that you could take advantage of
and this is something I would recommend
is using Facebook's open graph
so what is Facebook open graph so for
those that aren't familiar it's been
around a while I think we're in 2021 so
2010 that's how long Facebook and graph
has been around it's just simply a
protocol
and what that protocol does it extracts
certain elements from your page so title
images URL and other meta information
from your website okay and what Facebook
does is pull that information and that's
what they're going to display
and social post so it allows basically
your website to communicate with
Facebook and allow you to control what
information gets said and seen in
Facebook okay or which elements of your
page you really want somebody to share
regarding your website so that's
basically what a Facebook offering graph
is okay so that's something you
implement on your own website so moving
on from Facebook open graph you have
Facebook exchange also known as fbx okay
so that's been around a few years as
well I think 2012 is uh when it launched
and it's just a platform for advertising
Services two desktop users okay so
that's the key it's it's really for
desktop users it's not available on the
Facebook mobile app okay and it just
allows you to do real-time bid purchases
it allows online advertisers really to
place ads onto Facebook sidebar or
directly onto users timeline as they
scroll down
okay so it just allows you an Advertiser
to get your product out there a little
bit more
so you have sponsored storage you have
open graph you have Facebook exchange
you have Facebook advertising
promoted posts you have all sorts of
options available on Facebook
I think the key thing though to remember
when you're on Facebook
is to always provide value so what do I
mean by providing value so think of it
as value-added content and so
value-added content because that's
basically what you're doing you're
promoting or pushing content on their
platform you want it to be unique and
original
uh you want it to be exclusive content
or information that your audience really
can't get anywhere else
okay so that's the whole idea behind
value-added content
you know you can repost and rehash what
other people have written but to me the
whole idea behind Facebook is to write
something really unique that really
resonates with your audience okay and if
you can do that you're probably going to
naturally gain more followers and
generate more likes and engagement on
your Facebook page
okay the other thing you want to do
along with that value-added content is
really
in my opinion I've talked about this on
other
webinar sessions with simply learn and
that's really generating or leveraging
any social media platform like a sprout
social
um or HootSuite and why do you want to
leverage those is because it allows you
to really just create a Content counter
think about the content the value-added
content you're going to publish ahead of
time and it allows you to consistently
publish
at a good time and day and so you're
consistent with your publishing and your
schedule
that's the whole point Beyond using a
social media platform
if you don't not a big deal you can go
right into Facebook
just like clockwork and and publish when
you feel it's the right time to publish
I mean everybody's publishing schedule
is going to be different
everybody lives in different time zones
everybody every company's audience is
different
um and let's let's just face it that the
you know there's going to be
differentiation so there's not a set
schedule it's just what you're
comfortable with that's going to be
right for you and your audience
the key is consistency so and that's
where the social media platforms like
The Hoot Suites and the Sprout socials
come into play now a couple other things
you want to do
to take advantage of Facebook engage
with your fans meaning if somebody
comments
positively or negatively
go ahead and engage with them in a
positive manner
okay you know put some focus on
relevancy when it comes to your fans
okay so you always want to attract
people who have like-minded interest
always keep that in mind
now if you're trying to build more fans
and followers you could certainly use
Graph Search and basically all graph
searches is typing something in to the
feed bar and Facebook a keyword
basically and if you type in say coffee
shops or something of that nature you
know basically Facebook's going to allow
you to see you know pages that your
friends have liked uh friends who you
know live near excuse me coffee shops
who live nearby
um so it's going to give you some
feedback and other suggestions based on
that keyword or interest
so take advantage of the graph search on
Facebook to generate like-minded
or similar Pages it allows you to find
people that you can connect with on
Facebook
now the last thing we're going to talk
about
with Facebook is metrics
always my favorite subject for those
that have listened to me for a while
know that I am big not only on just a b
testing but on measuring data
and so of course just like you know
Google analytics or any other social
networking platform Facebook has its own
set of metrics and so I'm just going to
run through some of those metrics that
you should be aware of
and so we're going to start out with
engagement
so engagement is in my opinion probably
the number one metric you want to
measure within Facebook's ecosystem not
necessarily the most important however
it is at the top of the list okay
obviously conversions are always going
to Trump everything but engagement is a
form of conversion people are engaging
with your post or with your contest or
with a video and so that's really all
engagement is it's just a number of
times somebody took action on your post
okay whether they they liked it whether
they shared it whether they left a
comment those are all forms of
Engagement so to me engagement allows
you to really see over a period of time
over a period of post how well you're
performing
and you want to leverage engagement to
make adjustments to your post I mean if
you've posted say 20 posts on Facebook
and you've got no engagement then you
probably want to Circle back and think
about
what kind of post you're writing
are you adding value added content to
your relevant audience that's really the
key with engagement
okay reach is another metric reach is
just the number of times people have
seen your content on Facebook that's all
that's all it is
okay then excuse me reaches the number
of people your content is seen by on
Facebook so
so that's all reach is okay so reach is
a number that takes into account both
organic and paid okay so how many people
is your post really reaching whether
that be paid or organic okay and so
obviously that number you want as big as
possible so you're gonna probably start
out small but you want that to grow
because that's where the engagement part
goes in the more your post engage the
more people are going to like the more
people are going to connect with you and
the bigger your reach is going to be so
the other metric is Impressions and so
Impressions is basically the
divisibility
okay of your post okay how many people
saw your post that's impression
Okay so
you know if you're reaching 100 people
of those hundred people how many people
saw it how many Impressions did you have
now if it's a hundred you obviously want
100 if it's ten thousand you want ten
thousand Impressions so you want as many
people possible to see that post and if
they haven't and it's an important post
then remember you have the option to
remote that post and so that's going to
give you the Boost you need to go ahead
and and get more visibility for that
specific post so you can increase the
impression counts
now the other thing you want to measure
with Facebook is referral traffic so if
you're running a contest and sending
people back to your site where you're
running Facebook ads and sending people
back to your website you want to
leverage Google analytics or similar
tool to measure how much referral
traffic Facebook actually drove okay so
that to me is key if you're driving
traffic back to your website so always
keep that in mind okay how much traffic
is Facebook really driving and more
importantly of the traffic that's going
to my website how much of that is
converting so that's something you want
to look at
of course if you're running a Facebook
page and you're not doing any Facebook
advertising page likes or something you
want to keep a tab on okay how many
people liked or followed you directly on
your page okay obviously you want that
number to grow over time
again it goes hand in hand with the the
amount of content and the value added
content that you're posting on Facebook
okay so obviously with Facebook ads or
organic post on Facebook you have the
option of videos
and so if you're going to post videos
then you want to be able to see
retention meaning what percentage of
your videos were watched
okay and so to me that's important
because if I post a good video and it's
a 30 seconds
and I didn't get that many people to
watch it
then what does that say about the
quality of the video or if vice versa if
I have a two minute video and I have a
large percentage of the people who only
saw say 25 to 30 seconds what does that
tell you you need to kind of compress
that video down so retention to me is an
important metric on Facebook related to
videos and then obviously engagement
remember I said earlier that most people
like to engage with videos on Facebook
and so you want to be able to measure
the amount of likes shares or comments
that that video received so retention
engagement are both available
for videos on Facebook
and then rounding out the metrics when
you're doing Facebook ads
you're going to have some key metrics
that you're going to want to measure
okay aside from cost you want to really
measure click-through rate and click the
rate basically is just the percentage of
people that saw your ad and then clicked
on your ad that's all click-through rate
is okay so you want a very high click
the rate obviously if 100 people sell
your ad you obviously want 100 people to
click on that
okay the thing about Facebook
advertising is the cost model could be
cost per impression or cost per click so
if it's cost per click obviously you
want that number to be as low as
possible that's the whole idea so if you
get
100 people clicking on your ad
then
obviously if that cost per click is low
then you're not spending as much so to
me it's better to pay say 500 for 1500
clicks then say paying 500 for 250
clicks obviously the 1500 is a means
your CPC is a lot lower than the two
dollars you're spending for 250 clicks
at a cost of 500.
so that's the whole key here is to try
and run ads and keep that cost per click
low
okay so the other metric you want to
measure with Facebook ads is cost per
acquisition or CPA okay and basically
that just measures the cost based on a
specific action so if you're asking
somebody to fill out a form submission
okay how much did it actually cost you
an advertising dollars to get a person
to do just that fill out a form
submission okay if it was a hundred
dollars then you gotta ask yourself wow
is that high obviously cost per
acquisition numbers always need to be
low okay so if you're selling T-shirts
at the at a cost of say ten dollars if
your cost per acquisition is ten dollars
okay you're in trouble you want to keep
that cost per acquisition number as low
as possible so that's a key metric to
always keep in mind
for Facebook advertising
and then another metric to kind of look
at or keep an eye on is AD frequency so
how many times did people see my ad okay
so you want to be able to show your ad
probably at most two to three times I
mean if somebody's seen your
advertisement
five six seven times they're just gonna
ignore it and so to me those are just
wasted impressions and so you want to be
able to control your ad frequency the
number of times you want somebody to see
your ad it could be one time it could be
two times but you obviously don't want
somebody so you're at five six seven
times
otherwise you're just not going to get
probably much out of that
so those are all the different types of
metrics available in Facebook you know
heed my advice pay close attention to
the metrics that's going to tell you a
lot about how your Facebook page is
performing have a look at this amazing
certification in digital marketing which
is post graduate program in digital
marketing so don't miss out on this
incredible opportunity take action today
and enroll in our course to unlock the
secrets of digital marketing success
click the link in the description box
and embark on your professional growth
and achievement Journey
and we're talking about
advertising
we're going to talk about how businesses
use face we get fertility how the what
are the benefits they can get from it
we're going to show you with a demo on
how to set up your Facebook advertising
and we will close today's session with a
few do's and don'ts of Facebook
advertising but before we go into that
make sure that if you like today's video
or if you like the simply learn Channel
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
below and if you like the video feel
free to like it and share it with your
friends so let's get started
today's world has changed dramatically
when it comes to reaching your audiences
fact is that everybody is trying to get
the attention of the million of
prospects out there in the market
everybody is screaming try my product
try my product or try my product but
most businesses they now have to realize
that today's customer has changed yeah
today's customer is looking for instant
gratification they want a product now
wherever they are whatever their device
that they're using yeah and they can
prop they can Source their products from
everywhere in the world yeah but it is
your challenge to make sure that when
they are in the buying mode that you are
there to help them it's a new economy
out there it's a service driven economy
look at products like Uber or Airbnb
where a whole new ecosystem has
developed of people offering their
products their services to a global
audience in marketing terms we're using
a term called solomo standing for social
local and mobile
yeah when you bring those three elements
together of social media local marketing
and mobile marketing you stand a really
good chance to connect with your
customers at the right time
Google has summarized this in what we
call Google moments on average people
have a couple of hundred moments during
a day where they grab their mobile phone
to do a search on their mobile phone
they maybe want to buy something they
want to book something they want to
share something they want to learn
something all those little moments or
opportunities for you to connect with
your customer or your prospect and
that's your opportunity but that's also
your challenge to make sure that you are
there
when your customers are having those
moments when they scream I want your
products and there are plenty of
channels that you can use to reach those
customers yeah we know about social
media we know about your website there's
things like influencer marketing there's
email marketing and there's more and
more competition out there that are
trying to use those channels to reach
your audience but fact is there is one
channel that really stands out of all
these channels and that is pay-per-click
advertising
pay-per-click advertising is a well
established part of what we call the
digital marketing Trifecta and this
Trifecta consists as the word try says
of three components owned paid and
earned yes so the old is your own
website or your own social media
profiles and your social media pages
but owned is no longer enough you need
to supplement your own media with paid
media and this is what we call
pay-per-click advertising
and then the third element of the
digital marketing Trifecta is what we
call earned media and earned media is
where you can still use that powerful
um effects of public relations in an
online world or where you can work with
influencers to help you develop your
online presence and connect with your
audiences
but one of the best ways to start
getting to your audiences is to use
advertising
yep and there are various platforms for
advertising there is
um Google yeah there is Google search
advertising Google display advertising
and there is Facebook advertising now to
put these two in the context Google did
about 210 billion dollars of Revenue in
advertising in 2021 Facebook is about
half of that 115 billion dollars in 2021
and the most powerful models for
advertising are search ads and display
ads yeah so with search ads is in the
Google search which is what Google the
offers the display ads and video ads are
offered by Google and by Facebook
and we call this pay-per-click
advertising which means you're not
paying for showing your ad but you're
paying when people click on your ads
okay so let's have a look between uh to
this advertising in a bit more detail
you have Facebook advertising was
introduced on around 2007.
yeah so in 2007 it was launched by
Facebook
yep so but it has grown drastically
since then in 2011 ads were being shown
in the news feed yeah Google a Facebook
called it sponsored stories in 2012 ads
came on the mobile yeah mobile ads are
now considered the most powerful
um forms of pay-per-click advertising in
2014 a Facebook introduced a three-level
advertising structure which was very
much introduced by Google as well where
you have campaigns you have ad sets and
you have your ads and when you go in
setup and you'll see that later your
your ads in Facebook you will have to go
through these three ad elements
campaigns ad sets and ads to set up your
advertising on Facebook
in 2016 in 26 sorry in 2016 Facebook
introduced chat Bots and ads in
messenger which became a whole new area
for advertising for Facebook yeah
connecting with
um customers on Facebook messenger and
offering that for advertising as well
and in 2018 there was a whole range of
AD formats available on Facebook from
videos stories messenger Carousel
slideshows collections so a whole range
of ads to choose from when you start
your face setting up your Facebook ads
now what is the future yeah what does
the future hold for Facebook advertising
as you may have read
um that both Facebook and Google are
having a lower Revenue in their
advertising given the whole world
economic uh situation we're slowly
moving towards a a recession even yeah
Facebook and Google and Microsoft all
the big Tech players are feeling the
impact in that yes so that is one
Element now one of the other reasons why
Facebook's Revenue has gone down in
advertising HD tracking capabilities and
a lot of businesses they track people
when they visit their website and then
you can Target them with ads we call
this retargeting in marketing terms now
Apple has announced
um earlier this year that on iOS people
can say which is on the iPhone people
can decide to not being tracked yep so
that has put a whole sort of kind of a
um a a a a
different
set of Dynamics in Facebook advertising
on the iPhone and it is not as effective
as it was before that announcement from
um from Apple
so the future of advertising is all
about security it's about privacy and of
course in the end it all comes down to
how good are your ads how what is the
quality of the content in your ads are
you able to stand out from the crowd
yeah so those are the big challenges in
Facebook advertising now you have to be
aware that Facebook advertising is
completely different than Google search
advertising
you have to put it into a context Google
search advertising is what we call
intent based
yeah so when I have a question or I'm
looking for something or I need a
plumber I go to Google Search yeah and I
search for plumber near me and Google
will give me some ads with plumbers near
me
that is not the way Facebook advertising
Works Facebook advertising yeah is not
intent based it is basically it is your
challenge when you advertise on Facebook
is to stop the user from browsing and
click on your ads so it's more
interruptive you need to make sure that
they stop what they're doing which is
much more difficult
yeah so you'll see that Facebook is
therefore slightly more challenging to
actually generate leads yeah to get new
customers
Google advertising is much better for
that but Facebook advertising is much
better to reach a global audience very
targeted yeah and work on awareness
developing your proposition helping your
prospects to go through the buying cycle
yeah so Facebook ads they help spread
product and brand awareness in the news
feed or on Instagram or on messenger to
a very specific targeted audience
now another element which is important
to understand when it comes to Facebook
advertising is to do with Organic reach
when I have a Facebook post and I do oh
sorry when I have a Facebook page and I
do a post on my page the people that
will like my that have liked my page
will see my post on their news feed
that's how the theory
is yeah of course not everybody will see
those posts because that wouldn't work
because then you would get way too much
advertising in your feed yeah so
Facebook is very selective in the number
of posts from advertising from
businesses or sorry from businesses that
will show on your news feed
yeah and in fact that percentage of
people that will see your posts your
business posts on their personal news
feed is less than three percent so again
if you have a Facebook page let's say
with 10 000 followers and you do a post
on your Facebook page less than 300
people will see your post
now businesses are not happy with that
yeah they said hey Facebook why are you
doing that I want to reach my entire
audience and Facebook says well hey you
still can yeah but it's going to cost
you some money
and Facebook says you have to go and
advertise on Facebook to reach your
audiences so businesses Now understand
that Facebook is what we call pay to
play
you to reach your audiences you have to
supplement your organic reach with
advertising
and the beauty about Facebook
advertising is that it is a fantastic
way to reach your target audience
and that is the biggest benefit that
Facebook advertising can give you it's
all about the targeting there is so many
targeting options in Facebook and I'll
show you when we go into the short demo
on how to set up your ads so what are
the reasons why businesses go into
Facebook yeah what are the reasons what
are the benefits that they will get from
it and the first big benefit that they
get is that they get access to an
audience which is out there
yeah and it is not just a small audience
we're talking about Facebook at as of
today as close to 3 billion active
monthly users that is a massive numbers
and most of these people they check
their profiles at least once daily so it
is a huge audience to reach and there is
no better social media Network to reach
a global audience than on Facebook
yeah so that is one of the reasons why
you want to start advertising on
Facebook the second reason why you want
to start advertising on Facebook is that
Facebook gives you a fantastic platform
to advertise your products to People
based on their demographics based on
their interests based on their location
based on their
um their history of browsing based on so
many different segmentation factors
which means that you can make sure that
your ads reach the Right audience
which is a really good benefit that you
will get from Facebook advertising
the next benefit that you get from
Facebook advertising is that it is very
cost effective
yeah you can just start with a small
budget you can slowly increase your
budget you can relate your budget to the
returns that you're getting from it so
it helps you spend less and achieve more
it is one of the advertising platforms
with the highest return on investment of
your on your money so very cost
effective to advertise on Facebook
here are some other reasons why
businesses use advertising on Facebook
it really helps them with increasing
brand awareness as I said earlier the
difference with Google search
advertising Facebook is not intent based
people are not searching in Facebook
looking for Content which could include
your ads they are actually browsing on
Facebook and it is your challenge yeah
to
um to be creative enough to make them
stop browsing and pay attention to your
ads so it really helps in increasing
brand awareness it's let it's an
opportunity for you to Showcase your
brand and to help them add value to
their lives so by doing that you
establish trust you establish
credibility yeah and you provide recall
value for your brand
so it is all about taking the customer
by the hand and helping them
in going through the buying cycle
yes so when the buying cycle is about
awareness is about building interest
yeah then building that trust that
they've then will turn into buying your
product
the second big benefit that you're
getting from Facebook is to Target
people that have already expressed an
interest in your service we call this
retargeting you may also have heard
about pixel targeting or pixel marketing
it basically means that if somebody
visits your website
yeah you can then retarget those people
with an ads
from a technical element as a
perspective it means that you need to
put Facebook or give you a piece of code
that you need to put on your website
and then as soon as somebody visits that
website that triggers that code it
automatically connects with Facebook and
then Facebook will capture that user
data that you can then use to Target
them with a specific ads
so a big opportunity there for the
retargeting but things will be changing
here in the near future yeah Google has
announced that by 2023 24 it will stop
enabling third parties to leave cookies
on the um on on websites yeah to Target
people so that whole retargeting area
will go and will undergo some big
changes in the near future and then of
course Facebook advertising can really
help you increase Revenue as I said
earlier it is a fantastic way to to
connect with people and take them by the
hand through the buying cycle you can
educate your audiences about what your
product has to offer yeah and the more
people know about your products the more
likely they are prepared to make a
purchase and to share their experiences
so lots of benefits that you get now
let's dive a bit deeper into this and
let's look at the different type of ads
that Facebook has available so first
there is the single image ad for these
are single ads single image ads that
have an option uh optional text on the
top and a link description that links to
your website and a call to action that
is very important to have a good call to
action in your ads the ad images they
need to be 1200 by 628 pixels
so that's where you have an opportunity
in the visual to stand out in the news
feed and make people stop and then click
on the link as you see here for instance
sign up
the next ads are the multi-product ads
they are usually carousels so it enables
you allow consumers to see all the
products or the services that you have
available they're very efficient they're
very Visual and they have lots of
creative options
um in them so they're very popular and
they're blocks being being used Lots by
by businesses so that's your
multi-product ads usually via a carousel
then of course you have your video ads
Now video ads are 30 seconds to two
minute ads and they are amongst
Facebook's most engaging most popular
ads they get about 10 to 30 percent more
views than other ads and not only views
also engagement why because people love
to engage with video when you engage
with video you have the opportunity to
touch emotions of people which is much
stronger in building trust building
relationships with your audience
a particularly video on mobile yeah
works really well so it's a high growth
area of video advertising and one area
that you definitely need to look at if
you want to be successful with Facebook
advertising
then you have the lead ads lead ads they
offer slightly different way to
advertise your products they let you get
usernames emails phone numbers actually
without leaving Facebook
yeah and that's what makes them really
powerful within Facebook advertising you
can actually create a sign up form or
you could even drive them through
Messenger and have a communication with
them to get their details through a
chatbot
so people don't leave Facebook you do
the whole process of lead generation and
lead capture within Facebook and it can
be easily synchronized with your
existing CRM system
then you have collection ads collection
ads blend video and product catalog
photos so they are really good if you
want to advertise multiple products at
once yeah if you want to do this so
collection ads work really well
okay so that's a short introduction of
Facebook advertising the benefits that
you get why people would use them why
businesses would use them and the
different type of ads so in the next
section let's go and have a look at how
do you create an ad what are the steps
to create a Facebook ad
so here you see I am on a Facebook page
and this is the page for Riyadh for
Russia which is a hotel in Marrakech and
I am the admin for this page
and what I'm going to show you on this
page is how to access the advertising
platform and how to set up your ads
yes so let me first before I do this
show you what Facebook is trying to do
everywhere whether it's your desktop or
your mobile to make sure that you go
into advertise creation mode yeah so
you'll see it everywhere promote
ad Center create ads create automated
ads boost post wherever you are you will
come to sections like boost post or go
please create an ad on the mobile it's
even more obvious yeah here is the same
page but then on the mobile device and
if I scroll down you see on the first
post immediately boost the post so
you'll see that Facebook is trying
everything to get you to advertise
yeah and I think it is a bit annoying
yeah but it's also you need to be aware
that all the various places that
Facebook will try to to hook you into
advertising they lead to various
subsections of the advertising platform
yeah so if I click here on Boost the
post it will take me to a what I call a
quick and dirty boost advertising module
yeah so I say I'm gonna good morning
from our rooftop I'm going to turn that
post into an ad yeah it I can
immediately suicide what goal do I want
for my ad do I want to add a button what
is the URL yeah do I want to edit the
image who is my audience yeah and then
what is the budget what is the duration
where am I going to show these ads and
how am I going to pay Bang Bang
boost post now
yeah so it's looks very interesting and
very effective to do this but what you
see here is you will only get a
subsection of what Facebook advertising
can do for you
yeah and if you think hey if that's okay
with you that's fine but you're missing
90 of the other features to make your
ads as effective as possible
in other words my advice to you would be
don't click on the boost a post button
on your mobile or your desktop because
again it leads you to a limited
functionality of the advertising module
and the advertising capabilities that
Facebook can offer you
so back to the desktop the same applies
here if I click here on Boost post
yeah there's nothing wrong with
advertising for a post you can take one
of your most successful posts or for a
video and you can create additional
reach for that post through advertising
but don't do it through the limited
advertising functionality again this is
a quick and dirty module everything on
one page and it will you can click boost
post now and it's an easy way to start
spending your money yes so that is
if you click the Boost post the same
applies if you go to the
create ads or create automated ads yeah
so let me show you the create automated
ads it takes you through a very
automated process of creating ads which
is great when you're a beginner
but again it'll only give you limited
functionality of what Facebook
advertising has to offer you
so my advice would be don't go to the
automated ads click on create ads that
again gives you limited functionality
gives it all in one page again you don't
want to do that
yep and then you click on the add Center
that gives you again a summary of the
advertising slightly more tools
yeah but it's all to lure you into spend
money in a very quick way
so then where do I go for my advertising
the place where you go ish to the
Facebook or how they now call Meta The
Meta business Suite The Meta business
Suite gives you everything you need for
your advertising it allows you to manage
multiple advertising accounts
yep and it gives you access to the full
functionality of what Facebook has to
offer you so let's go there The Meta
business Suite
hmm
so here you see
everything you need for your advertising
yeah so here you see it's your read for
Russia and it's not only for your
advertising you can manage your posts
here you can schedule your posts manage
your inbox your notification manage your
content manage your shop plan your post
now we'll cover all these areas in
future videos but for now we want to
focus on the advertising again even here
they have ads as a quick and dirty
method to create your ads again where I
want you to go click here on all tools
and now finally this is where you want
to go it gives you access to the full
advertising functionality to create your
ads to manage your ads to manage your
audiences to set up events when you want
to connect get data from your website
and where you can create your forms
this is where you want to go yeah so if
I click here on the ads manager
that takes me to the full advertising
platform
now here you see by the way turn off ad
blocker yeah which is important because
in your creation of your ads Facebook
will obviously
[Music]
simulate your your ads yeah but if you
have your ad blocker on the ads will not
show in the preview so it is important
that you switch off the ad blocker so
you create your browser environment
exactly as users will have in when they
they see your ads so let me go into
switching that off
which is more tools extensions you see
here my ad blocker is on so I'm going to
switch that off
yeah let me do a review
yes so here you have your account
overview you have your uh your desk is
your sort of your dashboard now you see
I haven't run any campaigns yeah so I'm
not gonna so there's not much to see
here in this and this this tool so let's
go here under my campaigns
yeah and this gives me the basic sort of
structure of your advertising on
Facebook
yeah and remember we talked about
campaigns ad sets and ads
yeah those are the three elements of
your
advertising campaign on Facebook you
create a campaign and I'll show you what
you need to set up in the campaigns then
within a campaign you can have multiple
ad sets and those ad sets within a
campaign inherit the settings of the
campaign
and then within ad sets you have ads
yep and Those ads they inherit the
settings of the ad sets and the settings
of the campaign
all right so you see here we have three
or two campaigns or three campaigns
there is a new leads campaign there is a
page likes and there is a traffic
campaign so now I'm not going to show
you these campaigns I'm actually going
to show you how to create a campaign
so let's go into that here is create
if you have experience with advertising
in pay-per-click advertising you will
recognize this approach Google ads has
it as well it is what we call guided
campaign creation
yeah so when you start your Facebook ads
and when you start your Google ads you
can select do you want an awareness
campaign
do you want a traffic engagement leads
promote your apps or a sales campaign
yeah and basically once the campaign
objective that you select will
set a number of the settings yeah
sort of specifically for that campaign
objective so it makes it easier to align
it with your business goals and the
whole setup will be done easier
yeah so here you see an awareness
objective so that is too good for Rich
for brand awareness for video views yeah
so it's showing the ad to the month to
as many people as possible who are
likely to remember them
traffic is to send people to a
destination like your website this is
really good to get link clicks to get
views from a landing page or get people
get into conversations with people on
Messenger or Whatsapp engagement ads is
get more messages videos views post
engagements it's good for Instagram
first messaging apps good for video
views engagement on posts lead ads or
collect leads for your business or brand
they're good for instant forms on
messenger good for conversions and to
get calls here is to promote your apps
like in app installs app events and here
is sales that is for your catalog sales
for instance
yeah we're going to do a simple one I'm
going to set up a traffic I want to
drive people to a landing page
yeah so here I'm going to click on
traffic yeah and I'm going to click
continue
so now I'm going into the campaign
settings so here you see the three
structures again the new traffic
campaign new traffic ad set new traffic
ads that I'm going to use
okay so here is my traffic campaign I'm
going to create a name which is I'm
going to stick with new traffic campaign
am I going to use any ads are there any
AD categories yeah so is it about
elections is it about politics is it
about employment about social issues
yeah I remember a few years ago there
was this Scandal when there was brexit
and the Trump elections or the in 2018 I
believe it was there was a lot of data
being sold by this Cambridge analytica
that they data they took from Facebook
and they sold it to the campaign teams
of the U.S election and of the brexit
yeah that had a big impact on privacy on
Facebook and on
um advertising for for elections and
politics shown and now Facebook has set
some extra sort of security guidelines
for specific ad categories
now what are the campaign details
here you see by default it is set as an
auction pay-per-click works on an
auction base and this is not a
pay-per-click course but basically it
means you will do a bit on your ad how
much you're prepared to pay for a click
yeah and that will then go into an
auction and that will determine the
position of your ads we want to get more
traffic
do you want to do a b testing yes and we
want Facebook to do that yeah or you
switch that off and what is your budget
do you want to create distribute your
butt set across ad sets yeah if you want
to do that you can switch that on and
then you have your campaign budget so
we're going to set a daily budget of 20
pounds yes so go back to the
phone setting yeah and then what is your
campaign bit strategy I just want the
highest volume and there's more options
you can schedule your ads so you can set
it at specific times my advice is to run
the ads all the time yeah particularly
in the learning phase when Facebook
launches your campaign it goes into
learning mode and then Facebook will see
by itself when your audience will
[Music]
will will respond and they will adjust
the ad scheduling accordingly so there
is your traffic campaign
details then we're going to your traffic
ad set where do you want to drive your
traffic to your website to an app to
messenger we want to drive it to the
website
now Dynamic creative is an important one
yeah do you want to want Facebook to
create your ads or do you want to do it
yourself when you want Facebook to do it
you provide creative elements like
images and headlines and then Facebook
will automatically generate the best ads
for you yeah so I kind of like that yeah
so I always switch that on on here you
see the schedule when do you want to
start
yeah so do you want to send an end as
well so that would be then let's say
November the 22nd and then here is some
more options you can set ad spend limits
and here is where the real meaty
sort of stuff happens in Facebook
advertising this is where you can select
your audience you can save specific
audiences
in the audience manager yeah so you can
have a number of audience if you have an
office in one country or another country
you can just hear select select the
audience for that particular country or
you can just create a new audience
okay so you can exclude audiences you
can set a location you can set the age
location let's look at that if I click
here on edit people living in or
recently in this location
people living people recently people
traveling in this location so this is
really powerful if you want to Target
people who are visiting a uh an event
like a football match or what have you
and you can include and this is where
you can search location you can in
search by City let's say London
yeah so London England or I can say
let's do prisons reading in England
yeah and I can even say uh give me
yeah so I can search location give me uh
rg7 I can do by postcode yeah so I can
actually people doing in the reading
area by postcode and I really like this
so if I say for instance
rg76 yeah so here you can see how you
can Target a specific area yeah and this
is particularly for your local marketing
is very important
yep so that is the uh the local
targeting is really good so you can and
then by the way here you see your
estimated audience size and when your
audience get bigger you see estimated
daily results as well
and then you can do more you can search
by
um where was this you can search by
detailed targeting by demographics by
interests and behaviors yes if I want to
people who like reading
Football Club
yeah so here is the reading FC soccer
team yeah so here are I can now sent an
ad targeting specifically people in that
particular area who lie and we have the
UK as well yeah so uh in reading and
that particular area who like football
who like Reading Football Club yeah or I
can
um other at other areas as well there's
also the suggestions if people like
reading they may also like these type of
things Neymar soccer or maybe they like
Manchester United yeah so this is just a
tip of the iceberg the whole
segmentation in Facebook advertising and
the targeting is extremely powerful
okay here are your placements for your
Facebook ads best is to let Facebook
decide where to place your ads but to
show you where your ads can be shown on
Facebook if you click on the manual
placements you see here they can show on
Facebook they can show on Instagram on
messenger and on the Audience Network
now what is the Audience Network Google
has said as well yeah in the display ads
which are ads that show on millions of
websites that Facebook has an agree or
that Google or in this case Facebook has
an agreement with so it shows your
Facebook ads outside Facebook
or millions of websites okay so that's
the Audience Network then if you look at
it here is the feeds where you're at can
she can show
your ads can show in stories and reels
your ad can show in stream videos
overlay and post Loop ads on reels on
Facebook search on messaging in article
apps inside so there is tons of places
where your ads can show but the best
thing is to let Facebook decide where
your ads are going to show
okay so these are your ad set settings
so let's now look at the ads
so here you see the Facebook page and in
our case it is the Riyadh for Russia
page
there you go yeah we'll make it you can
opt in for Branded content tools you can
look at the ad setup we can do manual
upload you can get data from your
product catalog and here you specify
what type of AD you want to show is it a
single image or a video or is it a
carousel
yep and then here you have your ad
creative
and your media and the select images
select videos and then here you have
your primary text headline description
your website URL this is where you can
do your url parameters when you want to
track your campaigns
yeah here you see the ad previewed at
preview is off and now it's on yeah but
of course I need to select media
so let's see
find images so here we're going to say
go to my website
and create an image for me approve
yeah so now it will actually show me
some images
select images yeah so here you see
images from my reacts
yeah that it picks up from my react or
from my website here's the website yeah
so let's take uh
let's take this image and we'll say
continue
yeah so
so selected destination link for your
ads let me see where we're going to put
that one
[Music]
there you go yes from now because I put
in the destination link you will see how
the ad start building but this is the
photo that I selected yeah now I'm not
going to show you the details of and I'm
not going to use as an example here I
just want you to show you the fields
where you can play and create your ads
yeah and then you see here in the ad
preview whether you see it in the feeds
there is a mobile preview as well
yep so you see here the feeds you see
here the stories and the reels how they
would look on Instagram the in stream
app and here in the search in article
and on apps
yes so there you have it that is your
traffic ads so we've now done our
campaign we've done our ad set we've
done our traffic ads and then basically
what you're going to do is you're going
to publish your ads
now when you're going to publish
yeah you can then go back to view the
details
and then you see that the ad is
um done and it is actually in review by
Facebook so if I now go back to my
campaigns
yeah let's close this one
you see here is the new traffic ads yeah
and you see here it's processing and
then here you see immediately the
details that you can get from your
campaign yes so you see the processing
you see the ad set name the bit strategy
the budget you see attribution setting
so basically attribution is how you
track the results of your ads
and then you see here the results in
number of Link clicks how many people
reached how many Impressions what is the
cost per result what is the quality
ranking the engagement ranking the
conversion ranking the higher these
rankings the better Facebook considers
your ads and the more and the better the
positions for your ads here you see your
amount spent and here you see the end
date of the campaign
yes so that is how you set up your
Facebook ads as a kind of introduction
to the Facebook advertising
yeah so if I now go back to all my
campaigns
campaigns yeah so you see here let me
see if I have some now you see there's
no none of these ads actually run or did
run in the past yes so I can't show you
the the results but we'll go into more
details at a later
um the later session on on Facebook
advertising for now this is I think the
best overview I can give you yeah and if
you want to get more than details then
we'll go in a more in-depth session of
the Facebook advertising
okay now that is all clear let's look at
the do's and don'ts of Facebook
advertising
what should you do and what shouldn't
you do with your ads
so there are various dues to first of
all make sure you continuously test your
ads
and the good thing is that Facebook will
do this for you yeah you can tell
Facebook please test my ads you can give
Facebook a collection of creative
materials a collection of headlines yeah
and it will actually mix and match those
headlines and it will use the ones that
will give the best
um the best conversions so it's very
important that you continuously look
yeah at your performance and see if
minor changes to your ads will lead to a
better performance
second make sure that your images and
that your videos are engaging remember
there is no intent in Facebook
advertising you have to be very creative
to stand out from the crowd and you can
only do that by making your ads
engagement or them by making your ads
engaging
in images and videos
so the not only the images or the videos
but it's also the messaging that you use
use a message that will stay with your
audience
yeah so it's the combination of the
visuals and the key message of your ad
that will make people stop
if by looking in a split second at your
ad yeah they get it
then they will stop and they will
click on the call to action so make sure
you use a message that is
powerful and effective
also keep it simple or we say kiss keep
it simple and stupid make sure that
people easily understand
the message that you're trying to convey
with your ads don't make it too
complicated don't use complicated
visuals don't use complicated messages
keep it simple
and make sure that you reach the Right
audience
yeah Facebook's biggest benefit is the
targeting you can Target
micro or micro level targeting people in
very specific areas
yeah so that is the dues and of course
there are don'ts as well so the first
thing is be sensible with your budget
don't spend your whole Budget on one
single campaign
yeah so start small and basically grow
your budget based on the results that
you're getting
yeah if you have to use visuals and
messages that are appealing then of
course don't make sure that you put too
much information in the ads again keep
your ads simple don't clutter them with
too much text and too many visuals
make sure that you proofread your ads
don't have typos in your ads there's not
a lot of text in your ad so please make
sure that you double check the quality
of the ads when it comes to the language
and the um the Cramer yeah so don't
forget to proofread your ads
be sensible in the activity level that
you have on your Facebook page yeah up
until a few years ago it was
it was actually promoted by Facebook to
do as many posts as you think are
relevant for your business people did
four or five posts a day nowadays it is
not about the quantity it is about the
quality so don't do too many posts on
your Facebook page be sensible think
from a customer perspective also when it
comes to your ads yeah so too many ads
or showing the same ads to the same
people all the time yeah may have an
adverse result
and then finally make sure that your
image relates to your product so don't
put up an image that doesn't relate to
the advertised product Instagram
followers the people who choose to keep
up with your content on the Instagram
they are like your own personal
cheerleaders following you through every
post story and update you share do you
want to boost your popularity on the
platform you need those followers they
are the key to building your audience
increasing your reach and showing the
word what you are all about whether you
are a business influencer or just an
average user getting more followers is
the name of the game on Instagram from
clever hashtags to paid promotions these
are plenty of tactics you can use to
grow your following and become the Talk
of the Town so get out there and start
building your insta fanbase everyone I'm
vaiba khandival and I welcome you all to
Simply learns YouTube channel
today we will be learning on how to
increase Instagram followers so first
let me ask you a question
that the Instagram get launched is it a
6 October 2010 or B 6 October 2011 or C
6 OCT November 2010 a d 6th August 2009
you can comment on your answers in the
comment section below now let's get on
with our session but before we get into
nitty-gritty of things let me take you
through simply learns professional
certificate program in digital marketing
or better known as postgraduate program
in digital marketing it is the
post-graduate program course by simply
learn in collaboration with Purdue
University and meta blueprint in digital
marketing this comprehensive program is
designed to equip you with skills you
need to excel in the fast-paced world of
digital marketing with this program you
will learn everything from fundamentals
of digital marketing to the latest
trends and techniques used by top
marketers worldwide you will explore
topics such as SEO sem content marketing
social media marketing email marketing
and much more
this program is led by Industries
experts who bring their real world
experience to the classroom giving you
an Insider perspective on what it takes
to succeed in the digital marketing
world
and with Hands-On projects and practical
assignments you will have chance to
apply your knowledge and develop the
skills you need to stand out in the
competitive field so if you're looking
to jump start your career in digital
marketing or take your skills to the
next level then simply learns
professional certificate program in
digital marketing is the perfect place
to start to learn more about the course
you can click on the link in the
description box below now without any
further Ado let's get started with the
agenda for today's session
we will start off the discussion with
various steps to increase Instagram
followers moving forward we will also
discuss best practices to increase
followers finally we will wrap this
session with the best tools to help get
more followers so let's get started with
a few steps to help increase Instagram
followers first up you need to lay the
groundwork you need to identify your
ideal Instagram customers and create a
plan you can include keywords in the in
your profile and bio next you need to
create some interesting and engaging
content we have to craft a stunning
Instagram feed we can use lengthy
captions that are both engaging and
informative
then we have to make ourselves
discoverable
you can tag your location and other
relevant individuals in posts and use
hashtags to expand your audience
afterwards you have to be able to engage
with your community and build relations
you can start by collaborating with
similar companies and influential people
also you can interact with your
community and build trust and loyalty
finally you need to keep learning you
don't have to be afraid to use different
Instagram features and keep up with the
trends to stand out from others best way
to learn is to keep trying and keep
learning now let's check out some of the
best practices to keep in mind
in your Endeavor to increase followers
first up use relevant hashtags in your
posts and stories to reach a wider
audience
next
you need to post high quality visually
appealing content that resonates with
your target audience
then we have to engage with your
followers by responding to comments and
asking questions
then we can also collaborate with other
users particularly those who have large
or engaged following
then we have to use Instagram features
such as deals and Instagram live to
share more personal and interactive
content next we have to utilize
Instagram speed promotion options to
reach a larger or targeted audience then
you can also consider using Instagram's
explore feature to discover and engage
with user who are interested in similar
content as to yours
afterwards we can also use Instagram
stories to share behind the scene
content and give your followers a more
personal look at your life or business
then you have to also post consistently
but you need to be careful not to flood
your followers feel
at last you have you can use Instagram's
analytics tools to track the success of
your posts and adjust your strategy
accordingly finally let's close this
session with the best tools to help get
more followers the First Tool in your
agenda is plan a pie
this tool allows you to schedule and
publish your post as well as analyze
their performance
the next tool we have is hoodsuit
this tool offers a variety of features
including the ability to schedule and
publish posts engage with followers and
track Analytics
then we have a tool called later this
tool is specifically designed for
Instagram and allow you to schedule post
track analytics and find relevant
hashtags
after that we have boostgram
this tool can help you to get more
Instagram followers by providing a
targeted followers through paid
promotions
following that we have social B this
tool offers the ability to schedule and
publish posts engage with followers and
track analytics finally we have social
drift this tool helps you get more
Instagram followers by using artificial
intelligence to engage with users who
are likely to follow you in today's
video we are going to be talking about
Instagram advertising and Instagram
reels what is it what do you need to
know about um what ads are available on
Instagram how can you optimize these ads
for maximum performance and how can you
use Instagram reels to grow your
following even further now I am Mark
campman I'm your digital navigator for
this video but before we start if you
like this video click the like button
and if you want to join our learner
community on YouTube subscribe to our
Channel by clicking on the link below so
are you ready let me start with giving
you some interesting Instagram stats
that will show you that Instagram has to
be part of your digital marketing
strategy now Instagram is only 12 year
olds it is now the seventh most visited
website in the world yes listen to this
it's the seventh most visited website in
the world and it is the
um fourth most used social media
platform by monthly active users
1.22 billion
users every month their nines Instagram
is ninth on the Google's most Search
terms list it's the second most
downloaded app in the world on the uh
the app stores and Instagram is most
popular amongst gen Z population
generation Zed Generation X May skills
are the fastest growing demographic yep
and that takes Instagram into a B2B into
a business world as well India has the
most number of Instagram users in the
world and people spend more time on the
Instagram stories than in the Instagram
news feed telling you a lot about the
importance of stories these days and
Instagram story adds they generate about
25 of Instagram's advertising Revenue
now do you need any more facts to
convince you that Instagram is one of
the most popular social media networks
and that it has to be part of your
digital marketing strategy so let's dive
a bit deeper into the Instagram
advertising opportunities and the reels
that you can use in Instagram so in this
session we are going to be talking about
Instagram ads in digital marketing why
is it so important what are the benefits
that you can get from Instagram ads
we're then going to look at the
different types of Instagram ads that to
you that you have available I'm going to
show you some Instagram ad Types on
Instagram and I'm also going to show you
where on Facebook you can go to create
to create the Instagram ads we're then
going to dig into the Instagram reels
yeah it's a new feature about two years
ago it is kind of the um the the
follow-up from igtv it is Instagram's
response to tick tock success you have
an Instagram reels are short vertical
videos that are very powerful in the um
and used by many people these days so
we're going to dive into these we're
going to see the benefits that you can
get as a business for them and I'm going
to show you quickly where to go on
Instagram to set up these these
Instagram reels I'm then going to give
you a few tips on the Instagram reels
and then we're going to close off
today's session with some frequently
asked questions that I'm getting a lot
in the when it comes to Instagram
advertising and Instagram reels so are
you ready for this let's get started
let's look at Instagram ads in digital
marketing so let's talk about Instagram
ads and branding first why is it so
important to use Instagram advertising
for your branding well more than 25
billion businesses use Instagram to
promote their services and products
yeah so when they are all working on
developing their brand through Instagram
so 90 of the Instagram accounts they
follow at least one business on
Instagram and 62 percent of users say
that they are more interested in a brand
after seeing them in an Instagram story
so it's a very important platform for
Brands to connect with their users yeah
when many Instagram users they actually
use Instagram to research new products
and services and most Instagram users
almost more than 80 percent they say
they take an action after seeing a
product on Instagram
yes so no surprise that many brands are
active on Instagram yeah and on average
you can say that the brands do about one
and a half times posting every day yeah
so there's no doubt that Instagram
should be part of your business yeah it
is an effective tool for advertisers to
boost brand awareness and increase
engagement with their followers and
their customers and it's not only a
platform to Showcase your brand but also
a channel through which you can interact
with your followers and build customer
loyalty and then I'm not even talking
yet about the e-commerce opportunities
you have on Instagram by opening up a
shop by promoting your products on
Instagram so a platform where you
definitely have to be
so it can act as a new channel for your
business which can extend your online
presence
and when you are on Instagram you can
promote you can sell you can increase
sales of your business and you can gain
many many benefits from being on
Instagram and here are just a few of
them so you can keep up with what's
happening in the world so if many people
if everyone yeah billions of people are
on Instagram why aren't you so there is
the new Instagram shop feature that can
help you and your brand to get more
sales so you can open up a shop on
Facebook you can then connect that shop
with your Instagram and you can promote
your products you can tag your products
in your Instagram posts and that will
lead
to sales through your um your Facebook
and your e-commerce shop it's fantastic
for competitor analysis what are your
competitors doing on Instagram what are
they promoting what are they advertising
you can learn a lot about what works and
what doesn't work in the the markets
Instagram is also a place where you can
connect with your customers where you
can deliver customer service yeah so
it's not just offline or not just on
Twitter but you can use that on
Instagram as well
so
Instagram these days is a very normal a
very basic platforms and it's almost
like you're having your website
customers expect you to be on Instagram
as well these days so if you do that
properly it can help you in getting more
customers growing your online customer
base on Instagram and it can help you in
developing your brand to generate more
sales and to grow your online reputation
by setting the tone and the style of
your posts you can immediately develop
and present an online sort of identity
that you can then transfer into your
online reputation
another powerful aspect of that you have
with Instagram is that you can work with
influencers yeah there's many
influencers many Instagram
users with large followings they offer
their services to Brands to help them in
promoting their products and services
so that is not enough for you finally
yeah the virality on Instagram is very
very strong so if you have good content
good posts good stories Good reels you
can go very high and wide and far
through the uh the Instagram
um the Instagram world and many people
will view your videos and share your
videos so it's a platform you can no
longer ignore and you definitely want to
be there
so in 2020 a new style of post was
created which was called the Instagram
reels which is kind of the follow-up of
the igtv which was a kind of a vertical
video kind of YouTube channel that you
could get on on Instagram now it is sort
of a response of Instagram to the growth
of uh of tick tock and creators on
Instagram like Justin Bieber lizzo
Stanley Tucci they really helped to
transform this
um feature from a almost like a tick
tock wannabe to a full-blown competitor
of tiktok they are full screen vertical
videos that can be up to 90 seconds long
yeah they come with many unique editing
tools and an extensive library of audio
tracks as well so it's very easy to make
these short videos and to start sharing
them and you will see that the fuse and
the engagement that you get with these
reels in Instagram is extremely high on
top of the sound real can include
multiple video clips filters captures
and in an interactive backgrounds so you
can add stickers all the tools that you
expect in that you see in stories that
you see in Tick Tock you see that in the
Instagram reels as well now they're
clearly different from Instagram stories
yeah Instagram story they did disappear
in 24 hours once you post a real it is
available on Instagram until you delete
it so they are also favored by the
Instagram algorithm yeah which is more
likely to recommend them to people who
don't follow you yes so it is a very
good tool to grow your following but
we'll talk about reels a little later
when we go into the after we've gone
into the advertising on Instagram
so let's look into
um advertising on Instagram here are
some interesting facts about Instagram
advertising each month there are two
million advertisers active on Instagram
yeah so that is a big number of people
the estimated advertising reach for
Instagram users is
1.32 billion users
yes so there and that is an important
one the Instagram advertising reach has
outpaced Facebook advertising reach in
the last year so and did you know you
can reach 22 of the global population
age 13 or older in Instagram so a
platform an advertising platform that
you cannot ignore yeah and through
Instagram reels you can reach another
potential audience of close to a billion
people
so and interesting fact you know is that
the split in female and male is about 45
and 55 on the advertising audience for
the Instagram reels
so how do you create Instagram ads
through the Facebook advertising manager
yep and we've done a short or a video
about Facebook advertising in the um in
in an earlier video of this series but
um I'm sorry I'm not going to go into
this but I do want to show you a new
feature in the Facebook and Instagram
advertising advertising setup but before
we go into this let's have a quick look
at Instagram and see if we can find some
ads so if I go out of here and I go to
Instagram
yeah so here you see my mobile let's log
in and we're going to Instagram
yeah so by just by browsing through your
news feed you will already come across
ads
yeah so let's see where we see an ad
popping up
so here you see one yeah so Shahara
Services official and because it's an ad
you see it's a sponsored ad and here you
see the type of ad that we see here is a
photo ad just one photo that they have
with a call to action in this case visit
the Instagram profile
so here you see an ad yeah which is
again is sponsored but here you see I
can flick through the photo so this is
what we call a carousel ads yeah so
there are multiple photos or in this
case videos so you could also see this
as kind of a video ad but this is a
combination of a video ad and a carousel
ads where you can flick through multiple
photos so what I've done I've saved a
few
um a few ads yeah that is easier so I
don't have to browse so if I click here
on the saved and here you see some ads
yeah so here you see an example of a
photo ad but multiple photos and that's
why we also call this a carousel ads
okay here you see an example of us
another Carousel ads yeah so you can see
that it's an ad because it's a sponsored
again multiple photos and a call to
action yeah here you have a photo ad
where it's just one photo and here you
see another Carousel ad with two photos
and here you see a video ads
yeah so these are the ads that you see
on uh in the news feed
besides that there are ads in the
stories and here at the top you see the
stories so let's go here browse through
the stories
so here you see and we immediately see
here a sponsored ad from Barcelona Tanja
yeah and this is a video ad
yeah what I like about the ads on the
stories and that's why they are so
powerful they have a very sort of
natural blend with the stories before
and after them they don't really look
like ads and particularly if you're
making them full screen vertical ads
yeah they blend in very well with the
the with the news feed yeah of the story
feeds yep so here you see another ad
yeah with as a story
so you can the call to action are you
looking for the click on the more yeah
and then you can have different more
information in the ad as well so very
powerful
yeah here you see another ad
okay so those are your ads on uh on the
stories and then here you see the reels
yeah now
um
yeah but we'll come back to the reels
later and here in the reels you will be
will be able to see and to Showcase your
ads as well
okay so that is the those are the ads on
um uh on Instagram yeah so if I
summarize this
yeah if we look at the the Instagram ads
so the first ads that we saw were the
photo or the image ads yeah so
particularly for campaigns where there
is a very strong visual aspect yeah
strong visual information that you can
summarize in one single image they are
the best
um for creating image ads these pictures
can be produced using your own
photographers or designs or
illustrations or you can even take an
existing post that you can promote or
that you can boost as an image ad as
well so very straightforward very simple
but the image ads are the simplest way
of creating Instagram ads here you have
a story ads so a story ad multiple
visuals that go in a story engagement is
typically greater with story ads yeah
because it sort of gets the entire
Mobile screen and it's much more
engaging than at in the in the news feed
yep so you see here there is not really
video in there but it is moving kind of
images moving text yeah and audio in
this ad from from Spotify so story ads
are extremely powerful one of the most
popular types of ads in Instagram and
again very easy to create
you don't have to video ads so if you
want to give the viewers from more
in-depth look of your brand your
products your services then run a video
ad on Instagram
so make them short you can make them
Square you can make them full full sort
of vertical full screen but the
important thing is try to make the
content engaging
yep and that is where video ads are so
powerful and they can bring a message
across in a very powerful way video ads
on Instagram they are probably the ads
with the highest conversions yeah for um
for people that view the ad and if you
want them to take an action so yep so
those are the video ads and then you
have the reels ads so intermitted with
reels you can have 30 second long ads
that are sort of comparable to story
advertising so they're full screen
vertical videos and again they properly
merge with the organic reels it happened
they have featured they have sound they
feature Sound and Music
so very powerful ads where you can get
very good call to actions learn more
learn more buy now yeah this sort of
call to actions that can really lead
people either to drive them to your
website or drive them to your shop where
they can buy your product
yep and then we have the carousel ads
and the carousel ads is what I showed
you where you have a collection of
photos or videos that people can swipe
through yep so they can particularly
they work really well in your Instagram
feed and they are really good for
showcasing multiple products in your ads
what you also see is that people use
Carousel ads where they have one large
sort of horizontal photo that they split
up in three sections so it is almost
like browsing through the photo from
left to right so very powerful ads that
you can get on on Google on Facebook and
on Instagram advertising
okay now before we go into the reels
let's go to Facebook ads and show you
some new feature on on the advertising
for the um for Instagram advertising so
here you see the Facebook business
manager yes so it is the meta business
Suite which is sort of a new integrated
platform
um which brings together a number of
functions it used to be the Facebook
business manager but they now have
brought it all under the meta business
Suite so if I go there for my Riyadh for
Russia page it takes you to everything
you need to do and to plan and to manage
and to track of your Facebook or your
Instagram account yeah you see here Iron
Man can manage the Facebook page and I
can manage the Instagram page now we're
not going to go into the whole of the
meta business suit I just want to show
you the advertising and a new feature
here in advertising if I click on all
tools and then I click here on ADD
yeah so this is kind of a quick creation
of ads I can automate my ads I can
choose a goal for my ads or I can boost
existing content and I just want to show
you how easy it is these days to make an
ad for your Instagram so if I want to
boost a post
yeah or I can get more leads or whatever
I want to do yeah boost an Instagram
post or real let's go into that
yeah so content type I'm just going to
do a post for this sake yeah so we're
going to boost this post
yep and then here you will see how the
ad will look like in your Instagram feed
in this case yep and that's where you
can change the text of your ad so it's a
really good feature to quickly launch an
ad of an existing pouch post make sure
you've got your ads blocker Switched Off
to get access to this yeah you can have
other previews as well
let's see what that will give us
yeah so here you see the feed in
Instagram Explorer here which the
Instagram feed
he able to do how it looks in Instagram
stories
here is how it would look in Instagram
reels
yes so really useful tool to quickly see
how your ad will show on Instagram yeah
for an existing post and then of course
you can have the same facilities if you
want to create a new post
okay so that's all I'm going to share
with you on Facebook and Instagram
advertising and how to create your
Instagram ads through the meta business
Suite right so let's go back to the
presentation and let's look at the
Instagram reels so
yeah so where are the reels in Instagram
if I click here on Instagram and then
here is my home
yeah if I click at the bottom on the
little icon here I can then go to reels
and this is exactly like
Tick Tock I can just flick up and that
takes me to the next post
okay so very useful and very simple way
of um of creating and sharing content
and very popular way and a lot of people
spend time on the reels to find really
cool content okay so here I can go to
the search and I can search for items so
I can search for instance look at
marketing how to yeah and here you see
books to master marketing which is in a
real format so this is how I can then
access posts in relation to marketing
yeah and and other elements yeah books
to read
yeah so lots of stuff here on the reels
that you can use to find content in
every topic that you're interested in
yep so here is more reels on Morocco
yeah so very useful tool now how do you
create a reel you click on the plus icon
and you basically select here at the
bottom post story real or live you click
real and then you see the four up five
options that you have here for the audio
the length of the video the speeds yeah
the grids that you want to change the
scale and there's even a timer so
there's lots of functionality that you
can use here in your
um in developing your video Then by
pressing the center button you can start
recording the video yeah and there is
also opportunities to get
um take for instance do little
characters dancing on your desk yeah or
on your keyboard you can make them
slightly bigger
yeah we lost the character where was he
and now we're recording we've lost so
here's our character I can blow him up a
bit yep and we then see him dancing on
our screen
yeah happy with that stop it do next
yeah I'm gonna not not add a sticker
here is the video that we've just
created yeah I can edit a clip if I want
to I click next and then I can share it
to Reels I can write a caption I can add
stickers and all the standard stuff that
you can do on your uh on the reels yeah
so very cool very like Tick Tock and the
the the
best thing about it it is so simple to
make it's very intuitive
okay so that is a quick introduction of
the reels
so how do you fit reels into your
digital marketing strategy let's have a
look at that in a bit more um in a bit
more detail yes so it is a really good
way to give your audience a behind the
scenes
overview yes so which works well to get
engagement and to get Trust on your
brand yes so look at the culture in the
company how you make your product how
hard people work look at the the
customer services how they work it's a
really good way to give people a behind
the scenes look of the company and again
to build this brand trust people really
appreciate that yeah so that is one of
the things that you can do with
Instagram reels another very powerful
aspect of Instagram reels is that you
can use it to generate what we call user
generated content why not ask your
customers or your users to create reels
around a topic that you work on yeah and
share it with with a hashtag yes so it's
a great way for people to getting to
know the company getting to know the
products start using influencers yeah
get competitions going where you do
photo contests or maybe video contests
and you can turn those into reels with
the pictures or make them actually let
the user share the the reels they
created themselves yes so sharing user
generated content is a second big
benefit that you can get from using
Instagram reels now Instagram reels
because they're short people have short
attention span they're also really good
to educate your customers yeah or
educate your audience they're a great
way to develop yourself as an expert in
your field by giving their audience
value yeah on how to use your products
how to
um
to to answer questions about your
products yeah on how to do specific
things in in using your products so get
people to learn around your product and
if you make that a recurring type of
real people will come back for them
because they want to learn more about
your products it's also good to see your
products in actions so combined with
user generated content why not ask your
audience yeah your customers to make
sure it real somehow they use your
products
yes so but if you want to do it yourself
you can really try to highlight what
sets your product apart from your
competition
so yeah use that to your advantage in
using Instagram reels to highlight your
products and to see your products in
action
and of course it goes without saying if
you make it fun if you make it more
personalized yeah that is a fantastic
way to connect with your audience yep
and that is where children work really
well where pets cats dogs work really
well try to get casual try to interact
with your followers through very sort of
emotional casual content so so and often
what you will see that these type of
reels will have very high number of
views because people just love to browse
through that type of content yeah create
your own challenge or create your own
Trends encourage your fans to
participate and use a special hashtag to
share the content they create yeah for
you
so that's the big benefits that you can
get from the reels yeah so use that to
your advantage
good so let's look at some dips and
tricks on Instagram advertising now
remember
most people watch
content on their mobile Instagram is a
mobile app
so make sure that you design your ads
with Mobile in mind make sure that you
optimize your ads for mobile there's
nothing worse than seeing a an Instagram
story ads with a horizontal video and
then black above and below yes so
optimize it for the mobile and mobile is
vertical so use that vertical format
because the immersion is better but also
it's much easier to crop a vertical
video to a 4x5 aspect ready a ratio or a
square ratio than a landscape video
yeah so make sure you design your ads
for mobile first
tip two let the visual speak for
themselves
yeah make your ads less wordy and use
Font sizes that are optimized use color
and make the use capitals make sure that
it is optimized for mobile devices use
big phones that stand out use colors
that stand out and that's a visuals
speak for themselves
tip three yeah use animations use Motion
Graphics it is not just video that you
need to have but animated text animated
things happening on the screen they are
videos as well so let the screen come to
life either through video or through
animation and Motion Graphics
and of course very important Keep The
Branding keep the messaging that you
have keep it at the front yeah the first
three seconds people will decide if they
want to watch the entire ad or continue
to scroll yeah so make sure that in the
first three seconds you capture people's
attention and you've put your branding
and your message across
and then of course you sound yeah you
sound in your ads so although a lot of
the people they may want to watch it
without audio Yeah make it accessible by
people with muted volume use trendy
soundtracks to engage those who choose
to listen to your videos
yeah consider using captions as well or
text overlays that's very important if
you have somebody speaking in your ads
yeah always use captions or overlay of
text to make sure that if people have
the sound off that they can still
understand what the ad is all about
right so that is
Instagram ads and the Instagram reels so
let's look at some of the questions that
I'm getting yeah from people when we
talk about Instagram reels and Instagram
advertising so one question I'm getting
a lot is if I do my reels yeah
I didn't get much engagement what should
I do to improve yes so now first of all
in general Instagram reels have a very
high engagement yes so they're probably
the part of Instagram with the highest
engagement that you will see and I will
show you yep so if I go to my Instagram
here on the of my my Riyadh for Russia
let me close this here
yeah
so save the draft close yeah so I'm
going to my Instagram so this is my
profile and here you see my reels now if
I post a video a normal video I used to
get maybe I could I get some views but
nothing like thousands or thousands of
views yes so since we've been using
Instagram reels
yeah we've now get views and plays on
our videos here
1244 here is a view 11
000 views of the video
yeah here you see six thousand views of
the video these were numbers we would
never get yeah on the Instagram news
feed or the Instagram stories so here
you see you do get the engagement of
your um of the reels on Instagram yeah
and it's one of the big reasons is that
Instagram favors the Instagram algorithm
favors reels in your um yeah in sharing
your content okay so make sure that your
video content is up to scratch maybe the
music could be improved a really good
way is to look at what your competitors
are doing
yeah and maybe they do things that
you're not doing so try to learn from
that
okay question two how do I choose to
write soundtrack for my Instagram reels
good question yeah it's very important
that you get the right sound for your
Instagram reels now Instagram has a
whole library of sounds that you can
choose from in creating your uh your
reels Facebook has a huge library of
thousands and thousands of songs that
you can download royalty free and use in
your in your posts in your ads yes so
very important first of all is that you
look at what's trending in the world
where when it comes to picking a
soundtrack yes so learn from that what
are the hits at the moment what are the
most popular sound music videos on
YouTube what's the most popular music on
the on Instagram learn from that yep and
then make your decision on what music
you want to use in your video
okay will reels get me organic audience
or do I need to promote them as well
so the beauty about digital marketing is
a duty site what you want to do
yeah whether you just want organic or
whether you want to advertise yeah so
just to be clear for everybody when I
say organic audience it means that if I
do a post without any advertising
how many people will see my post how
many people will see my video my reel
and how many people may like it or share
it
yeah and we know and as I said earlier
the reels have a high
fairly High organic reach from the three
areas in Instagram posts stories and
reels reels gives you the highest
organic reach at the moment but we also
know these days and if you look at some
of my other videos that I posted on
YouTube on digital marketing that social
media is no longer a free right social
media these days is pay to play yeah so
if you really want to use Instagram and
Instagram reels to grow your business to
find leads then you need to combine
organic marketing with paid marketing
yes so start looking into what we call
the pay-per-click advertising and see
how much wider and how much bigger the
audience is that you can Target yep and
then try to invest some money in the
pay-per-click advertising and see what
results you get
so always good to look into that have
your options open but the good thing
about digital marketing you decide what
you want to do in this case have a look
at this amazing certification in digital
marketing which is postgraduate program
in digital marketing
so don't miss out on this incredible
opportunity take action today and enroll
in our course to unlock the secrets of
digital marketing success click the link
in the description box and embark on
your professional growth and achievement
Journey Instagram is a social media
platform that needs no introduction with
nearly 1 billion monthly active users
and 500 million daily active users
Instagram is a platform drive with
marketing potential
more than 7 billion dollars Revenue has
been generated from Instagram mobile and
it's home to more than 2 million
advertisers
not only that marketing on Instagram has
the following advantages too
you have increased conversions according
to research more than one-third of the
people using the app have used it to
purchase products which means by
marketing your products on the app
there's a higher chance of conversion
you also have advanced targeting options
this is in part thanks to Instagram's
parent company Facebook Instagram has
access to just about all advertising
features offered by Facebook ads with
this you can advertise to People based
on their age location gender interests
and much more
you can also build better brand follower
relationships you can stimulate
conversion with your followers and build
a connection with them you'll also get a
greater understanding of what your
followers like and dislike based on
their engagement this enables you to
make content they enjoy more and
increase the chance of converting a user
to a consumer
so let's have a look at how marketing is
done on Instagram
let's start with number one optimize
your bio
your bio is the first thing people
notice when they get to your page that's
where they make the first impression of
your brand and that's why it's important
for your bio to be informative
captivating and engaging
use your bio to provide a brief
description of your brand or product the
type of content you'll be posting brand
hashtags links to other social media
platforms and more
your bio should also include a URL to
where you want to drive traffic to be it
your Brand's website or a page for a
particular product make sure to track
this link as well to see how much
traffic it brings
here's an example of how Samsung uses
its bio effectively
you can see it's a very straightforward
it's got a branded hashtag it talks
about all the services Samsung offers
there are links to other pages and a
link to the website as well it's to the
point and covers everything you need to
know about it
next up at number 2 we have create a
Content calendar
now if you ask anyone who works with
social media one of the most important
things they'll tell you is to have a
Content calendar
a Content calendar enables you to keep
track of your posts it'll help you plan
ahead and automate the process of
publishing your posts when your audience
is most active a calendar helps you
decide what content caption hashtags
videos goes live on what day date or
time a consistent post schedule will
enable you to make the most out of
Instagram it'll also keep your audience
engaged and also give you access to
historical posts if you want to repost
your older content
next up we have number three get greater
reach with ads
paid ads can enable you to get more
followers engagement leads and
conversions
the caveat here being that you'll need
to pay for it too the ad options are
pretty similar to what you have on
Facebook like audience segmentation
based on likes interactions buying
habits and more
you also have a variety of AD formats to
choose from like story ads image ads
video ads collection ads and more
moreover they can also be set up from
Facebook ads manager
here's an example from an ad from body
shop in which they are using a single
image ad the advertising works because
of its interesting creative and
attractive ad copy that attracts the
customer to interact with the post and
click on the link let's go to number
four have a visually consistent feed
Instagram is a platform in which people
gravitate towards aesthetically pleasing
content
two authentic expressions and diverse
perspectives the objective is that your
feed needs to match with your Brand's
identity and must appeal to the audience
within your industry what works nowadays
are candid shots muted Earthly tones
with a low key editing style your
content must feel down to earth and your
brand approachable
as you can see in the images all of them
have aesthetically pleasing images and
are somewhat blue or underwater theme
and that's the kind of thing you should
aim for your content following an
understandable and interesting aesthetic
depending on the product you're trying
to sell now for number five tell a story
the images videos and stories you post
need to tell stories that can Captivate
your audience and establish a connection
with them this makes it more likely that
they flee closer to your brand and buy
your products your captions can tell
stories that can help your brand appear
more human and build deeper connections
with your audience
your content needs to align with what
your audience cares about or solves
problems they face here's an example of
how the page Patagonia talks about
forests in America each of their posts
tells stories about a different tissue
that affects nature their brand on
Instagram revolves around bringing
awareness to such issues that's the kind
of stories you should tell with your
brand
next up number six use the right
hashtags
using the right hashtags can make the
difference between your post showing up
on the Explorer tab for everyone to see
and it getting lost in the sea of
content
your hashtag shouldn't be too generic
like hash New Year or hash style since
they'll have too much competition
instead mix up trending and Industry
specific keywords to connect with your
followers
research on successful hashtags and
limit yourself to less than seven in
each post
the more the hashtags in your post the
more likely it seems spammy untargeted
and unprofessional
find out what and how many hashtags your
competitors use and how you can do
something similar
you could also create a hashtag for your
brand these need to be short easily
memorable and involve your brand name in
some way
let's now go to number seven take
advantage of ugc
ugc or user generated content gives your
followers to further involve themselves
with your brand
ugc also buy them as well regardless of
the field your brand belongs to ugc can
be used to converge followers into
Advocates of your brand
here's an example of how Starbucks uses
user generated content and takes
advantages of Their audience to
advertise their products
in this post here they are attracting
customers with an image of happy
children dressed in products stalled at
Starbucks
the post posted by another user would be
appreciated by the audience and improve
Branch loyalty
next up number eight
take advantage of video ads most
instagramers state that users have
visited websites searched or told a
friend after being influenced by posts
even though photo ads are still the more
popular form of advertising we do
advertisements aren't too far behind
there are three key video formats when
it comes to Instagram ads single video
ads that can create 60 second ads
carousels are a combination of images
and videos and Instagram stories that
enable you to combine images and videos
to create visually attractive ads
here's an example of the brand Pizza 73
using story ads to advertise their
pizzas
it's successful because you're showing
off the product they are advertising
with well short videos and captions now
for number nine partner up with
influencers
connecting with influencers will enable
you to connect with thought leaders
within the industry and enable you to
show off your brand to a larger audience
by connecting with them your brand will
have greater authenticity and Authority
influencers need to be given new tools
resources and guidance to carry out
their role effectively and to work
together as partners
micro influencers are also considered to
be more affordable and they have a
closer connection with their audience
here we can see how Ralph Lauren have
collaborated with an influencer to
advertise their products the influencer
showing off the latest Ralph Lauren has
to offer this encourages his interested
followers to check out the page and buy
something for themselves
next for number 10 host contests and
giveaways contests enable your audience
to engage with your brand with 3.5 times
more likes and 64 times the comments you
can give away a product or a service
which enables you to boost engagement
and brand awareness
contests and giveaways need to be
planned Brands need to be partnered with
Contest rules need to be identified
posts need to be created and much more
monitoring the contest and then running
it is also really important you would
need to track your contest performance
and promote the results on other social
media platforms as well here's an
example of a contest run by Domino's
Pizza which encourages people to
contribute their own short stories and
connect better with the brand
number 11 take advantage of stories and
igtv
stories enable you to create a
combination of photos and videos that
disappear after 24 hours
stories can greatly influence your reach
and engagement traits even giving your
story the chance to show up in the
explore section it can also help make
your brand seem more approachable and
authentic adding links to the Instagram
stories can also help with driving
traffic to your website
igtv on the other hand although now
seemingly on the decline still has a few
advantages to offer to The Savvy
marketer igtv provides you a unique
mobile-friendly layout that serves as an
evergreen content very well like
featurettes and interviews another new
tool they have introduced is Instagram
reels Instagram's answer to tick tock
Instagram released reels through which
users would be able to upload 15 second
clips and since it released very
recently it's a Rife with marketing
potential
finally we have number 12 track and
learn identify effective hashtags visual
Styles and the best times to post doing
this you can develop the best practices
for your brand social listening and
analytics will help you fine-tune your
marketing strategy and increase
Instagram engagement let's get started
first off let's have a look at an
introduction to Facebook
Facebook was first launched in February
2004 and was initially known as the
Facebook
in 2005 it removed thee from its name
and it has now become the Facebook we
all know today
it is now the world's most popular
social media and social networking
service
next let's have a look at Instagram
it was launched in 2010 for iOS and then
in 2012 for Android by Kevin Systrom and
Mike Krieger
Instagram has now evolved to become one
of the fastest growing social media
Platforms in the world
in April 2012 thanks to its popularity
it was acquired by Facebook for
approximately one billion dollars in
cash in stock
now let's compare some stats between
Facebook and Instagram
first let's have a look at the worldwide
stats first off Facebook like I
mentioned earlier Facebook is the
largest social media platform in the
world reaching almost 60.6 percent of
the internet it has 2.5 billion monthly
active users and approximately 1.6
billion active users in fact as of Jan
2020 the US has approximately 190
million and India is approximately 280
million Facebook users an indication of
a market that's still ripe for the
picking
now let's have a look at Instagram
although having released significantly
later earns its title of the fastest
growing social media platform with 1
billion monthly active users and 500
million daily users
in the United States there are
approximately 120 million and India has
close to 88 million Instagram users
next up let's have a look at the next
statistic age group of the user base
first off Facebook
although there's a general opinion among
the younger population that Facebook
isn't hip or is induced all that much
anymore this statistic has something
different to say
turns out more than 65 percent of
Facebook users are between the ages of
25 and 34.
for Instagram it's no surprise that 71
percent of the user base are under the
age of 35.
next let's compare the usage time of
both these platforms
let's take Facebook first
in the United States users spend
approximately one hour on Facebook every
day in India users spend an average of
three hours a day on Facebook
shockingly High numbers for a platform
that's assumed to be dead isn't it
on the other hand in the United States
users spend 23 minutes on average on
Instagram in India users spend
approximately 45 minutes
now for the most important stat
marketing
for Facebook 86 percent of marketers use
it for advertising
Instagram is used by 71 percent of
businesses for their marketing
requirements
now let's have a look at some industries
that will work well on both these
platforms
if you do belong to any of these
industries if you're not taking
advantage of these platforms you're
missing out
so let's have a look at some industries
that can capitalize on Facebook
food and beverage companies news and
media e-commerce automobile
and packaged Goods
next time you're on Facebook take a
closer look at your feed there's a good
chance you'll see most of these
industries is post on it
next up Instagram we have Industries
like fashion athleisure Cosmetics
Automobiles and food and beverages
I can guarantee that if you take a
closer look you can find all these
industries advertising on Instagram
now let's take a closer look at how
Facebook can help with marketing
first off let's have a look at Facebook
business pages
now these are basically platforms where
you can create an online presence for
your organization for free
moreover they've got some great
advantages to offer you as well
first off your business page can keep
your customers or potential customers
informed it can be about a new product
launch a webinar a live broadcast a new
store opening anything whatever it is it
can go on your Facebook business page
it connects people with your products
and services with your page you get
greater visibility letting people know
about the products and services that you
offer you can offer customer service as
well in fact according to American
Express 90 of users use customer service
as a deciding factor for whether or not
they continue to do business with an
organization so customer service is
pretty important like I mentioned
earlier your business page provides a
place where you can offer your followers
offers and other advantages
and finally the page lets you build a
community
a highly targeted community that has a
higher possibility of buying your
products and services
next we have Facebook groups with
Facebook groups you can build a
community of like individuals
some of the advantages that come with us
are it provides a highly targeted
audience I mentioned earlier that
business Pages provide you with a highly
targeted audience groups take that to
the next level it enables everyone to
learn from one another
with a large community there's a good
chance that some members know things
that others don't
your group will enable them to
communicate with each other and learn
these new things
you also get honest feedback your
customers who are also likely part of
the group will be able to give their
feedback on how they like your product
and perhaps even give you tips on how to
improve now since your group is filled
with the community that's highly
interested in your brand you can also
increase engagement in an organic manner
and as an extension of the previous
point you also get more leads and
conversions
next Facebook has events with Facebook
events your organization will be able to
mobilize your brand and enable online
consumer marketing basically meaning
that you have a platform for letting
people know about important
announcements not to mention there's
also the opportunity to get some free
advertising done events also help you
increase brand awareness most people get
to know about your brand by attending
the event or just seeing the promotion
for it now let's have a look at Facebook
Stories for groups and Pages a feature
that is available for both groups and
Pages it provides you the ability to
appropriately represent your brand or
business directly from your mobile
device or desktop
now some of its advantages
are that it helps you engage with your
audience with stuff other than the
usuals like articles videos and other
similar posts this way you can also vary
the kind of content that you post
moreover stories can help you humanize
your brand
rather than seeming like you're
pandering to your audience or seeing
them only as potential leads or
customers stories help your brand show
that you're generally interested in your
audience
you can also reach your appropriate
audience with greater frequency next
Facebook has Facebook Messenger
with messenger you can connect and
interact with your audience at a
personal level
in the last few years messenger has
proved itself to be a great marketing
tool it helps acquire more customers now
people are more loyal to a brand that
generally cares about them and by
directly interacting with them through
Messenger their loyalty towards you is
certainly set to improve
and as an extension of the previous
point you also get a greater number of
transaction and even if a customer
doesn't give you a transaction at least
you're increasing your brand awareness
then we have Facebook live Facebook live
gives you a platform to interact with
your audience in real time it can be
used to diversify your content providing
your audience with something different
from what they've received from your
brand initially live can also be used to
show what happens behind the scenes in
your organization further helping
humanize your brand
and finally you can also provide instant
questions and answers to your audience
increasing engagement with them
next we have the Facebook shop
the Facebook shop is a business page tab
application that enables your customers
to purchase your products directly from
your store it also has the following
advantages firstly you can use the shop
to drive new sales you can give the
customers who are on the fence about
your product a small Push by engaging
them and how can you do that with deals
and promotions you can also reward
Advocates of your brand with special
benefits to be availed from your store
and finally you can build brand
awareness and recognition
now let's have a look at Facebook ads
Facebook ads help spread product or
brand awareness in the news feed of a
specific targeted audience on Facebook
now some of the advantages of Facebook
ads are that they help increase brand
awareness
they enable you to advertise your
products and services to the appropriate
audience and it provides you with
greater reach while making new spend
lesser amounts of money it also helps
you re-advertise or retarget your
products to an existing audience and
finally it helps increase Revenue sales
and leads
if you guys are interested in learning
about Facebook ads you can check out our
Facebook ads video I'll add it in the
live chat so you can check it out if
you're interested
now let's have a look at the final
feature Facebook offers to help you with
marketing
Facebook insights I'm sure all of you
have heard about Google analytics let's
just say this is Facebook's version of
that with insights you get information
that can help you refine your brand
strategy by tracking and measuring
results
it can help you determine reach and
engagement actions people who are
viewing your posts when your fans are
online the type of posts that are
working for you and much much more
that brings us to the end of the ways
Facebook helps you with marketing now
let's move on to Instagram
first off we have Instagram business
accounts Instagram business accounts
enable Brands to be recognized as
businesses
now it also has the following benefits
to offer it's only with the business
account that you can get Instagram
insights we'll talk about insights in a
little more detail in a little bit you
can also add a contact button on your
profile enabling users to connect with
you directly you can also specify what
kind of service you offer by adding what
industry you belong to in your bio and
finally you also have the ability to add
links to your Instagram stories now I'm
sure you've all seen the see more option
in your stories so now you know how that
shows up
now if you guys are interested in
finding out how you can increase
followers on Instagram you can check out
our video on the same topic of the same
name I'll add the link in the live chat
next let's talk about Instagram stories
with Instagram stories you have the
ability to grow engagement build brand
awareness and to drive sales you can
also use stories to provide recent
updates about your brand
now some of the advantages of Instagram
stories are that they help businesses
grow Their audience and can enable them
to engage with their audience regularly
with stories you can also Drive traffic
to other websites like your company's
website it can also help diversify your
content setting it apart from the usual
videos and photos next up let's talk
about Instagram DMS or direct messages
DMS help you grow your business by
interacting with customers at a personal
level it can also help build connections
with your users by building a personal
connection with your followers their
loyalty towards your brand is improved
not only that it helps you make or grow
your connections within the industry and
as an extension of the last few points
this leads to easier lead generation and
increased sales
next up we have igtv
now igtv is a platform that's gotten
really famous recently it enables your
brand to get closer to its audience and
enables it to be discovered by new
people
other benefits include creative
visibility of your products and services
having the ability to educate and
entertain your audience
improve engagement and greater chances
of conversions finally it also helps
build a community of a highly targeted
audience
next we have Instagram live
Instagram live enables you to
communicate with your audience in real
time further improving your
discoverability and strengthening your
connection with the audience moreover it
provides a lot of visibility
your followers are immediately notified
when you go on live stream
and finally it helps you interact with
your audience in real time
this helps further humanize your brand
next we have Instagram apps
Instagram ads provides you with control
over advertisements you decide how they
appear and who sees them like Facebook
Instagram has a number of different ad
types to offer
they are photo ads video ads Carousel
ads slideshow ads and stories ads
next up Instagram offers an Instagram
shop
the shop helps you incorporate your
product catalog with your Instagram
profile
at some points even enabling users to
access the shop directly from an image
showing the same product
one of the major advantages of the
Instagram shop is that it provides easy
product discoverability and since it
provides visual marketing it also leads
to more sales
and finally Instagram insights
Instagram's answer to Facebook insights
and Google Analytics
insights is an analytical tool that
provides data on follower demographics
their actions and your brand content
it helps determine engagement
Impressions and reach best and worse
performing content profile visits
website clicks and much more
and there you go that's everywhere
Facebook and Instagram can help you with
marketing
now we've laid out the facts for you
keep in mind your requirements and make
a wise choice
welcome to today's training where we
will be talking about YouTube channels
we're going to be talking about what are
YouTube channels how do you set them up
how do you optimize them and how do you
subscribe to them but before we start
let me quickly introduce myself I am
Mark campman I will be your digital
navigator for this video and if you
liked the video please click the like
button or if you want to join our
YouTube Community why don't you hit the
Subscribe button
so what's all this about in YouTube why
is YouTube so popular what makes it so
special and why do you need a YouTube
channel well the numbers they speak for
themselves over two and a half billion
people open YouTube at least once a
month that is one third of the world's
population
generates around 30 billion dollars of
Revenue in 2021 that is 78 million
dollars a day these are extraordinary
amounts and this is primarily
advertising Revenue
now 25 of global mobile usage is for
YouTube it's one of the most popular
mobile apps and YouTube is the main
source of video for 78 of its users look
at the younger generation they don't
watch terrestrial TV they watch TV on
YouTube so on the back of this a whole
community of video creators have emerged
people who go on YouTube to present to
share to discuss to debate to invent to
compare and become famous with posting
their videos we call them YouTubers and
I don't have to mention people like
Gangnam Style Justin Bieber Shawn Mendes
Ariana Grande Dua Lipa and what about
brands that made it big on YouTube the
Dollar Shave Club Blendtec with blend
will it blend and it's the YouTube
channel they use as the social platform
for their videos a YouTube channel
serves as the homepage for a user's
account anyone can view YouTube without
having an account however you need to
create a YouTube channel if you plan to
upload videos add comments or make
playlists but more about how to do this
later
businesses can also have a YouTube
channel these channels are different
from the personal channels because they
can have more than one owner of manager
so how do businesses benefit from
YouTube
well posting on YouTube will help people
find you on Google remember Google owns
YouTube by consistently utilizing
YouTube for your business you can
increase your chances of showing up in
the search results and improving your
own rankings
YouTube will also expose you to a huge
Global audience YouTube is available in
over 80 languages and it receives more
than 30 million visitors a day who watch
nearly 5 billion videos
it's the second biggest search engine
coming only after Google itself and the
YouTube app again as I said earlier is
one of the most popular apps in the
store
YouTube gives you qualified traffic
people on YouTube often have a question
they search for and if your video can
answer the question they have you will
get a qualified lead it's much like
Google search but then it's visual
also video content is 12 times more
likelier to be watched than text to read
video can evoke emotion they can make
you think they can make you feel and if
they make you think and feel you're not
likely to forget those videos and that's
much more that can be said for most
other types of online marketing
video also helped to humanize your brand
they bring it to life taking your
messages from flat and static to Dynamic
and engaging
videos help your brand build trust and
loyalty in a unique way
you can also use YouTube ads to reach an
even bigger audience YouTube advertising
runs on through the Google ads platform
and has some very powerful features and
more about these ads on YouTube later
videos can also be repurposed across
many other channels so they can help you
drive additional traffic to your website
you can share them on your social media
channels you can embed them on your own
website or you can include them in your
email marketing
to summarize video marketing is a must
for your business and if you're not on
the video train you will miss the next
stop
publishing regular videos is key and
YouTube offers you a YouTube channel as
your YouTube homepage for all your
videos so here's a bit more background
information about YouTube ecosystem it's
important to know that there are three
players in the YouTube ecosystem
there's you the viewer there's the
content creator or the people that
upload their videos and there are Brands
Brands who want to reach you to sell
their products
and it's YouTube's challenge to keep
everybody happy in this ecosystem to
keep you happy to show you the best
videos keep content creators Happy by
enabling them to make some money and to
keep Brands Happy by connecting them
with the biggest audience possible so
how do Brands connect with you very
simple through advertising showing your
short video as before or during the
videos you watch in fact 84 of YouTube
reviewers both from Brands after
watching videos or ads they see on
YouTube
and then how do content creators make
money very simple YouTube enables them
to earn ad revenue from ads that run
before or during their videos every time
an ad shows in front of the or during
the video they get a percentage of the
ad revenue and I'm sure you've seen
those ads while you were watching
YouTube videos
but not every YouTube content creator
qualifies for this you need to have at
least 1 000 subscribers to your channel
and a minimum of 4 000 watch hours on
your Channel
in other words advertising in YouTube is
the oil of the YouTube ecosystem it
keeps everybody happy
and there are a variety of ads
marketeers can choose from many of them
find pre-roll skippable ads the most
effective you know those ads that you
can skip after a few seconds
just a little side note Here YouTube ads
or mobile are the most effective for the
simple reasons but many people watch
videos on their mobile but also many
peoples have ad blockers on their
desktop so your ads will not be seen on
their desktop
YouTube has recognized the power of
mobile video and mobile ads and has
announced that it will share 45 of AD
revenue on YouTube shorts
now what are YouTube Shorts YouTube
shorts are short vertical videos and
they are YouTube's response to the
phenomenal growth of tick tock and
vertical videos are key these days if
you want to boost engagement consider
using vertical videos
and here's why it has a 90 percent
higher completion rate compared to
Vertical videos
about 80 percent of consumers claim that
the format is more engaging and 65
percent of people find Brands using
vertical videos for their advertising to
be more innovative
so enough of the theory let's look at
the YouTube channels and look at what
you need and how to set up a unit your
YouTube channel
first of all you need a kit to make
videos whether it's your computer your
webcam a camera a smartphone and of
course you need a video editing software
and very important you need an indoor or
outdoor environment to make your videos
and then of course you need to make the
video this will be a topic for another
simply learned video in its own right
but here are a few tips
what make people watch videos
people watch videos when they are
educational
informational
entertaining funny controversial or
shocking lots of examples in these
categories of videos in YouTube now what
type of videos do people like to watch
there's a whole range of different types
of videos but if you want to look at the
most popular ones you talk about
unpacking videos review videos Challenge
videos whole videos parodies covers live
videos how-to videos it's a whole range
of styles of video of topics or video
that you can create whether it's for
Consumer videos or for business videos
now what type of videos can you make
there's a whole range of different types
there's standard format video which is
horizontal there's the vertical video
which I talked about a little earlier
there are stop-motion videos
yeah there are time lapse videos you
could do 360 videos and the big growth
these days is in art is in augmented
reality and virtual reality
yep and then what do you need to think
about when you shoot your video there
are three very important aspects of
making your video think about light
think about sound and think about having
a stable camera position
your light is very important there's no
better light than outdoor lights and if
you haven't got our if you don't shoot
outdoor but indoor make sure you have a
good lighting setup
sound can be very deceiving if you're
interviewing somebody on the video
outside you think there is no wind but
then when you hear the video back on
your computer you hear the wind it's
it's quite an interesting phenomenon but
it's effect so best is to have a high
quality microphone that you use when you
interview or when you record your videos
and think about a tripod as well make
sure your camera is in a stable position
so that's the theory behind all this
let's now look at some YouTube channels
and show you how to make a YouTube
channel and here is the simply learn
YouTube channel
a very clear Channel with lots of
content for people to learn about all
topics in um in technology so here you
see the banner yeah with some good
messaging in there you have your logo
here you see the number of subscribers
yep so you see it's a verified account
by YouTube and here is the Subscribe
button yep and when you are subscribed
to a video or to a channel the you get
um sort of personalized notifications or
you can switch off the notifications but
the beauty about people subscribing to
your channel is that they will receive a
notification when you publish a new
video
then here you have a menu of things that
people can go to there's the home page
for all your videos there is a list of
all your videos you can organize your
videos in playlists you can look at the
comments that you're getting in the
community section you can set up
different channels and you can group
those channels under your account and
here is the about page where you have
about information about the company yep
and this is you can optimize this with
keywords so Google will Index this for
the for the search as well so let's look
at this home page again and the um The
Branding yeah so here you see a feature
video
and there are two elements in this area
that are important here first of all you
saw just when I got on the page before I
subscribed you saw a different video yep
and then when you come back to the page
you can see another video so basically
you have a video that you can put here
for first-time visitors where you can
promote your company or your channel and
then you can have another video set up
for returning visitors
and then here you have all your videos
and you can organize them in playlists
and in a minute I'm going to show you
how to set this all up and how to create
your own channel
okay so this is simply learn another
example would be one of my favorites on
social media is social media Examiner
here is the social media examiner
YouTube channel
yes so here you see the the featured
video here you see The Branding very
good branding with strong messages on
there an industry report that people can
download you see here you can put a few
links to your social media or your
website or where people can download for
instance the industry report here you
see The Branding the logo yeah again I
can subscribe to it and then here you
have the descriptions of the video and
the different channels the different
um playlists
okay so then here you have to group the
different channels that they have under
their um their their main channel the
social media Examiner
okay so you see coming back and I see
another video here so finally the other
one I want to show you is GoPro GoPro
they are very active on YouTube very
active on on having videos having videos
from their users from their subscribers
having very clear playlists
yeah so
um and this could be a different
playlists from users the different
products features and what what have you
what you also see here is access to the
store
you know where they sell products and if
I click on this I can then go to the
GoPro website where I can buy this this
product
so this is an overview of the YouTube
channel on the desktop but as we all
know most people and particularly the
younger generation they watch YouTube
videos on their mobile device so
whatever you do and in The Branding as
well on setting it up you need to make
sure that it looks well and it looks
good on the mobile as well so let's look
at these channels on the mobile device
yeah so here you see the mobile you see
exactly the same elements of it you see
your banner you see your uh your your
logo number of subscribers and your
feature video and then you have your
other videos
yeah so it's a lot easier to navigate
through one thing that you need to be
careful of is that the width of the
banner is not as white as the width on
the on the desktop yeah so in your
design you need to take that into
consideration otherwise half of this
text will be chopped off
yep so this is simply learn if we're
going to social media Examiner
yep so here is the social media examiner
page yeah their Channel again the the
banner and you have subscribed
yep and then here you see a different
color yeah with simply learn it was
brownish here it was greenish you cannot
change this color that is something that
YouTube will decide based on the overall
color it can pick it will pick up on
your um on your desktop on your uh on
your YouTube channel
okay so and again remember the banner
how white you go and then the other one
was the GoPro
yep here is the GoPro Channel
same look and feel here it is grayish
yeah with the banner the logo and then
the um the feature video
right
time to have a look at how I create a
YouTube channel and how I optimize it so
I can grow my number of subscribers to
my channel
here you see the overall YouTube
interface and it's very important that
you get into YouTube and that you sign
in with your Google account
and once you have your Google account
set up and you're logged into your
Google account you can create a YouTube
channel
so how do you create a YouTube channel
here you see a your user yeah and here
you see your user icon and for me it's
just a why I haven't put any visual
there yet yep and if you haven't done
anything on YouTube yet then this is the
screen that you will see yeah here you
see the videos that you can all access
the subscriptions how you can explore
and you can use YouTube without having
uploaded any video yourself or without
having created a channel
if you want to upload a video on YouTube
you click here on the plus
of course everything I'll show you you
can do on the mobile as well but my
experience if you are in admin mode and
you want to add text you want to add
your about you want to make different
selections then it's much easier to work
on the desktop so for demo purposes I'll
be showing it on the desktop okay so if
I click here on my user icon I get to
the menu of things I can do in my
account my Google account and my YouTube
account here you see create a channel
I can also go to YouTube studio and in
YouTube Studio I can edit all my videos
and optimize them I can check with
another I can switch to another account
I can look at my membership my date I
can look at the device theme I'm using
the language the restricted mode whether
you want a certain videos not to have
presented to you your location keyboard
shortcuts
Etc but what we're going to be looking
at is the create a channel
so I'll just click on create a channel
and here I'm going to add my name and my
name is basically I'm going to call it
Mark
tube yeah so my channel is called Mark
Cube I can upload my picture here I can
also do that at a later stage so let's
create the Channel first and then I'll
show you how to do The Branding so we'll
click on create channel
yep and then you will see that your
channel is ready so what I can do now of
course I can upload my first video I'm
not going to do that yet I'm going to go
straight into customize my channel and
then once my channel has been set up
I'll show you how to upload your first
video so here is customizing your
Channel
and there are three elements to it there
is the layout of your channel there is
The Branding of your channel and there
is the basic info of your Channel
yeah so let's look at the branding first
the before yeah remember we had the
video Spotlight which was your featured
video
so here you can specify which two videos
you want to have in the featured section
whether it is the video for people who
haven't subscribed and then the feature
video for the people who come back and
have subscribed and then here you have
your featured sections
remember you can have the videos you can
have different sections that you can add
here like popular uploads live past live
streams upcoming live stream the
playlists subscriptions feature channels
all in the menu that I showed you
earlier but we'll come back to that in a
little bit
yeah here is your menu on the left
which is also important yes so and we'll
come back to that in a minute as well so
first we're going to do is look at the
branding
yeah and here I can add my logo I can
add my banner image and I can add a
video Watermark which is standard watch
Mark that will show in all your videos
so very simple we're going to upload the
images so here you see my I've created
these in advance yeah so here you see my
YouTube logo
yep so very simple icon and I can now
select okay what section will I do I
want and make sure it fits within your
image area and you click done and you
have your icon your picture in setup
here you see the banner image you see at
least 2048 by 1152 pixels and six
megabytes or less if I click upload I
then have my banner image I click open
yeah and here remember what you see on
the desktop and what you see on the
mobile so here it is important that you
look at the text that you have on your
banner and make sure that it is viewable
on all devices I'm happy with this so I
click done
I'm not going to do the watermark and
then I'm going to click publish
yep so the changes have been published
so if I'm now going to look at my
channel
view the channel on YouTube you now see
I have my banner I have my my banner
here I have my logo but of course
there's still a lot I have to do I have
to look at work on the about I have to
add maybe some other items in the menu
and of course I have to upload a video
so let's go back to the customize the
channel and what I'm going to look now
is to the basic info so first of all I
have my description so in the
description I'm going to tell people
what my channel is all about welcome
to my YouTube channel
a place
to learn everything
there is to know
about digital marketing
yeah and I can make this as big as
possible very I have a thousand
characters available and very important
think keywords here yeah if you follow
digital marketing courses keywords are
the Cornerstone of your digital
marketing strategy I can add a language
and here I have my channel URL and I can
change this if I want to yeah so it's a
standard web address for your channel it
includes your unique Channel ID yeah but
you can change this as well
yeah so I can say here mark
no actually I cannot change this I will
be able I think to change this let's
have a look
customize a customize URL is a shorter
easy to remember URL that you can share
with your audience and where you have
100 or more subscribers you have at
least 30 days old of your channel you
have uploaded your branding as well yeah
so to have
your number to have your customized URL
you need to have these 100 subscribers
and they have a channel that's at least
30 days old so I can't change this right
now and then here you can add the links
remember the links that you see on your
banner you can add a link
yeah so here I can say the link is
um Mark kempman or let's say
simply learn
dot com and I can say https
simply
learn.com yeah and I can add a link I
can say Facebook
and I can say https
Facebook
.com forward slash simply learn and I'm
going to add Instagram
and I'm going to say https
instagram.com
forward slash simply learn
okay
yep and then here I can say which links
do I want to show on the banner yeah I
can add a whole load of links here but
then I can say just show me the first
three links on the banner here's the
contact info that is marked at
simplylearn.com yep so here is my about
section ready and then here I can click
publish
and now I can go back to my channel
and what you see now my channel is ready
we have the banner we have the home uh
the logo and now here you see
simplylearn.com the website the Facebook
and the Instagram it will automatically
pick up the logos from the Facebook and
the Instagram and the other social
networks that you want to add here
all right so the next thing is that we
need to look here at the the topics that
we want here yeah we have Home Videos
playlists channels and about so I can
add multiple channels if I want but
let's go back to customizing
yeah so we've done the layout we've done
we're going to look at the layout now
we've done The Branding we've done the
basic info so here is the channel
trailer we're going to do in a minute
when we've uploaded our first videos so
let's add a section and that would be
the created playlists
yep and we want to add a section let's
say uh popular uploads okay and then I
can say give me the created playlist I
want to the top
yeah I want the uploaded videos and then
I have the shorts and I have the popular
uploads okay and again I'm going to
click publish I'm going back to my
channel
yep so and now you won't see the order
yet because I haven't put in any any
videos of course but you will see as
soon as we start adding videos then you
will can you can see that we um that you
get the order that we've specified
Okay so
finally before we're going to upload the
video when we go into customizing your
channel you need to be aware here of the
features as well yeah the menu items
that you have so here is your channel
dashboard
so in your channel dashboard you see the
videos that you uploaded and it gives
you basic Channel Analytics
yeah and here you have some news from
YouTube about new features new training
Etc
here you see the content so here you see
a list of the videos that you've
uploaded
their feasibility status is there a
restriction on the video what is the
date that you uploaded and you get some
basic analytics fuse comments and likes
okay here are your playlists that you've
created
here you get your basic YouTube channel
Analytics
yeah you're looking at your comments
that you get so here you can sort of
review the comments you can set some
moderation guidelines here you can also
add subtitles to your videos now we'll
go into that in more detail when we go
into YouTube and uploading videos and
how to optimize your YouTube videos
but Google will automatically subtitle
your videos and you can edit the um the
Subscribe the subtitles that Google will
uh will do yeah and very important to
remember if you use the Google
subtitles for your video it will not be
indexed for search for the simple reason
that there may be words that Google
misinterpreted in your video so you
always need to edit the video take the
typos the um the words that are
misunderstood by Google change those and
then as soon as you then change the
revised version of the subtitles Google
will then index the um the transcribed
file yeah for search
here is copyright information here is
monetization of your videos it's
important we talked about this earlier
yes so remember where you can have
advertising showing before or during
your videos and that is you will have to
become part of the YouTube Partner
program and once you're a member of the
partner program you'll be eligible to
earn money from your videos but you need
to have a minimum of 1 000 subscribers
and a minimum of four thousand watch
hours on your videos
you need to set up two-step verification
and you need to agree to the community
guidelines
okay here is customization of your
channel yeah we sort of went through
this earlier and then here is a little
nugget in YouTube that not many people
are aware of and that is the audio
library YouTube holds a huge audio
library of tracks and sound files yeah
and sound effects that you can actually
download and add to your videos you can
search the library so it is a huge
library that you can add for free to add
to all your videos
and then finally there is the settings
of your channel so you can specify the
conversion or the currency for your
channel that you'll be using you can
specify the basic info of your channel
yeah you can have the country of
residence in my case we can set that on
the United Kingdom
yep and it can add keywords which is
digital marketing
yeah and I can say social
media and I can say YouTube
Etc
yep there is upload defaults so for
every video that you upload you can
specify a standard element in the title
standard element in the description the
visibility you can specify and public
private or unlisted so prior unlisted
means it will not show in the Google in
the YouTube search results
there is advanced settings that you can
say you can also in your video specify
chapters
and you can spend those chapters will
then be sort of summarized in the
description of your video and that will
be noted in the timeline of your video
as well so it's really good to structure
your videos
there's permissions yeah and this is
where you can invite other people to
make changes or to edit your channel
there is your community that's where you
can set moderation guidelines and then
there are agreements yeah there's the
subject to the the terms of service
okay so those are your settings so very
important that you understand this menu
right so our channel is ready however we
haven't got any video in our Channel yet
so let's go and add a video so here to
add a video we click Plus
okay and we're going to upload the video
or we can also go live
yeah so that's where we're going to do a
live broadcast or a live stream so
upload a video and here I'm going to
draw drag and drop a video or I can
select a file and here is my about us
short infographic
yep so here is the about us infographic
that is the title of course I can make
it as exciting as possible here I can
tell the uh short introduction
to our company
I can select a thumbnail of course I
have it hasn't selected the thumbnail
yet because it is still uploading and
optimizing the video yep you can then
say what playlist do you want it to be
part of what audience yeah there is an
automatic
catch filter is it made for kids or is
it not made for kids so it's like a
business type of theme yeah here is paid
promotion it's the paper Motion in the
video do you want automatic chapters
allow automatic places you can add text
this is all about optimizing your video
and that is for a different video that
we will be talking about how to optimize
your YouTube videos
okay and then it is going okay so that
is all done we're then clicking next
yeah I can say do I want subtitles do I
want to add an end screen do I want to
add cards remember you see that on
videos where at the end of the video you
see two cards where you can click on uh
to go to another video again I'm not
going to do that for this video and I'm
going to click next
yeah there is some copyright checks on
music and then we click next and here is
the video I can then save and publish I
want it to be public I can schedule the
publication yes so but this is all there
is to it and I'm gonna click publish
so I have now published my video I can
share it straight away on social media
again we're not going to do that I'm
just going to click close And now I see
my video in my content list
yeah I see a thumbnail I see the title I
can see the different details and if I
now go back to my channel
I can see my video in my channel but you
see here I have just put it as an upload
because I haven't added any playlists
yet
yeah so I need to go here to my
customize my channel
and I'm going to click first I'm going
to add the channel trailer and the video
I want to add to this is my about us
infographic and people that subscribed
I'm gonna give them the same video
I am now going to add a playlist
so here are my playlists oh I first need
to
publish this
yeah there we go I'm now going to go to
my playlists and I'm going to create a
new playlist and that is sort of info
Graphics or let's say a video graphics
all right and I'm gonna create my
playlists
okay so now I'm going back to my uh
content
and I'm now gonna say go to edit this
video
yeah let's see if the playlists are here
go to the details thumbnail so here I
now in the video details I'm going to my
playlists and I'm going to select the
video graphics playlist done and I'm
going to click save
so now you see if I go back to my
channel
yeah so back to my channel that my
channel now looks slightly different
I have my presentation my featured
videos
okay and I have my playlists
and I have my uploads
yep so this is how you can build your
channel how you can optimize your
channel add videos to your channel add
playlist to your channel
so I hope that was a um was a simple uh
yet effective overview for you how to
set up your Channel
so
that is it on the channel so let's
finish today's video with giving you
some tips on how to promote your YouTube
channel
it is very important that you promote
your channel for the simple reason you
want to get
subscribers
yep remember your YouTube channel is
your show your YouTube social media
Network it is where you can develop your
brand it is where you can get people
excited it is where you can build
relationships with people who watch your
videos so it's very important that you
do everything that's possible to promote
your uh your YouTube channel so how do
you go about promoting it first of all
very important in video marketing is the
title of your video
yeah you see here the about us
infographics you see that is the title
of this video is pretty boring if you
look at most titles of videos on YouTube
yeah let's see let's see if I search on
YouTube for let's say social media you
immediately see the titles that are
powerful how social media rewires your
brain is social media hurting your
mental health
yeah like selfies and self-promotion the
hidden dangers of social media
five crazy ways social media is changing
your brain right away
yeah you're a bit more neutral but still
powerful how to develop a social media
strategy step by step these are the type
of things that people like to uh to
watch because those titles are very
engaging
you know hand in hand with the title is
also the thumbnail that you're using for
your videos
yeah so here you see a good example 365
days of journaling that's the thumbnail
that they they use yeah if you go to
social media examiner you see good
examples of thumbnails
yeah and they are all they have the same
color style they have the same bold text
bold titles they still show people yeah
so these are very powerful
thumbnails for your video and look at
yourself if you're doing a search on
YouTube yeah what videos will you most
likely watch videos where you like the
title and videos where you like the
thumbnail when they spring out when they
scream out of the search results
okay so very important that you um that
you look at that
okay next thing how do you optimize your
channel is by making sure that your
videos are optimized
yeah so if I go to my videos your videos
and then here you have your video and I
go to edit the details
I can edit the title the description
remember keywords I can edit the
thumbnail I can edit tags yeah I can
edit
um language lots of stuff that you can
optimize about your videos another
important
factor is make videos that your audience
wants to see
understand your audience yeah in digital
marketing terms we advise our clients to
make customer personas
and customer personas you specify their
pains their needs and everything that
is important for them when they buy your
your product yes so by understanding
what your audience wants you then can
tailor the content of your videos
to their requirements
the next important aspect of your
YouTube channel is engaging with the
community
it has very important that when people
start adding comments in your videos
that you engage with them
yeah that is one place where you sort of
build your your community you engage
with people but you also engage with
YouTubers in your Market
associated with your Market yeah comment
on other people's videos so start
engaging with other content creators in
building your online YouTube reputation
as it were and start sharing your videos
yeah with them so that is an important
one another important aspect of your
channel is that you need to cross
promote your own videos within your
videos yeah so it's very common if I go
to Simply learn yeah and go to their
Channel and I'm sure they have it on one
of their videos if I go to let's say
here
um data analytics
yes so it's a long course but if I go to
the end of the video
I'm sure you see that here at the end
yeah so you see here at the end the next
video that they promote so you cross
promote your other videos within your
video that you're showing it's a very
powerful aspect of
um the growing your YouTube channel
cross-promoting your video
yeah another one is very powerful it's
what we call video series
yeah they are
very good in driving traffic to your
channel yeah why because people want to
if they like it they will come back for
the second episode
or if they jump in for instance for the
first time in the fourth episode if they
see the episode if they like the
episodes then they say hey I want to
watch episode one two and three as well
so very important is to create series of
videos a good example is social media
Examiner
yeah when you go to the social media
examiner YouTube page and you go to the
playlists here you see the journey
and the journey is a uh basically a
series of videos of the history of the
company yeah so you see episode one
episode two episode three yeah they even
have multiple Seasons yeah of this and
this was very successful in their their
marketing promotion yeah so create
YouTube series
okay so back to my channel another way
of promoting your channel and promoting
your videos is to make sure that your
videos are outside YouTube as well so if
I click on the video yeah and I click
share instead of just sharing the code
here yeah the the URL I'm actually going
to take the embed code so the embed code
gives you an iframe which will actually
show the video on your website if you
add this iframe code to your web page
yeah and people will watch can watch the
video on your um your website but it
will count as a few on on YouTube
yep and then when people click on
Youtube it'll take them to your channel
where they can
um where they can subscribe to your
Channel
yeah we talked about playlists very
important to promote your Channel
yeah the playlists are important and
make sure you add calls to action to
your video at the end of the video get
people to do something to buy something
or to sign up or to register for an
event going live always works in
promoting your Channel
yeah doing live broadcast live behind
the scenes when you're at an event new
live broadcasts really good way to
promote your channel you can promote the
event you can announce the event it will
lead to bus before the broadcast during
the broadcast and after the broadcast
yeah we talked about collaboration with
other creators with other brands and
then of course Very powerful you can
actually promote your own ads by
advertising yes so I can go to Google
ads I can create a video ad and add a
video ad is my short video and then that
video will show before and during
um videos that people watch
yep and that will drive views on your
videos and Views obviously will turn
into subscriptions to your channel as
well
and then last but not least of course is
publishing your videos and your YouTube
content on social media channels as well
yeah Twitter of course is a very obvious
place to promote your videos but use it
on on other social channels as well now
Facebook doesn't necessarily like it
when you link to the YouTube video
because Facebook wants you to upload the
whole video yes so then people will stay
within YouTube within Facebook to watch
the video but there are other social
media channels where you can promote
your videos as well
okay well that concludes the session
on your YouTube channels
I hope you liked this yeah so remember a
YouTube channel is your social media
Network for your videos on Google and on
YouTube
yep and it gives you a fantastic tool to
widen your reach to reach a global
audience and to start building
relationships with your subscribers yep
and help them in the process of
familiarizing themselves with your
products or your services ultimately
leading to them in buying your product
of your service YouTube ideas for 2021
YouTube is the social media platform
that needs new introduction launched
back in the Year 2005 YouTube was a
fresh breath of air for the people who
were slowly becoming aware of the hype
that surrounded the internet several
other platforms like Dailymotion redmi
and VMO which admittedly have their own
fans have tried to stand up against the
wehemoth that is the YouTube and failed
slowly but surely marketers began to
realize the enormous potential that
YouTube offered they could add small
advertisements like they do in the cable
TV they could show banner ads and do
much more and all of the thanks to the
robust advertisement features that
Google already offered if you're not
already sold on why it's important to
advertise on YouTube here are some facts
that might change your mind YouTube has
more than 2 billion users across the
world a good fraction of that audience
could be shown your product and could
turn from users to customers next
important fact is that 8 out of 10
marketers consider YouTube to be one of
the best platforms to advertise their
products and services followed by that
people watch one billionaires of YouTube
per day as you watch this video you are
contributing to that number
next 62 percent of the business use
YouTube to post content this could be
just videos on their products tutorials
event announcements and much more
seventy percent of the YouTube watch
time comes from mobile this means that
when you create an advertisement for
YouTube you keep the mobile users in
your mind and finally 90 percent of the
people say that they've discovered new
products or brands on YouTube which
means that by posting on YouTube your
brand awareness is highly likely to
increase now let's talk about the video
ideas
the first one is behind the scene videos
these videos give you the opportunity to
showcase your audience how your business
or brand operates a creatively made
video on the inner workings of your
business will show off a more human side
of your brand and make you more
relatable to your audience it is also
guaranteed to get you loads of views and
engagement here's an example how Amazon
showcases the warehousing and
distribution aspects of its products it
takes the viewers into the factories and
involves the various people working
there this shows to the audience that
even a large organization like Amazon
how each individual has an important
role to play in the overall process
next we have the company culture a video
that highlights your company culture
will tell the audience what your
business goals are what its values are
and why it exists it can also focus on
the various people who make sure the
company works in the way it does this
can help better connect with your
audience here's an example a company
culture video created by GoDaddy the
popular domain register
the video talks about how GoDaddy
creates a fun inclusive and energetic
environment for its employees it
includes interviews of employees talking
about why they enjoy working in GoDaddy
so much and this helps the audience
relate with the company and could also
catch up the interest with some
potential job Seekers next we have the
third idea that is the marketing team a
brand is nothing without the people
working behind it and that's where these
videos come in these videos will help
shine a light on the people who create
the products that the audience knows and
loves this helps create a personal
connection with the audience these
individuals can end up becoming mascots
for your brand
here's an example of Meet the team
focusing on Olympus crew the video goes
into the history of masket makers brand
and the people that make it a grand
success the lighthearted tone of the
video also greatly helps with making it
more relatable now we have number four
product showcase or announcement
a product Showcase Video aims to show
the features and benefits of the Brand's
latest offering to its audience these
short concise videos can inform the
audience about everything they need to
know about the new product or service a
product announcement video on the other
hand can be used to give the audience a
more detailed look into the product or
service than the product showcase it can
include comparisons to older versions or
competitors the aim of such video is to
show customers how the new product works
and why they need it
now this video needs no introduction
Apple's iPhone videos have always been
short but smooth sleek and concise
representations of what the product
would be like
next at number 5 we have event
announcements these videos can build a
hype regarding an upcoming event it will
also give you the opportunity to engage
with your audience and build their
interest
this promo video for the data Innovation
Summit 2020 Hypes up the event posting
the greatest Minds in the tech the most
Innovative companies and much more
the next video idea we have at number
six is the explainer videos these videos
are aimed to tell users how a particular
product or a service works these tend to
be much more useful than wall of text
explaining how something works they also
have an added advantage of simplifying
complex Concepts and features to your
audience for example we have our own
video on digital marketing we cover a
number of different concepts like SEO
social media marketing search engine
marketing and more on a visual Mana
making it more likely to grab the
attention of a viewer
next at number seven we have tutorials
tutorial videos give users some
actionable insights and knowledge that
your users can learn from these videos
aim to be guides to information complex
Concepts hints tips and tricks relating
to your industry here we have our own
digital marketing course video as an
example unlike the previous example I
mentioned this video goes into much more
detail regarding each of the concepts of
digital marketing on that note if you
guys are interested in learning about
digital marketing I suggest you start
from this video it's a great one to get
started with now on the next video idea
at number eight we have the product
tutorial a product tutorial video will
take your audience through the various
features of your product offers
alongside its intricacies it can also
detail some additional insights about
your product you can also explain the
best way the product can be used
here is a video of how the meditation
app headspace explains the app's usage
with an interesting and creative
animated video
now let's go ahead with number nine at
the number nine we have the webinar a
webinar thanks to its nature provides
your brand with loads of opportunities
to interact with your audience they are
usually very accessible and easy to make
they are also very cost effective and
can be reused as video content after the
session is complete here's an example of
Simply learns webinar where we talk to
the industry experts regarding wide
variety of topics while involving the
Audience by having the guest answer the
audience questions whenever possible
next at number 10 we have the live
streams live streams for an event will
help build excitement and hype for the
event it can be advertised on other
social media platforms to generate some
hype as well these videos can also help
you bring up your product to a larger
audience and at a reduced cost
here's an example of a live stream that
constantly keeps a track of subscribers
increasing for some of the most popular
YouTube channels next at number 11 we
have Ama or ask me anything sessions
the AMA or ask me anything sessions are
usually live streams or pre-recorded
sessions that feature questions
collected from the audience although it
originated from Reddit these videos are
finding a success on YouTube thanks to
the interactivity that it offers these
sessions can also give your audience the
opportunity to interact with you provide
suggestions feedback and much more
here's an example of AMA session with
the actor Matt Damon where questions
covering a wide variety of topics
collected from Reddit were answered by
him
next at number 12 we have interviews
interviewing someone interesting or of
an authority within your Niche can go a
long way to grow your audience these
sessions are doubly advantageous too
firstly you and by extension your
audience get to interact with an
industry style word and since this video
can be shared on your channel as well as
theirs you can expose your channel to a
brand new audience here's an example of
an interview between Marcus Brownlee a
popular Tech YouTuber with Bill Gates
the interview covers a wide variety of
topics and maintains a pleasant theme
throughout let's now go to number 13
testimonials a testimonial video help
highlight the positive feedback from a
client or a customer they provide social
proof and provide a unique perspective
on your products and services these
videos can greatly help improve people's
trust on your brand shareability and
credibility here's an example of Simply
learns testimonial video that covers a
learner's Journey as he grew in his
career video thanks to Simply learn
certification a video like this can be
greatly relatable to the audience and
even encourage some of them to take up a
certification let's go to our next video
idea that is a number 14 whiteboard
videos a whiteboard video offers your
visually attractive way of explaining
complex Concepts usually this involves a
trained experts breaking through a
complex topic on a whiteboard nowadays
there has also been the trend of digital
whiteboard videos that work thanks to
the visual style and Charisma of the
narrator here is an example of the
Whiteboard video Simply learn created
covering various concepts of social
media marketing with the help of an
engaging narrative and interesting
visuals next up we have number 15
competitions competitions or contest
videos give your audience the
opportunity to get involved with your
channel these videos enable you to
generate fresh and original content with
little from your end
in an interesting example for foldable
flight Channel users submitted their
ideas for paper airplanes that would go
to the farthest distance the channel
received a significant amount of
submissions and saw considerable growth
next we have 16 the lists list videos
are some of the most commonly found
content on YouTube most users enjoy this
type of content thanks to it being small
easily digestible and bite-sized
these videos can cover a wide range of
topics like options to choose from the
best products techniques and much more
the main advantage of these videos are
they provide users with value while
further involving them with your channel
here's an example of a list that we have
created on the top 10 skills you need to
become a data analyst in the year 2021
if you are interested don't forget to
check it out at number 17 we have case
studies case studies talk about how your
product or service have benefited
clients and users
videos like this can greatly improve
relatability and making your brand seem
more likeable
here's a video that analyzes Coca-Cola's
marketing campaign and what it made one
of the most popular brands in the world
now let's talk about content that may
not be necessarily for a brand but for
individual creators at number 18 we have
Tech unboxing these videos usually
involve packages being open for the
first time while these are fairly common
for technology these videos have also
found success in fashion apparel these
videos enable the users to experience
the products for the first time
sometimes even helping them decide
between rival products here's an example
of PS5 being inboxed by Marcus Brownlee
who goes into detail regarding each of
its console components controllers and
other specifications at number 19 we
have tech reviews where tech reviews you
can talk about the various features of a
particular product what you liked about
it what you didn't its price and other
practical information and much more
here we have an example of OnePlus 8 Pro
being reviewed in detail covering its
many features advantages disadvantages
and much more and finally we have number
20 reaction videos reaction videos are
exactly what the name says you giving an
emotional reaction to something like a
movie trailer music video or TV episode
these videos encourage a large amount of
Engagement from the audience and make
your brand seem more relatable here's an
example of a reaction video involving
teenagers reacting to the latest tech
talk videos these videos usually enable
a large amount of likes comments and
shares keyword research so basically
what we want to do is Center our
keywords just like our website we want
to set our keywords around or our
content around good keywords so the
videos on YouTube are no different than
the web pages on our website so if we
have somebody who states YouTube is the
world's second most well well-known
engine well it is because it's right
behind Google it's not a search engine
per se it's a video platform but if it
was a search engine it'd probably be
second right behind Google so YouTube is
pretty popular majority people use
YouTube search every day to watch videos
on a number of different topics so they
can find these videos in Google but
because YouTube's so powerful and so
popular people go directly right into
YouTube for their searches and so the
whole idea behind YouTube being the
second most well-known search engine is
centered around keywords so if you have
the right keywords for your video then
the chances of you ranking higher
increases on YouTube so we're gonna
share with you a few easy ways to do
keyword research this is the most
important step in getting your videos to
rank on YouTube just like for those of
you who watched any of the SEO videos we
produced it simply learn you know that
keyword research is so essential to
getting your web pages to rank on Google
well it's no different keyword research
and choosing the right keywords is just
as important for your videos as is for
your web pages so we're going to go into
a few things to do here to find the
right keywords so we have the search
suggestion you can look at your
competitors we have different tools we
can use some other factors involved in
Google itself so let's start talking
about some of these ways to really hone
in and do some good research on your
keywords to align them with your videos
the first thing is search suggest so
YouTube has a feature called
autocomplete so if you've done any
searches on Google it's very similar if
you're typing something in to YouTube
search then YouTube is going to suggest
other related popular keywords so let's
take a look at that if we go back to
YouTube for a second and I just type in
machine learning YouTube is going to
populate on the autocomplete in the
search bar some other popular keywords
that we can potentially use or in this
case if I Choose You Know machine
learning tutorial I'm going to see a
video about machine learning tutorial so
here you can see Simply Orange ranked
number one from a machine learning
tutorial but there are other videos that
show up in my search result so we want
to be able to use the search suggestion
box in the search box field so when
we're typing in something you know
YouTube just like on Google is going to
give us those suggestions so if we're
focusing a video on machine learning
then you know we have some ideas of some
other keywords that we could center
around because these are are popular
keywords these are key words that people
are using to search on YouTube so that's
one suggestion looking at competitors is
another suggestion so we could search
for keywords used by our competitors in
their video and title and description so
let me talk little bit about that what
you want to do is you want to go to that
particular channel of your competitor so
when you go to your particular
competitors YouTube channel you want to
be able to click on the videos tab when
you click on the videos tab then you're
going to sort by most popular and then
what you could do is see a list of
videos and then when you look at a list
of videos you're going to choose a video
and then what you're going to do then is
take a look at the keywords used in the
title description and then once you do
that you're going to have a list of
keywords that you can use yourself for
that video so for example let's go back
to YouTube so if I go to type in simply
learn here's our Channel page just by
clicking on simply learn I click on
videos ever wonder if there's so now I
can see all of them ever wonder if
there's an easier way go back so here I
can see all the videos sort by most
popular once they do that then I can
choose a video this is the most popular
video right now for simply learn I click
on that video it's automatically going
to start playing but what I could do is
simply just look at you know the content
description so just by clicking show
more I can see all the content that
align with this video that's one way to
do it is simply by looking at your
competitors now what you could also do
is look at the tags associated with the
particular video and so what you want to
do is you want to look at the HTML and
so that means looking at the page source
so just like web pages what YouTube does
is they look at meta tags so if you call
from SEO in order to get your pages to
rank you need to have a title tag and a
meta tag description so videos are no
different what we're doing for YouTube
is aligning certain keywords with the
video so if you take a look and do a
search for keywords by viewing the page
Source you're going to see all the
keywords associated with a particular
video so for example if I go back to
YouTube and I look at the page source of
a video Let's just say this video here
Facebook's ad tutorial I'm going to pull
up the page source and all I need to do
is control F and type in keywords and
now for that Facebook video I can see
all the keywords associated with the
video so you can see there's a lot of
different keywords we're aligning with
this video and so why do we want to do
that because we want you know our video
to show up for keywords that people may
type in and so if you use that YouTube
autocomplete it's going to give you
those ideas this most popular keywords
so if they're related align those
keywords with the video so here you can
see Facebook marketing Facebook ad
strategy Facebook ads for beginners so
forth and so on so there's a lot of
keywords we've aligned here with that
particular video and again all you need
to do is look at the page source so
right click in view page Source do a
control F for keywords and and you'll be
able to see the keywords aligned so you
could do that for your competitors
videos as well so you could see what
keywords your competitors using for a
video that's most popular for their
Channel and is also ranking on YouTube
and on Google so using the autocomplete
gives you those keyword ideas looking at
your competitors videos also gives you
some other ideas for keywords that you
can align with a video that's relevant
that you want to rank for so let's look
at some other ideas here so you can
install plugins and there are plenty of
plugins available on the Chrome browser
that will help you see the video tags
associated with a particular video so a
couple of examples are vid IQ and
tubebuddy those are extensions that work
in Chrome and what they do is they give
you the exact tags that a particular
video is using so for example if I go
back here and I look at a video on
YouTube let's just say the machine learn
learning Basics video I have vid IQ
installed on my Chrome browser so just
by clicking on that vid IQ is going to
give me a lot of information about that
video they're just going to give me an
overview of their particular metrics
they're going to give me some other
information associated with Facebook
some engagement metrics really what I'm
interested in is those keywords so if I
scroll down a bit here I can see the
video tags associated with the machine
learning Basics video so vid IQ is
telling me is these keywords are
associated with this video and not only
does it show me what keywords are
associated I can also see where they
rank so for machine learning Basics this
particular video ranks number one if I
go down I could see what is machine
learning and how does it work I can see
it's rank number two here I could see
machine learning algorithms it's ranked
number nine so I can get some ideas of
the types of keywords that are being
used as tag tags for that video further
down I can also see some Channel tags
but really this is the video tags or the
idea place I want to be able to look to
get an idea of the types of keywords
that are associated with the video that
are also ranking or not ranking so
that's another way for you to really get
an understanding of what keywords to use
at the particular video so autocomplete
you can look at the page source of a
competitors video or you can use a
Chrome extension in this case I'm using
vid IQ to give me some information about
the video tags for a particular video so
according to an industry study using
keywords and video tags will help you
rank well on YouTube so you have to use
keywords and video tags if you want your
video to rank there's been a lot of
studies YouTube is so popular and videos
are so prominent in today's world where
if you have videos and you're going to
upload them to YouTube then associate
the right keywords with those videos so
some important factors when we look at
keywords what we want to do is look at
search volume we want to look at
competition we want to look at relevancy
we want to look at the primary and
secondary keywords that we want to use
so well chosen keywords will help you
rank so we just gave you some ideas on
how to do some keyword research again
those ideas were really to use the
autocomplete on YouTube or Google
they're going to give you some popular
keywords you can look what your
competitors are doing by looking at the
page source and just looking at the
keywords that are aligned with that
video or you can use a third-party
extension in Chrome in my example I use
vid IQ that gave me the keywords
associated with that video so you have
ways to get the keywords so what we want
to do is we want to make sure we choose
keywords with high search volume they're
going to drive more traffic to your
video however we want to balance it out
with key words that have low difficulty
and are easier to rank for so you don't
want to choose something very broad
that's just going to be very difficult
to rank for and of course we always want
to go with relevancy so for talking
about machine learning Basics then we
want to choose keywords associated with
that and that's where that autocomplete
comes in handy because what Google's
going to do and YouTube's going to do is
give us keywords that are very closely
related to the video that we're trying
to optimize for and so we have a number
of different keywords that are disposal
that are relevant that we can look to
see if they have good volume in the
competition and so the whole idea is we
want to choose a keyword that defines
the nature of the content and then what
we want to do is support that with
secondary keywords so we want keywords
that are highly relevant to the primary
keyword so that's the way to go about
aligning your keywords you want keywords
that are high volume low competition or
relevant and you want to choose that one
key keyword that is really what the
content's about and then those secondary
keywords that support the primary so if
you have a machine learning video you
could choose your primary keyword as in
this case the machine learning Basics
video so well chosen keywords help you
rank well on YouTube just like the
machine learning Basics so if I go back
to our video our machine learning Basics
video if I just type in machine learning
Basics I'll be able to pull it up and so
here it is if I click on it I'm going to
go to YouTube and so here I can see this
keyword we know humans learn from there
is well aligned because it's in the
title it's in the copy and it's aligned
as a keyword tagged with the video so we
know that that keyword has good volume
low competition is relevant because
that's what the video is about the
basics of machine learning it's an
introduction to machine learning so
instead of honing in on just
introduction and machine learning
primary keyword is machine learning
Basics and then we supported that video
with those secondary keywords what is
machine learning because somebody who
doesn't know machine learning is
probably going to type in that keyword
and then introduction to machine
learning is a good secondary keyword
because it's explaining the basics of
what machine learning is all about so
primary keyword machine learning basic
secondary keywords what is machine
learning and introduction to machine
learning so that's the whole idea behind
choosing keywords you want that keyword
that really is going to define the
content and then support that with those
secondary keywords so remember when
you're performing your keyword research
choose keywords for your videos that
Google shows on the video results page
so what I mean by that is your video can
get more views if you rank on Google as
well so the whole idea is not
necessarily to be found on YouTube it's
also to be found on Google so if I go
back to Google and I just type in data
science for beginners and I type in
videos then you can see we're ranked
number one so you even if you're not
looking at the videos clicking on the
videos link on Google search you can
always just when you do a search what
Google's going to do is also put in the
videos here on par as part of the search
results so what they're going to show
you is the top videos that are ranking
for that particular keyword and so we
may not rank overall for data science
for beginners but we're ranked number
one in the videos category and so if
somebody's looking for a video that's
important and you can see here that
these first two are ads so what Google
is doing is they're saying hey this is
so relevant this particular video for
the keyword query data science for
beginners that we're going to show it
above the organic listings even though
it's a video so the whole idea is to be
found on YouTube and Google because
you're increasing your visibility you're
increasing your chances of getting found
on both search platforms so according to
backlinko google Ranks videos with
keywords like how to tutorials so you
know a lot of the videos that you find
on YouTube are going to be instructional
based and so what Google's doing is
they're saying hey if somebody types in
how to or tutorial or an introduction to
anything that's going to signal to
Google that it's instructional it's
going to help you rank so when you
search for machine learning tutorial or
how to become a machine learning
engineer you're going to get results
related to that because if you look at
these examples we have machine learning
tutorial in our title or how to become a
machine learning engineer so keep that
in mind if you're creating a video and
it's educational in nature you know use
those key terms like how to and
tutorials in the video title because
that will help you rank so let's move
over now to video title so we want to
use our Target keyword in the title of
the video and again we want to make sure
if it's education additional to include
that keyword tutorial or how to so for
every video title YouTube has a limit of
100 characters so we really have to pick
and choose really wisely so if we look
at the video that we were focusing on a
couple of minutes ago so machine
learning Basics here we could see under
100 characters we have machine learning
Basics what is machine learning
introduction to machine learning and
then the brand name so that is the title
of this particular video so it takes
into account the primary keyword the
secondary keywords and the title and it
also includes that really the key term
that really Google and YouTube like and
that's what is machine learning so it's
helping us Rank by having our keywords
in the title with that key phrase what
is okay so that's a good tidbit on
creating a good video title is to align
it with the right keywords your primary
and your secondary and so we want to use
the those catchy words and numbers to
gain High click-through rates just like
you would on the title tag of your web
page we want to do the same with our
video title because the video titles
what's going to show up in search so if
I go back to you know search here we
could see you know data science tutorial
data science for beginners so we want to
make sure in this case you can see data
science in five minutes so that was
purposely done so that hey I don't have
time to watch a video I only have a
couple minutes data science in five
minutes okay great I'm going to click on
the video and now I have an opportunity
to watch something and learn something
under five minutes so choosing the right
words in your video title is going to
help you get that click-through rate up
remember clicked array is clicks divided
by Impressions and an impression is how
many times your video shows up and the
search results on YouTube or Google so
we want to keep our click-through rate
high and in order to do that we want to
be able to write some really good title
tags for our video so use catchy words
like a number or how to or what is
because that's going to resonate with
people when they're searching now for
the description what we want to do is we
want to use the target word at the
beginning of the description the title
and the tags itself so if I go back to
my video here machine learning Basics we
know it's in the video title and right
off the bat if I look at the description
of the video here I can see this machine
learning Basics video will help you
understand what is machine learning so
our primary keyword is in the first
sentence right in the introductory of
the description and so that's going to
bode well for optimizing our video the
description length is 5 000 characters
so we have a lot of characters to work
with so if I go back to my video I click
show more we have a lot of characters to
really describe what the video is about
okay there's no shortage no shortage of
including keywords into the content so
you have 5 000 characters go ahead and
see if you can work in naturally your
keywords but one of the key tips here is
just make sure that first sentence
starts out with that keyword that's a
good tip of course you always want to
make it sound natural as possible you
don't want to stuff it with keywords at
the same time work them in naturally
work in your keywords naturally and then
include hashtags in your description to
help the audience find your video is
easily so if I go back here you know we
want to be able to include hashtags so
hashtags it's like anything else you
would use on social media it just
signals to the end user hey this is what
the video is all about and if I go ahead
and type in that keyword then it's our
video has a better chance because it's a
line with that hashtag and then there's
Target keywords and LSI keywords latent
semantic indexing keywords we want to be
able to use those keywords as Target
keywords with our video so if you recall
the example I gave a few minutes ago we
used the Facebook ads tutorial as our
example here I could see all the target
keywords associated with that particular
video so don't be afraid to use those
LSI related keywords meaning keywords
that are related to the content use them
as Target keywords with the video so
between your LSI keywords Target
keywords and then using our primary and
secondary keyword in the title tag using
our primary and secondary keyword in the
description and then using hashtags in
the description the combination of all
of that if we chose the right keyword
then we should find that our video will
eventually rank on YouTube so just doing
these small tidbits with our keywords
really help get our video to rank so at
the end of the day we want to be able to
use the tools available to Us YouTube
Itself by looking at our competitors
those extensions like vid IQ the
autocomplete to really find our good
keywords and then incorporating those
keywords into you know the title tag the
description as Target keywords hashtags
we should really be off and running with
our video on YouTube if you try to
figure out what those seven are you
might come up with a list but let me
share it with you because it's the
outline for this short course
um first thing is you've got to make
YouTube a key part of your social media
marketing strategy I know it probably is
it may be but we're going to tell you
where it fits and why it probably isn't
getting the kind of resources that it
deserves
in this uh first part we're also going
to talk about how you can create the
type of video content that your target
audience will want to watch
and uh we're also going to talk about
scheduling your videos and optimizing
your content and then in the next module
we'll get to the rest of the top seven
strategies so let's begin with uh the
first thing that you really got to get
your arms around it turns out according
to recent research YouTube is the
largest
video sharing site I'm sure that didn't
shock you you knew that part but it's
also the largest social media site in
the United States
and that may surprise you
in other words YouTube has slightly more
unique visitors a month in the US
than Facebook
and I can't tell you how many people who
have a social media marketing strategy
say oh yeah yeah Facebook Twitter uh
LinkedIn right need to have LinkedIn all
of those are social mediums those are
things that you should have programs
around
but excuse me YouTube is too big to be
ignoring
oh by the way there's some other people
say yeah but what about Vimeo well Vimeo
is on the list of the top 10 but it's in
10th Place
so yeah let's start with YouTube in this
particular course if we have time to get
through the other nine underneath it God
bless you good luck but you know what
we're going to focus on YouTube
now one of the things that marketers
have been complaining about lately is
that Facebook has been taking away some
of the features that made it such a
wonderful place to do marketing on it's
a little harder now things are changing
things aren't working the way they used
to
[Music]
even
industry analysts
at Forester have said you know what it's
time to tell it like it is Facebook
seems more interested in your ad dollars
unless interested in you actually using
it as a marketing platform
meanwhile at the same time
YouTube has been going through some
Transformations and in order to be a
little more brand friendly one of the
things that they've done lately
is they've cleaned up the comments area
underneath videos and now they'll do
some Auto searching for well let's just
put it this way hate words uh trolls
there's a lot of things now that you can
do to moderate the comments underneath
your YouTube video that actually makes
it a more interesting social media to
engage your prospects and clients with
so I think if you net all this out what
it means is that yeah YouTube needs to
be a key part of your social media
marketing strategy
and even if you don't make it like
number one on the list which frankly I
think it probably should be
it still needs to be right up there
uh it's not an afterno thought it's not
something that you should get to when
you have the spare time
it ought to be a priority and that means
if you've delayed getting your arms
around this thing or well we created a
YouTube channel and we uploaded a few
30-second ad spots and nothing magical
happened
it's like yeah yeah that's why you're
here in the short course let me tell you
what you do next
one of the things that you need to
understand is what are people actually
watching and it turns out repurposed
30-second television ads ranks really
low on the list
and if that's all you're putting on your
YouTube channel check out what actually
is being watched more often than not
it's um everything from product teasers
to how-to videos in other words there's
ways to use YouTube for marketing
purposes Way Beyond a repurposed 30
second spot
this is also true with B2B
YouTube is a wonderful B2B marketing
platform in fact this is a case study of
a company called sonosite they're in the
medical products industry they sell to
hospitals so it is a B2B cell and they
sell several hundred thousand dollars
worth of portable ultrasound equipment
and they used you to quite effectively
to surprise surprise shorten the sales
cycle
and in a B2B cell that's money in the
bank how did they shorten it well
there's always a committee that makes
these kinds of decisions and not
everybody on the committee got to meet
with the sales rep and so not everybody
in the committee is fully up to the
speed with features and benefits of the
product
but if there's Video available of how
the product works all of a sudden a
whole lot of those questions that may
slow up the sales process get answered
and sales get completed in fact they
were able to grow their revenue 12
percent year over year
by basically using video to shorten the
sales cycle
so you want to be able to create the
kind of video content that your Target
customers watch the most and trust me it
is not hard to get corporate approval to
create how-to videos
we're not talking about you've got to
convince them to do more funny cats I
mean that's not what you want to work
what you want to use to Market your
products unless you're selling cat food
of course
but guess what you can create a range of
video content that will engage your
prospects will move them along
um you know the purchase process
and at the end of the day can be a key
part of both your social media marketing
campaign and frankly your content
marketing campaign it it's pretty useful
stuff
now here's the bad news this is another
reason why people who've tried to dabble
on YouTube haven't seen much success and
then came to the premature conclusion
that well this just doesn't work for us
the answer is they dabbled
meanwhile a whole lot of other people
who've been incredibly successful on
YouTube
our uploading content if not daily
then at least several times a week
and this includes brands that you know
frankly are doing very very well as well
as some of the YouTube Stars which
frankly all of us should watch because
we can learn a lot of interesting
lessons from people who you know have
built their own franchise on YouTube
so you know surprise surprise you need
to start thinking about how the heck do
we go about creating more content I mean
that's going to take effort well of
course it does
well it helps to have a plan and it
helps to understand that you can have
more than one type of video one type of
video that the YouTube calls hygiene
content to Define this in sort of terms
that I think most of us marketers would
understand and might want to reuse
around the boardroom table
we can do our keyword research discover
which questions people are asking on
YouTube and then create videos that
answer those questions
one of the people who does this
incredibly well is Matt Cutz of Google
you know every one of the videos that he
is uploading on almost a weekly basis is
Matt you know I just got this question
from a guy named Matt and let me answer
it well sometimes Matt writes questions
to himself so it must have been a slow
week but the point is it is compelling
viewing I mean those of us in the
industry who are trying to keep up with
the latest wrinkles at Google are
watching Matt's videos every week
so that's one type of content
you can also create a web series where
if it's Monday then we're going to
feature yet another one of our wonderful
customers talking about how they're
using our product in their industry or
business
and then occasionally you can create
something really special and the people
who sort of taught me this trick are
over at the discovery digital Networks
and I don't know if you've heard of it
but there's something called Shark Week
and who invented Shark Week the people
at the Discovery Channel and when does
it happen some week in August and what
does it feature a whole lot of video
about sharks
and who declared this Shark Week well
they did they made it up you can make
stuff up too
so whether you're doing Q a whether
you're doing uh ongoing series whether
you're doing something special once a
year guess what you can build out a
programming schedule
just the way those big honchos up at NBC
ABC and CBS do for every fall you can do
it for your annual
YouTube channel
so
key to being successful
key to being effective develop a
programming strategy and then plot out
your content because you know what it's
a heck of a lot easier to create more
content if you're not trying to
pull a rabbit out of your hat every
other week
it helps if you have a plan because then
suddenly you can shoot half a dozen
episodes on the same day you just happen
to upload them over the next six weeks
that's a way to keep your budget sort of
in line in your production capabilities
don't have to grow beyond what you can
afford and yet
you know you now have a heck of a lot
more content that you can play out over
the course of a year
you'd also want to optimize your video
so they can get found in search right
right but let me share with you the
first rookie mistake that most people
make when it comes to optimizing a video
they use Google Keyword tools to try to
figure out what terms to put on their
YouTube videos
and pardon me when people use Google to
do a search
believe it or not they use different
Search terms or in some cases they may
use the same term but in different
volumes than when they're on YouTube and
let me just share this quick example
with you it turns out that Google Trends
now not only gives you what the Google
interest is in a particular term you
know they've had that since day one
but you know in the last year they've
also added a drop down menu option to
say oh I want to see YouTube search
Trends so you can use the same tool to
see both and this example here shows the
terms Chevrolet
and Chevy
and in Google it's a horse race it's
about 50 50 you know even Steven you
could pick it either term what the heck
in YouTube it's no contest Chevy has
almost twice as many searches on YouTube
as Chevrolet
and so this is just a quick illustration
that when you want to do your video
research you want to use video research
tools
then of course you want to optimize your
video and there's more to it than just
putting the right keywords in the right
places that used to work and it used to
be sufficient that's what YouTube calls
metadata so you want to put those
keywords in your titles and your
descriptions and your tags okay got it
YouTube changed its algorithm to include
something called watch time
in other words if people start to watch
your video and go eh boring or oh
corporate propaganda
and they stop watching you don't have
very much watch time and guess what your
video doesn't rank very well
so you know surprise surprise surprise
you're going to have to create some
pretty compelling video content or some
pretty interesting video content or some
how-to videos where nobody in their
right mind is going to bail out halfway
through and only know how to complete
half of the project
in order to get your watch time up
and then last but not least you
certainly want to make sure that your
video is distributed in lots of places
why because the YouTube player is sort
of interesting in that if it's embedded
in a blog for for example and somebody
watches the video by clicking it and
watching it while on the blog and they
never come to YouTube to watch the video
that view still counts and if they watch
it all the way to completion guess what
that counts in the algorithm back over
on YouTube in the watch time part
and so yeah find ways of not just
Distributing your video but Distributing
your video in places where it is likely
to be viewed and watched by relevant
audiences hopefully all the way through
to the end
and I can be blogs that can be your own
website
frankly it can be your Facebook page it
can be your Twitter account it can be
your LinkedIn account it can be your
Pinterest account you know what you can
share YouTube videos to all of those and
you should
so you want to be found you want to be
discovered you're going to have to
optimize your videos and your playlists
and your Channel
in order to reach and keep your audience
why all of those because if you do a
search in YouTube You'll discover that
videos
playlists and channels all come up in
the YouTube search results
and let's not forget YouTube is the
world's
second largest search engine there are
more searches done on YouTube a month
than are conducted on Bing the only
thing that's behind is Google itself
so again optimize your videos optimize
your playlist optimize your Channel and
help your videos get discovered
hello again and welcome to part two of
the YouTube and mobile video short
course in part one we covered four of
the top seven things that you need to
focus on so let's start with part five
most of us started off in the era where
if you optimize your video you could get
sufficient traffic to actually help it
get discovered these days there's more
than a hundred hours of new YouTube
video content uploaded
every minute
and unfortunately the downside is that
makes it even harder for your video to
get found in organic search
so I know I'm going to sound like I'm
straying over into the dark side this is
not the dark side this is still a white
hat tactic but one of the things that
you may need to consider is when to jump
start your campaign by using paid
media
so here's some of the things that you
have to understand to understand why
that's a white hat tactic
and by the way it's a white hack tactic
even YouTube approves of this
one of the things that you need to know
is that when you create an ad in YouTube
one of your options is not to upload a
brand new video but to take an existing
video
and promote it
in other words existing content can
quote be turned into an ad
and what that means is you can take the
new video that you've just uploaded it
and you can sort of do double duty
you've just optimized it and hopefully
it'll get found for a couple of the
Search terms that you focused it on
but then you can use YouTube advertising
which is called trueview that's the name
of their uh what Google calls AdWords
for video
and what you can do with this trueview
ad is take that basically existing
content turn it into an ad
and then have it displayed over not two
or three Search terms which is about
what you can optimize it for organically
but you can actually advertise it
against hundreds
perhaps even thousands of relevant
Search terms
and what this means is is that your
video content your video
surfaces when someone does a search on
YouTube
and if they click on it well that's then
when it's an ad and it uh and you pay
for it so you know other than the sort
of the crossover where the content came
from yeah okay got it it's like AdWords
it's an auction based system you know
get it okay whatever
but here's one of the things that
happens and this is part of the mystery
of YouTube
for every two clicks that you get that
you're paying for
somebody's going to watch that video and
say wow I'm going to share that with a
friend of mine and then their friend
watches it and when they share the video
and the friend watches it that's not an
ad
because it's your same content
and that means you don't have to pay for
it
so one of the things that YouTube has
found by examining over 6 000 recent
campaigns
is on average for every two paid clicks
that the paid Advertiser uh is paying
for they're on average getting one free
click
again this helps jump start your traffic
it helps people uh discover your video
and oh by the way the bonuses you get
people to start sharing your content if
it's compelling if it's informative if
it's something worth sharing
you can get organic views on top of the
paid views you can't do that with
regular AdWords and Google trust me but
you can do it with YouTube
so how do you succeed with trueview ads
it's a little different
because in addition to being like the
auction based system in addition to
being AdWords for video
you have a couple other options as well
one of them is you can run that ad as a
pre-roll in other words before let's say
somebody wants to watch a very popular
music video before that video starts
your quote ad which again can be regular
content that you promoted will appear
before the video that they wanted to
watch as a pre-roll ad
or what YouTube calls a true view
in stream format
and about five seconds in to your video
playing your ad starting
YouTube does something pretty amazing
that they pioneered and really blew me
away the first time I saw it they put a
little skip ad button at the bottom of
the video
which means if the viewer sees this as
an intrusion I'm sorry I wanted to go
watch the music video I don't want to
watch this ad they can click that skip
it button and go straight to the video
and here's the interesting thing for you
as a marketer if they skip your content
you pay nothing
in fact they have to watch more than 30
seconds of it before basically the meter
starts running and you then pay per
click
wow so again you're not only getting
organic views you know one for every two
that you pay for but you also are
getting people let's think about this
for a second the only ones who I have to
pay for the ones who are interested in
watching more than 30 seconds of it
you know frankly that's pretty
revolutionary so again if you have not
checked out trueview ads
you you really want to they can do some
things for you that frankly we haven't
seen in any other kind of AD format out
there from anybody else
so again the net net of this part you
can leverage paid video
to put your organic content in front of
the Right audience that's not something
you might think of doing because it's
not a tactic that you can borrow from
somewhere else it is unique to YouTube
just as trueview is unique to YouTube
just as a whole lot of the other tactics
that we're going to go through in other
words this is a big opportunity and it's
one that you want to get your arms
around even if it's a little different
now another tactic that you're going to
want to use is you want to make sure
that your video is shareable it helps if
you've got content that is shareable but
even so one of the things that sort of
put YouTube on the map in the first
place the reason why it is known as a
video sharing site
is because it has so many wonderful
options not only can you embed the video
and blogs or on websites
not only can you like email the URL to
people you know yeah yeah yeah got it
but you can also share it to Facebook
and Twitter and to Google Plus and
Pinterest and a whole bunch of other
social medias
and one of the things that you need to
understand is about oh 500 years of
YouTube video content
is watched every day on
Facebook
and there are about 700 YouTube videos
tweeted on Twitter
every minute
so again you know it's not just about
YouTube in itself the YouTube audience
is distributed and that means your video
is going viral if it's actually pretty
interesting and all those extra views
can't
now understanding that that's what it
takes to be successful why aren't more
Brands successful in fact they're
pathetic in in some Industries they
account for single digit percentage of
views of all the videos watched in that
genre or or industry at most in in let's
say the electronics Industry where they
do the best brand generated videos
Barely reach you know in the mid-20s in
terms of the percentage of content that
people are watching in that category
what happened
well what happened is most brands are in
a set it and forget it mode we'll put
the video up we're done
and most of the successful channels
particularly the vloggers who are trying
to make this their living
understand that it's also about engaging
your audience which means when they post
a comment you're still around
to respond
and you know the difference in
engagement is night and day and that's
one of the reasons why a whole lot of
the amateurs are doing a whole lot
better than a lot of Pros on YouTube
because the pros don't realize that
maybe hanging around for 15 minutes
after the video goes up is critical to
success
so the net net of this tactic you
absolutely want to amplify what your
video content says by socializing it
interacting with your prospects and you
can do it at scale
because if you're interacting with the
first
people who respond to you in the first
15 minutes everyone who comes by later
sees your response and they know the
lights are on there's somebody here who
cares
it actually encourages them to say hey
there's a community I could I can build
it around this video
as part of the secrets of the success
the other interesting thing that's worth
noting is that YouTube gives you YouTube
analytics now this wasn't always the
case there were no such thing as even
YouTube inside until 2008 analytics
wasn't old out until late 2011.
but now what YouTube is giving you for
free
with your YouTube channel
is a very robust set of analytics that
go frankly Beyond Google analytics one
of the things you will not find in
Google analytics that you will in
YouTube analytics is how people were
watching your video and when they
stopped and if you suddenly discover
everyone's bailing out 30 seconds in
you've got a problem because a you're
not getting very much watch time and
what was it that was happening at that
30 second Mark that everyone went if
give me a break I'm out of here
so there's a lot of things to learn from
your YouTube analytics if you can learn
not only did people watch it views has
been around and people have been paying
attention to that metric but it's one of
many
you know the one I urge you to look at
is your watch time and by the way which
Search terms were people using to find
your video and guess what YouTube still
shows that even if Google doesn't
and the other interesting things is you
can find out which videos people were
watching uh when they decided to
subscribe to your Channel
which videos triggered people to share
it to others on social media so you can
begin to find out where people were
interacting with you which videos out of
all the ones that you've uploaded
actually connected with the community
that's killer data
and why is it important because you then
need to bridge the next Gap
because most of your
executives are going to say well that's
nice people watched your video and they
shared it and that's great
but what they really want to know is did
they come to the website and did they
buy anything
and increasingly it's becoming a little
easier it's still not perfect to sort of
bridge that cap you know in some cases
you can use cookies in other cases you
can use
um you know links that are called
annotations to get you from the video
over to your website
but the other key is beginning to use a
multi-channel funnels
in Google Analytics
to begin understanding not only where
your traffic came from and what they did
next but oh by the way when they came
back to your site Days Later weeks later
and began doing something else in other
words we may be Upstream generating
people who come and discover our
companies or our brands or our products
early in the cycle
and then come back either having
bookmarked that page
or using organic search or come back in
some other fashion when they decide to
finally make the purchase so again
multi-channel analytics will help you
bridge that Gap
and at the end of the day you know you
really want to put together the right
key performance indicators the right
kpis
to make sure that you're measuring the
success of YouTube strategy and that
goes Way Beyond measuring views
one of the most frequent questions I get
asked is well how long should a YouTube
video be
well the answer is how long does it take
you to tell a good story
in other words there's no right time
there's either good stories or there's
not so good stories and there's some of
them are short and some of the frankly
are a little longer and unfortunately
too many marketers have drawn the
assumption that short is required
and they are making videos that are two
to three minutes long and figuring well
that's it right
interestingly enough new research from a
company called pixability says well
there are a group of people that will
watch videos that are two to three
minutes long that's okay
but even more are watching videos that
are three to ten minutes long
in other words if it takes you a little
longer to show people how to do
something
take the time to tell them how to do it
and don't try to force it into the
three-minute limit
you know at the end of the day they want
to be able to complete the job not to
get an overview of it so take the time
to tell your story
have a look at this amazing
certification in digital marketing which
is postgraduate program in digital
marketing so don't miss out on this
incredible opportunity take action today
and enroll in our course to unlock the
secrets of digital marketing success
click the link in the description box
and embark on your professional growth
and achievement Journey we are going to
talk about YouTube SEO we'll be covering
what it is what you need to know how you
can optimize your videos to get found on
YouTube and how you can use it to
maximize your views but before we go
into this let me introduce myself I am
Mark campman I am your digital navigator
for this video and as usual if you liked
the video click the like button and if
you want to join our YouTube channel
click the Subscribe button below so you
become part of our wonderful Youtube
Learning Community on on simply learned
YouTube channel so are you ready to
start let's get into some numbers here
yeah let's give you some interesting
stats about YouTube Before We Begin and
I'm gonna show you that YouTube has to
be part of your digital marketing
strategy Did You Know YouTube is the
second biggest search engine only after
Google there are 98 different language
versions on YouTube making it a global
social network now it would take a
lifetime to watch all the YouTube
content that's uploaded in the last hour
only so it's amazing amount of content
that is being uploaded we as the world's
population we watch about five billion
videos every day on YouTube
did you also know that YouTube
advertising is very important to YouTube
and to Google here they generate more
than 30 billion dollar per year in
advertising revenue and on top of that
YouTube has around 2.5 billion monthly
active users making it the second
biggest social media Network in the
world so do I need to convince you any
further that YouTube has to be part of
your digital marketing strategy
so let's talk about what you can do to
increase your chances that your videos
are going to feature in the YouTube
search results and in the
recommendations by YouTube
let's check about what we're going to
talk about in this video we will be
giving you an overview of what is
YouTube SEO
yeah how do you optimize your videos for
YouTube
um how does YouTube search work and how
does your YouTube search engine
optimization work I'm going to share
with you about 10 tips for optimizing
your video for search on YouTube and
then at the end I'm going to share with
you my favorite YouTube SEO tools I will
also show you in a demo where to find
all the tools that you can use within
YouTube and within some of those tools
to optimize your videos for SEO
so let's start with explaining what is
YouTube SEO as mentioned earlier YouTube
is the second most popular search engine
right after Google in fact YouTube
searches are actually more in numbers
than Microsoft Bing AOL and ask.com
combined so we're talking about a very
important part of your search strategy
YouTube as I mentioned earlier has about
2.6 billion active monthly users as of
2022 making it the second biggest social
media Network
only
um proceeded by by Facebook yeah so now
62 percent of global consumers say they
use YouTube and since the creation of
YouTube its Mission has been to provide
fast and easy video access to users and
the ability to share videos frequently
and since then it has grown Beyond
expectations now with so many people
uploading videos on the one hand and
watching videos on the other hand how
you do you make sure that your video
features in the top of the YouTube
search results
and that's where YouTube SEO plays a
vital role
so before I explain YouTube seo let me
give you a little bit of a history about
YouTube late 2004 an idea for a website
for users to upload video dating
profiles was born and in February 2005
the website launched to a small subset
of users as I said earlier I say video
dating platform now based on feedback
from their subscribers in April 25 or
April 2005 YouTube turned into a free
video hosting platform where each clip
had a unique Link in April 2005 the
first video ever was uploaded on the
website by one of the the YouTube
Founders and in May 2005 YouTube
launches its better version to the
public for the first time and it became
a massive hit in a year later October
and six Google acquired YouTube for the
not too small amount of 1.6 billion US
dollars in 2007 YouTube allowed YouTube
creators people who upload videos to
earn money from their content based on
ad Revenue yet turning their hobby into
a career and that of course gave a
tremendous push of people getting into
YouTube creating content for YouTube
where they could link it to advertising
where they could make a substantial
income now in no November 2008 YouTube
expands it ad offering to sponsored
videos and free pre-roll ads and in 2009
they launched a new music video service
called Vivo in collaboration with
fevendi so it moved on in 2010 one of
the most famous YouTubers Felix kelberg
joins YouTube to create content under
the Channel's name pewdp and that is now
one of the biggest channels that you can
find on YouTube in April 2011 YouTube
entered the broadcast business launching
YouTube live and in August 2012 2012 it
became the go-to place for presidential
elections by launching the YouTube
elections Hub it grew exponentially and
by 2013
YouTube had reached over a billion
monthly users
some other interesting facts in January
2016 the music video for Adele's hello
was the fastest video on YouTube ever to
hit 1 billion views
and a very strategic move for YouTube
was in November 2018 when they rolled
out a stories-like feature YouTube
shorts yep where they would sort of
relate to Snapchat and Instagram stories
where videos are automatically deleted
after a day
in November 2019 YouTube announced that
the service would phase out the classic
version of YouTube Studio yep and to all
YouTube creators by Spring 2020 and I'll
show you later what the latest version
of YouTube studio is all about in July
2021 YouTube did a massive cleanup of
all unlisted videos prior to 2017 were
set to be private making them unplayable
and in 2022 YouTube becomes the second
biggest social media Network after
Facebook so a whirlwind of a development
of a growth of an adoption in the market
it's being played and being used all
over the world and it is the channel of
choice for the younger generation to
watch TV and to watch video so a
spectacular development for a fantastic
channel so what is YouTube SEO now
YouTube SEO is a set of activities that
you need to do to enhance the search
rankings of your YouTube videos and or
your YouTube channel in other in other
words when a user does a query on the
YouTube search bar yeah which is related
to your videos what you do what do you
need to do to make sure that your video
features higher in the YouTube search
rankings or in the recommended videos
based on that search
now many businesses of today they see
the power of search for a YouTube it has
showing up and the importance of showing
up higher in the search results it helps
them to reach more people because more
people will click on the the video links
it helps in building and promoting their
brand it helps them in creating customer
engagements more people will like the
videos more people will engage with the
videos and it is a great opportunity for
Brands to Showcase their expertise so it
is a no-brainer for businesses to be on
YouTube these days and to put all the
effort in place to show up high in the
search rankings
so as you know the engine of a search
engine is what we call the algorithm so
before we dive a bit deeper into YouTube
SEO let's have a look at this YouTube
algorithm YouTube says in their own
documentation that the algorithm is a
feedback loop in real time that
recommends videos to individual viewers
according to their different interests
now quality of the user experience
wasn't
that important at the initial start of
YouTube for the first seven years
YouTube rewarded videos that got the
highest number of clicks or views
yes so all based on number of clicks and
number of views but soon content
creators started to abuse the algorithm
approach and tricked people into getting
more views because of clickbait video
titles or catchy thumbnails so Google
had to do something about this and to
tackle this misuse of clicks and Views
and improve the user experience
today announced an update to the
algorithm in 2012. they prioritized
considering videos that had higher
attention time a higher watch time a
longer watch time
but still YouTube wasn't able to provide
what an individual user was looking for
so in 2016 they announced another update
to their algorithm and that's where they
announced to do to use machine learning
and deep neural networks for its
recommendation system completely
changing the user experience of a
YouTube user in other words YouTube is
focused on hooking users into valuable
addictive content based on their
interests
yes so how does YouTube SEO work
let's dig a bit deeper into the YouTube
algorithm overall the YouTube algorithm
affects the search results and the
recommendation streams so what do I mean
with that
in response to a user's query the
YouTube's algorithm analyzes videos
across thousands and thousands of
channels to return a list of the most
relevant videos
and the YouTube search results are
highly affected by YouTube's algorithm
yeah and the factors that will make your
video pop up in a user search query are
your videos comments the likes the watch
time you can call this engagement
your videos titled the description the
keywords the tags we call this the
metadata that matches the user's query
yeah so a lot of reasons yeah why the
YouTube algorithm picks your video to
show up higher in the search results
now the algorithm goes through a
two-fold process for recommending videos
to a user
yeah there is the search results but the
second part of this the SEO is the
recommending video to a user which you
see on the left side after your search
results first it ranks video Based on
data of their performance Analytics
so for instance videos that are trending
they have a higher priority
second it matches videos based on the
user's history and the similar content
they may have watched earlier so
ultimately they would end up spending
more time on the platform going through
as many videos as possible automatically
watching as many ads as possible
so now you got an idea about the end
goal of YouTube's algorithm in 2022 and
how it works to create a better user
experience
right now that you understand the
YouTube algorithm
how can you make this algorithm work
with you what I'm going to do here I'm
going to share 10 tips with you on how
to optimize your videos for search so
let's start with tip number one tip
number one is to make sure that you
conduct your keyword research before you
optimize your videos
make sure your keywords are relevant to
your video
because they allow YouTube to determine
the video topic and index the content
and relate it to the user queries
so here are five simple steps for you to
do to do your video keyword research
first start with topics that you want to
be an authority for
identify those topics and then for each
of these topics you generate keyword
ideas you find those keyword ideas by
going on YouTube for the YouTube
suggests and you can go to Google as
well you go to other video platforms you
go to keyword recommendation tools
yes so you generate keyword ideas then
for those keyword ideas you're going to
look for monthly search volumes and the
difficulty for those keywords how
difficult is it to get a higher search
ranking for those keywords
and there are tools that you can use to
find out about these keyword metrics
you're then going to conduct a YouTube
serp analysis so you're going to analyze
the search engine result page for your
keywords and find out what you can see
yeah it's a serp analysis is very
important because it helps you to
determine the types of keywords that are
currently ranking for that keywords or
the type of videos that are currently
ranking for that video
it helps you in determining the quality
of those videos and it also helps you in
determining the search intent for those
keywords why are people searching for
those words is it with a buying intent
is it with a learning intent or is it
with an informational intent
and the fifth tip or your keyword
research is to select those Target
keywords that are the most that have the
I search volume of the the the the the
best competitive
difficulty yeah so it's finding the
right balance and come up with a list of
keywords that you can start using for
your videos
and then you're going to assign those
keywords to your video
yeah and make sure that those keywords
are relevant to the content
and that you use them in the title that
you use them in the thumbnail that you
used them in the the the
transcription of the video and I'll tell
you more a bit about that in a little
bit yes so it is all about capturing the
content of the video make it unique and
encouraging viewers to watch your
content so keyword research is a very
important topic
second is to make sure that you use the
right title for your videos
titles is critical there are two
elements of your video that will decide
whether people watch a video or not it
is the title of the video and it is the
thumbnail of the video and more about
the thumbnail later so get a good catchy
title
make sure your keywords are in your
title as well yes so it's not only about
explaining the content of the video in a
very strong title but also
encouraging people to click on the video
link
yeah so your keywords and your title
play a very important role in this
right let's look at the third tip that
is the description of your video
yeah and for the algorithm the
description is very important the
algorithm uses the description to check
the topic of the video so make sure that
your description includes the keywords
as well
so the video description is the text
below each of your videos and viewers
can read the YouTube video description
by clicking on the see more button below
the video
yeah so these descriptions usually
include a short explanation of what the
video is about including the relevant
keywords links to any resources
mentioned in the video maybe affiliate
links website links maybe social media
handles
definitely asked if you were to
subscribe and chapters and timestamps
and Google now has the feature to sort
of split up the content of your video in
timestamps and people can jump from
timestamp to time stamp
so YouTube descriptions including all
the right elements like the informative
text the links the buttons they can help
the viewer to discover your video can
help you to increase your subscribers to
increase your views and to increase your
watch time
so tip four is about tags
very important to add tags to your video
YouTube uses tags to effectively index
and search for videos but also to
suggest other videos you might be
interested in
they help again the YouTube algorithm to
understand what your content is all
about and to serve it to the right users
so here are some best practice tips on
using tags don't overdo them don't use
too many tags
use trending texts yeah so find trending
topics with YouTube Auto suggest
yeah so and use those trending text be
specific with your tags for example a
road trip is a tag that is less Broad
and has a higher chance of ranking well
in search engine than for instance the
word vacation because that is too
generic
also includes synonyms think about the
words your audience is likely to use
when describing the topic of your video
and use those synonyms to broaden the
reach of your tags and if you're you out
of ideas user tag generator to identify
related and potentially trending tags a
really good tool for this is tune pocket
right let's move on let's go to the next
tip tip number five YouTube creates
transcriptions and captions for your
videos
and you can create your own
transcription
because the algorithm can't interpret
visual content only text and code so if
you can transform your video in text
through a transcription that can really
help in your search Effectiveness so a
transcription is the translation of what
is spoken in the video
and you can use this transcription for
subtitles in your video as well
they will also help you to generate
captions for your timestamps in your
video now very important YouTube will
automatically generate a transcription
file
but be aware this transcription file
will not be indexed for search the
because the raw file may have typos or
wrong translations wrong interpretations
from the Google automatic transcriber
so what you need to do is that you edit
the transcription file and take out a
typo and the mistakes and once you've
done that you've then uploaded that
transcription file up to your video and
once you've uploaded It Again YouTube
will then index the file and use it for
the search
so very important and I'll show you
later where you can find the
transcription file
tip number six think about the length of
your videos
focus on both the watch time and the
video length
and let's be realistic about it if it
takes 20 minutes to explain how to do
something yeah on your video then make a
20 minute video if you can say it in one
minute then make a one minute video
Don't Waste people's time by stretching
out your content just to hit a certain
number of minutes it's not about how
long your video is it is about when
people stop watching your video
if you can keep watching if you can keep
people watching longer than average then
you'll get more views and eventually you
will get more subscribers
now YouTube wants to recommend videos
that people stay engaged with or in
other words watch longer so if you can
increase your watch time for your videos
then YouTube will reward you with better
rankings in search results and
recommendations across their site which
ultimately leads to more viewers
so a good way to keep people engaged is
to use screens and YouTube cards
and that is tip six
yeah so an end screen is the YouTube
feature that appears in the last 5 to 20
seconds of your video and you can use it
to promote videos playlists merchandise
and external websites your end screen
can help you to get more views more
traffic and subscribers from every video
YouTube cards are a bit more flexible
they are interactive cards that you see
throughout a video
that let you share clickable links to
relevant content throughout your video
you can use those cards to promote a
related video or playlists to promote
your YouTube channel to encourage
viewers to take a call or to take a poll
to direct responses to a verified
off-site location like a specific
landing page or to ask viewers to donate
to a charity this will only work for the
US by the way so non-us
viewers cannot do those donations to
charity
right next tip
mixtape is making sure that you increase
audience engagement by increasing the
watch time of your video
yes so this is all about the content of
your video
and be clever with the content in your
video try to use elements of surprise in
your video or changing the pace of the
music or ask for audio participation for
instance by adding a quiz in your video
very important to maintain people's
interests
yeah and some other tips that you can do
to keep people's interest is to make
sure you have a strong video opening
yeah where you captures people's initial
interest to make sure that you use
chapters in your videos yeah because
that will give people a guideline of
what to look out for use pattern
interrupts as we call them like Music
bass different Graphics different camera
angles or you storytelling techniques
why are people so interested in stories
because stories use techniques like good
and bad yeah or one extreme to The Other
Extreme yeah to actually keep people
engaged in the um in the story maybe
create longer videos for a more targeted
audience where you know they have a
better interest in watching your videos
maybe look at developing a series of
videos
yeah because then you build up loyalty
and you build up kind of a viewer
membership for your video series and
then obviously use the YouTube insights
YouTube analytics to learn about how
effective your um your interrupts in
your video are
final there then there is tip number
eight
tip number eight is an obvious one make
sure that in every video you upload on
YouTube that you promote your channel
and promote the likes the people to like
your video yeah at the beginning and at
the end of your video just like I did on
this video and I'm doing it now if you
like this video click the like button if
you want to subscribe to our video click
the Subscribe button or subscribe to our
Channel yeah very important that you do
that
now a tip that is often overlooked is
the power of the thumbnail
yeah people make a decision as I
mentioned earlier to watch your video
based on the title of your video and the
thumbnail and the more exciting your
thumbnail the more likely people will
click
yeah so now YouTube will create
thumbnails for you but if you don't like
them you can also upload your own
uh your own thumbnails so you can design
those on any tool um any creative tool
make sure that if you upload your own
videos that they accurately represent
your videos
include a shortened version of the title
of your video
yeah make sure that the text is large
enough to read Because particularly on
mobile and remember about 60 percent of
people watch YouTubes on their mobile
yes so make sure that the text is large
enough to read use contrasting colors to
capture the attention make sure that you
pay attention to White space between the
images and create add your brand logo to
your thumbnail as well and the final tip
it goes out it goes without saying tip
number 10 make sure your video keeps
your viewers attention
yeah your videos have to be unique they
have to be different they have to be
engaging
the best videos are controversial
educational funny or shocking
check your analytics your YouTube
analytics to see and to analyze your
viewing behaviors learn from that and
tailor your content to what you learn in
your Analytics
okay so those are the 10 YouTube SEO
tips and now let me show you where to
find all this in YouTube
so if you go to YouTube
yeah I'll show you here this is of a
company
um and this is their YouTube kind of
Channel yeah if I go to the channel of
the company then here you see the
channel it is a shoe store and here you
see their videos now I'm not going to
explain the channels to you but here you
see if you go at the top right okay you
see this little photo here you're gonna
click I'm gonna switch the account I'm
going to my
solution and I'm gonna here have the
dashboard I'm going to look at the
content this one
how we made two and a half thousand
African kids happy with a pair of shoes
so here you see the metadata of this
video
okay so let me show share with you the
elements that we discussed first of all
there is your video title that you can
add here
right how we made two and a half
thousand everything gets happy with a
pair of shoes then here you have your
description
remember keywords actually what I did
here I took the script off the video and
put it here in the description yeah you
have a lot of characters available here
I always start a description with the HD
with the website
because there is another free
opportunity to get a link to your
website
yes so there is your title your
description then if I scroll down
then here you see your thumbnail
I've picked a thumbnail yeah the one
that YouTube created for me I can also
upload my own thumbnail
okay I'm not going to go into the
details I'm just focusing on the
elements that we discussed so here you
see show more and this is where I can go
2D automatic chapters
yeah so those are the chapters that
YouTube will create for you and here you
see the tags
so this is where you can add all the
tags for your video
okay
and then you have the language recording
date
Etc
and then finally here you have the
visibility here you have the section for
subtitles or transcriptions and your end
screen and your cards remember what we
talked about
so let's look at these subtitles
here you see the file
that YouTube created and that we have
updated as it were took out the pilots
YouTube does this automatic you can
download it and then you can edit it
so very useful very powerful tool and
this is by the way if you need to
transcribe any text for any particular
reason yeah just upload to text as a
video on YouTube and YouTube will
transcribe it for you
yep and then when you play the video
there you see here how the text
this is how
she belongs to 40 of the African
population yes so extremely powerful
feature of YouTube the uh the
transcriptions so close that and then
here you see your end screen that you
can pick so you could a video and a
subscribe you can put it at the bottom
you can put it at the top you can put it
in the middle or you can relate to two
videos and here you see the end of the
video where you can place those uh end
screens
okay and the same with the cards
so here you see the type of car to you
want a video cards and then you can say
which video do you want to relate it to
do you want the playlist do you want to
promote another Channel
or do you want to add a link but you
need to be part of the YouTube Partner
program in order to add links to your
cards
right
so that is all there is to uploading
your metadata to your videos a very
important part
to your YouTube SEO
cool let's go on and let's look close
today's session
yeah with sharing my favorite YouTube
SEO tools with you there are five tools
here and I want to actually highlight
two of them number one is canva number
two is socialblade
tubebuddy a refs keyword Explorer and
scyphy
so social blade is a good tool to
examine any popular YouTube video
yeah and then a reps keyword Explorer is
a tool where you can study keywords and
not necessarily only for YouTube but
also for your Google SEO
one of my favorite tools on YouTube is a
tool called tube buddy it is
specifically dedicated for SEO with a
lot of helpful functions yes so it
actually helps you with performance
tracking analyzing keywords yeah and it
is a very simple Google Chrome plugin
let's go to tube
buddy
Chrome extension
yeah here is Chrome tubebuddy
yeah so here you see the tubebuddy
extension and here I click add to Chrome
ADD extension
and you will now see up here that we're
going to add an extension
yeah it has been added to Chrome and now
you see here the um the extension okay
okay so if I now go to a video let's say
simply learn
social media
yep and I pick a video social media
marketing course you can now see that we
installed tubebuddy as a plugin and we
create an account and we logged in and
look at what I see now of the video that
I have on my YouTube screen
yeah I have what we call videolytics
I can see the number of views for the
video the number of comments number of
likes yeah I can see their social
channels I can see their channels uh the
Youtube channels I can see the best
practices does it have a high rest some
mail have info cards been added and
Screen being added has comments been
pinned Etc so some work to do here and
here I get the tags that are being used
for this video I can also show search
rankings yep and I can have additional
tools as well where I can look at
various elements like search ranking
share tracker Etc so a very powerful
tool on YouTube through tubebuddy that
gives you a whole load of
metadata of each video so if you are
doing a social media video and you want
to upload that on YouTube look on
um videos that are similar to the one
that you want to upload and look at
their tags look at their best practices
learn from that and you can use that for
your own video
okay so that is tubebuddy and then the
next tool I want to share with you is a
simple editing Graphics editing tool it
is a tool called canva
canva is what I call photoshop on
steroids it is a very easy site to
create Graphics to create thumbnails to
create Graphics that you can use on your
videos and there's even video Tools in
here as well that you can use yeah you
can create a design you can just say
let's see what you can create
specifically for YouTube you can do a
YouTube Banner a YouTube channel logo
YouTube display ad a profile picture you
can make YouTube Shorts YouTube
thumbnails YouTube video chapters so
lots of stuff that you can create for
YouTube where it has a set of templates
for you that you can use in your in your
design for your YouTube video or your
YouTube channel
so very powerful tool I love can Farm
yes Sophie is a good tool for
um for analytics so you can bring your
YouTube analytics into sci-fi create a
dashboard and it allows you to monitor
success of your videos and your top
ranking keywords so lots of great tools
that you can use for optimizing your
videos and my favorite are tubebuddy
canva and SciFi in today's video we are
going to be talking about YouTube ads
we'll share with you what they are what
type of YouTube ads are available how do
you create them what are the benefits
you can get with them so there's a lot
to cover in this topic of YouTube ads
but before that I am Mark campman I am
your digital navigator for this video
and as usual if you like the video click
the like button and if you want to join
our Channel click the Subscribe button
that you can can find under this video
but before we go into the topic of
YouTube ads let me share with you a new
program that simply learn has put
together together with Purdue University
marketing land search engine journal and
yes meta as well and the good thing
about this course is that you will get
all the skills in digital marketing to
easily complete the meta blueprint
courses as well which are very high
standard courses on everything you want
to know about Facebook and Facebook
advertising so I can highly recommend
this course
and just follow the link and the link
will be in the um in the notes below the
video as well so don't hesitate but join
this video right enough about this let's
go straight into
um YouTube advertising now let me give
you some history to begin with in 2007
YouTube introduced the ability for
creators to monetize their videos with
ads yes so welcome back to that later
there are three players in YouTube
advertising there is the YouTube
creators there are the brands and there
is Google itself of course well the good
thing about YouTube ads that is brands
are able to reach an audience and video
creators in YouTube they are able to
monetize their their videos by enabling
Brands to place ads before or during
these videos initially these ads were
displayed as overlays on top of videos
or as a pre-roll ad before the video
played now in 2010 YouTube introduced
trueview ads they allowed viewers to
skip ads after five seconds and only
charged advertisers if viewers watched
at least 30 seconds of the ad so that
was a benefit for
um for the viewer they could skip the ad
but also a Ben benefit for the brands
because the people that watch the whole
ads were more likely to engage with the
brand now in 2015 there was a new
introduction from YouTube which was the
six second bumper ads very short fleshy
ads that you can run
um during uh during videos in 2016
YouTube faced controversy yeah when ads
um appeared on extremist and
controversial videos yeah so that led to
many videos pulling their ads and
YouTube really had to get their act
together so YouTube implemented stricter
ad policies and introduced new ad
formats such as sponsored cards and
mid-roll ads in 2018 YouTube introduced
the non-skippable ads for viewers on
desktop devices so you could not skip
the ad in 2019 YouTube introduced at
pods so you could do two back-to-back
ads before a video starts and they can
be skipped after five seconds as well
now today YouTube offers a variety of AD
formats for advertisers including
display ads overlay ads sponsored cards
skippable non-skippable video ads bumper
ads and mid-roll ads and we're gonna
cover these later in this video
all right so let's move on let's talk
about what we're going to discuss in
this video we're going to start with
giving you a short introduction to
YouTube ads yeah what is it where how
can you use it but then look at the
benefits of using YouTube ads and then
of course you want to know what are the
different types of YouTube ads that I
can use and I'm going to share with you
the library of ads that Google has and
which ads you would want to use in what
particular circumstance circumstance now
a very big benefit of YouTube ads is the
targeting that you can do with the ads
so we'll cover the YouTube ads targeting
and then I'm just going to go into
Google ads with you and show you how to
create a YouTube ads and you will see
that it's a very simple thing to do and
then finally we'll close the session
with some tips and tricks on YouTube ads
and that should be it for Google and the
YouTube ads so let's dive straight into
this let me give you a short
introduction to YouTube ads to begin
with so let's talk about video
and advertising with videos video
advertising refers to the use of videos
to promote a product a service or a
brand it's very straightforward video
ads can be displayed on various
platforms like desktop on TV on social
media on websites and it can take
different forms yes so it can be a
pre-roll ad it can be a mid-roll ad and
it can be sponsored content that you can
see on the website video ads are very
very powerful because they are more
engaging and more memorable than any
other type of ads people prefer to watch
things and what they see they will
remember they can convey emotion they
can convey storytelling and visual
appeal making them more compelling than
traditional ads you can also reach a
much wider audience and it can be easily
shared across social media so it
increases your reach and it increases
your brand awareness
now one of the issues with advertising
on desktops is that a lot of people have
ad banners of ad blockers installed on
their desktop and that is a and that
Limits The Reach of General advertising
on desktop and also limits to reach of
your advertising on YouTube
because if I have an ad blocker
installed I won't see any ads on YouTube
now there's different ways of getting
um getting about that yes so try to work
with your your audience that they
um that they don't use an ad blocker to
have access to your your content but the
reality is that the best platform for
advertising
um is on whatever video is on mobile
yeah mobile devices they have really
they have fewer ad blockers and you will
reach more people bear in mind that
probably 70 80 percent of people watch
videos on YouTube on their mobile anyway
yeah so mobile devices they're becoming
increasingly popular for video
consumptions video consumption more
people watching videos on their
smartphone therefore a much better area
much better channel for you to advertise
yeah so they can be much more in
effective on mobile to capture users
attention and to generate engagement
because mobiles are more personal and
they're more intimate than other devices
so mobile video ads are more cost
effective you can Target specific
audiences and you can optimize them for
the different mobile devices so
all in all
mobile ads very powerful desktop ads
still a very good medium to use for your
video advertising now let's go to then
to the next level and let's talk about
YouTube ads so YouTube ads are a form of
video advertising displayed on Google's
YouTube platform
yeah so advertisers they can create and
upload videos yeah to be displayed but
then they can turn them into ads that
they can be displayed before during
after YouTube videos or a standalone ads
and they can take different forms as I
mentioned earlier they can be pre-roll
mid-roll display ads sponsored cards
bumper ads and what helps you and the
big advantage of YouTube advertising you
can Target very specific audiences based
on demographics interest behaviors and a
lot more and we'll cover that in a later
section of this presentation so it can
be a very powerful tool for brand
awareness for generating leads and for
driving sales so let's dive a little bit
deeper into this targeting is one of the
most effective
features in YouTube ads yeah so there's
lots of ways that you can Target people
in in YouTube advertising you can do
demographic targeting so targeting based
on age gender parental status household
income you can do interest targeting
targeting based on your users interests
and habits on and off YouTube you could
do behavioral targeting based on a
user's past behavior and interactions
with ads and content you can also do the
remarketing where you can Target people
who have interacted with your website or
with previous ads
you can do custom intent targeting like
targeting users based on keywords and
phrases that they have used when they
searched on Google and YouTube
you can do placement targeting where you
can very sort of specify which channels
videos or types of content you want to
use you can do topic targeting yep so
you can Target videos and channels
related to the specific topics or
categories of your business you can
Target by location
and you can also Target by device so
this again is one of the biggest
benefits that you can get in using
YouTube advertising
another feature is that YouTube ads are
part of Google ads yeah and that is
Google's advertising platform that
allows you to create and display ads on
various Google properties including
YouTube including Google search Google
Maps Google Display Network you can do
shopping ads so it is a fully blown
advertising platform and YouTube ads is
just part of that so it's the same
interface so if you're used to using
Google ads for creating search ads or
display ads and I'll show you later
YouTube ads is just another feature of
that functionality you can even use the
same Google ads account to create and
manage your YouTube ads and you can set
the same targeting options you can use
the same audiences that you created and
you can use the same reporting tools so
very easy very simple to set up and it
makes it very easy for advertisers to
run and to track their campaigns across
multiple platforms
YouTube analytics is another tool that
provides data and insights on the
performance of your YouTube videos and
your YouTube channel and those insights
are very very powerful you can track
metrics like views watch time engagement
audience demographics and it provides
information on traffic sources Revenue
generation if you've activated that and
even audience retention how long will
people watch the video and when do they
drop off and you can learn a lot about
it on fine-tuning your your content so
YouTube analytics YouTube insights can
be used to analyze the effectiveness of
your YouTube ads you can check use it to
monitor your growth of your channel and
to optimize your videos and it can be
accessed through the same analytics
dashboard and the first time YouTube
Studio dashboard and you can customize
and filter the data to get more specific
insights
right so then also you need to
understand
the kind of the ecosystem for YouTube
advertising there are three players as I
mentioned at the beginning of the video
there are three players that are
involved in the YouTube advertising
there is the content creators or the
video creators there are the brands and
there is YouTube or Google
and all three would like to make money
and the beauty is that Google and
YouTube they put together an
infrastructure that allows Brands to
make money and that allows YouTube video
creators to make money
so video creators they have their videos
on YouTube and they have their Channel
and when you
qualify and meet certain
conditions like number of followers or
subscribers to your channel a number of
hours that people have watched your
videos you can qualify
for the advertising sort of partnership
yep and then when you qualified for that
you or Google will add you to the video
Network that Brands can use to place
their ads yes so there is a money making
opportunity for video creators
brands have another objective they want
to reach as big an audience as possible
yeah and that's the beauty of YouTube
there are so many people using YouTube
so many people watching videos on
YouTube it is a fantastic platform to
show their ads on the content before or
during the videos from the YouTube video
creators
yes so the YouTube video creators can't
live without a branch to make money the
brands can't live without the YouTube
video creators to actually reach their
advertising objectives and then Google
YouTube is the third party managing this
ecosystem as it were and Google YouTube
is always sort of doing the The
Balancing Act of keeping both the video
creators and the brands happy
yeah so keep that in mind
advertisers video creators and YouTube
the three key players in um in YouTube
so what are the benefits then of using
YouTube ads well let's look at some
numbers the main benefit of YouTube
advertising lies in the size of YouTube
has over 2 billion monthly active users
and it's the second most visited website
in the world
over 1 billion hours of videos are
watched on YouTube every day which is
equivalent to over 114
000 years of video
now the most viewed video on YouTube by
the way is baby shark Dance by pinkfong
with over 9.5 billion views as of
February 2023 and the highest paid
YouTube earner
yeah so in 2021 was a nine-year-old kid
named Ryan Kaji who earned almost 30
million dollars from his YouTube channel
Ryan's worlds
so not only of course there's part the
advertising partly sponsorships yeah so
there's lots of other ways to monetize
your channel as well so YouTube is a
channel that is out there and it is a
and a fantastic channel to get a huge
reach for your campaign now let's take a
bit dig a bit deeper there are several
benefits for advertisers of YouTube
Because of its sheer sites it gives you
as I said the largest audience reach yes
so with over 2 billion active users each
month it is a tremendous Network where
you can reach everywhere in the world
yeah so you have access to a huge
audience and you can reach a large
number of potential customers that
audience is also very diverse and it
spans all age groups genders and
Geographic locations everybody uses
YouTube yeah so not like Tick Tock where
maybe a younger gen generation YouTube
spends all age groups
so you can tailor your ads to specific
demographics and Target very specific
groups YouTube gives you a variety of AD
formats as we talked about earlier and I
will share that with you so that is a
big menu of sort of options that the
advertiser has
because of YouTube's size and it
Advanced targeting capabilities it is
also a very cost effective way of
advertising with a relative low cost per
impression or cost per click yes so
making it very cost effective and
another big benefit of using YouTube for
your targeted advertising is the high
engagement in user on the on YouTube
yeah YouTube users spend an average of
11 minutes per day on the platform that
indicates quite High engagement and they
have an incline to comment to like to
share the content yes so it's a big
opportunity for Brands to build a
relationship with their key audiences
so here are some more facts about
YouTube's targeting capabilities yes so
in YouTube you can reach 90 of online
audiences in the United States
yeah so YouTube is available in over 100
countries and it supports about 80
different languages now what does that
mean for your targeting yeah so it
allows you to reach users in basically
every geographical location from entire
countries to individual cities or even
zip codes
yeah so they allow you to reach users
based on their language preference so
you for instance you can Target people
who speak a specific language or who
have set their preferred language on the
on their YouTube account
so another interesting statistic that
over 70 percent of in-stream ads on the
YouTube platform are now delivered
programmatically
yeah which basically means there is a
growing Trend towards automated buying
and targeting of your YouTube ads
so all in all the targeting on YouTube
is a big benefit of using YouTube ads
so let's look at some more Benefits
YouTube advertising is very cost
effective but it is important to
carefully plan and execute your
campaigns to maximize your Effectiveness
it can be cost effective based on
various factors like your target
audience your advertising goals and your
budget yeah you're getting different
advertising formats so that can relate
to the cost and the benefits that you're
getting and the YouTube
advertising is typically based on a cost
per view which means you only pay when
someone interacts with your ads and the
average cost per view on YouTube ranges
from let's say ten dollar cents to
thirty dollar cents but again this can
be slightly different based on targeting
ad format and competition
so also use the analytics that you get
here to measure the effectiveness of
your campaign and to measure to to get
the ROI of the campaign that you're
using
now for me one of the big benefits of
using YouTube ads is the increased
engagement YouTube's High engagement and
targeting options makes it a very good
platform for marketeer to reach a large
audience and to build relationships with
their customers
yeah customers spend an average of 40
minutes per session to watch videos so
with over 2 billion monthly active users
yeah you have a huge audience available
that you can build their relationship
with and the good thing is YouTube
videos are very highly shareable so
users they share their videos they share
the ads and they want to share it with
their family and their friends through
social media and messaging messaging
apps
so there's lots of features on YouTube
like comments likes and subscriptions
which helps with this engagement and
helps building the um the the
relationship with your audience
YouTube's recommendation algorithm also
helps to promote videos to users who are
likely to be interested in them and that
increases the reach and that increases
the engagement with your marketing
campaign
so by leveraging YouTube's High
engagement High best targeting
capabilities you can build brand
awareness Drive traffic to your website
increase conversions at a lower cost
compared to traditional advertising
methods
yep and then finally and we talked about
that yeah it is all about the measurable
results that you get and through the
YouTube analytics you get powerful data
powerful insights to optimize your
advertising campaign and improve the
return on your investment on the
platform so you can get very detailed
data in like clicks impress Impressions
conversions so you can really make
decisions on improving your campaign
based on the data that you get out of
the um out of the Google the YouTube
YouTube analytics yeah so you can also
track the performance of your
competitors and Benchmark their
performance against industry standards
and that can help you improve your
campaigns as well
so lots of benefits that you can get out
of YouTube ads and
um that's why it is such a popular
advertising platform because Brands they
really believe that YouTube is probably
one of the best channels for advertising
okay now let's look at the different
types of YouTube ads there's quite a few
of them first of all it is important to
understand the term trueview ads so
trueview is a type of video ad formats
over by YouTube that allows users to
choose whether or not to watch an ad
and with trueview advertisers only pay
when a user chooses to watch the ads
so that can help that you only get
interested users engaging with your
content
trueview ads can be targeted like we
talked about earlier again yeah based on
demographics interest search history
Etc yeah so they can also be optimized
for specific marketing objectives like
Grant awareness consideration or action
yeah so that can help you achieve your
campaign goals so overall trueview ads
they are flexible effective yeah and
allows you to reach a large audience
while ensuring that you only pay for
engaged views
so the first type of ads are trueview
in-stream ads
trueview in stream ads are very popular
and effective for reaching a large
audience on YouTube and for driving
engagement and conversion
so they are a type of Truth you add that
appear before
during or after other videos on the
platform
yes so true few in-stream ads are
skippable video ads so you can skip them
after five seconds so they can be up to
three minutes long and again the user
has the option to skip them after five
seconds and advertisers only pay when a
user watches more than 30 seconds of the
ads or the entire ad if it's shorter
than 30 seconds
or engages with the ad by clicking on a
call to action or companion Banner
okay so those are these true few
skippable in-stream ads
we then have to True view Discovery ads
trueview Discovery ads are a type of
trueview ads yeah that appear in search
results on the YouTube home page and a
long related videos on the platform
yeah whether it's the desktop or whether
it's the mobile they are thumbnail
images with a headline and a description
that appears in the search results and
on the YouTube homepage
so when a user clicks on the add
thumbnail they are taken to the
advertisers video on YouTube
so they can also appear alongside
related videos on the platform and you
only pay when a user clicks on the ad
thumbnail to watch the video
so they are very common you see them a
lot on on YouTube yes so those are the
trueview discovery ads
next the bumper ads I love the bumper
ads they are very creative and a very
effective way for advertisers to make an
impact in just six seconds and reach a
large audience they are a type of video
ad formats that are six seconds long
they're short snackable and memorable
they're non-skippable and play before
the video content that users have
selected to watch so they are really
good for advertisers to reach a large
audience quickly and effectively and
they're often used in conjunction with
other AD formats like trueview in stream
ads
they can be targeted to specific
audiences based on their demographics
their interest search history
Etc and advertisers only pay for
Impressions so they pay for instance for
every 1 000 times the bumper ad is shown
right the next one are the non-skippable
in-stream ads a very effective way for
advertisers to reach a captive audience
on YouTube and again to drive conversion
and drive engagement it's a type of
video ad that appear before during or
after videos on YouTube
yeah so they are non-skippable which
means that viewers are required to watch
the entire ad before they can continue
watching the video they selected they
can be up to 15 second long and they can
include a call to action which is very
important yeah so to encourage viewers
to engage with the advertisers brand or
products
and you pay only when the user watches
the ad to completion or the first sect
for 30 seconds if the ad is longer than
30 seconds
right and then you have the outstream
ads outstream ads are an ad type that
appears on Partner websites and mobile
apps but not on the YouTube platform
itself
yeah so they Those ads they often play
on the page rather than in a video
player which means they don't require
users to watch them to continue viewing
the content they have selected they can
just browse on on the page they're
designed to be mobile first and are only
available on mobile devices makes them a
great option for advertisers looking to
reach an increase in Mobile audience on
YouTube
yes so they can be up to 15 seconds long
and can be optimized for specific
marketing objectives like brand
awareness consideration or action so you
only pay when a user views the ad for at
least two seconds or interacts with it
in some way like tapping the ads to
expand it or clicking through the
advertiser's website
right and then there is the must-head
ads must had ads are a premium ad format
offered by YouTube and they appear at
the top of the YouTube homepage
yeah on desktop and mobile devices
they're typically reserved for large
Brands and designed to provide maximum
visibility on the platform
so they can be up to 30 second long and
can include a call to action doing to
encourage viewers to engage with the
brands so it's great for promoting new
products or Services great for building
brand awareness or driving traffic to
your website
so you can run a must-hat ad for a
single day or for a longer period of
time
depending on the goals of your campaign
and costs can vary depending on factors
like the time of the year targeting
options selected and the duration of the
campaign
and then finally there is the overlay
ads so overlay ads is very effective if
you want to drive traffic to a landing
page and to generate leads yeah for a
product or a service but sometimes they
can be seen as intrusive
so it's important to create ads that are
engaging and relevant yeah so they are
display ads that appear on top of a
YouTube video while that video is
playing Those ads are transparent and
can be text or image based and they
usually appear as you see here at the
lower 20 percent of the video player
to promote a product or a service or a
brand they can include a call to action
targeting specific audience so you can
run the overlay ad for a specific video
or for a group of videos in a particular
category or Channel
so cost for defend for the brand depends
on factors like targetings option
selected duration of the campaign and
the competition for ad inventory so as
you can see a whole library of ads
available yes so
um that YouTube has and that you can use
yep so good let's move on let's look at
the YouTube targeting we'll talk a lot
about the YouTube targeting so let's
summarize this targeting on the next
slide
yes so first of all there is the
demographic targeting so you can Target
people by age by gender by income and by
children
yeah so there's the behavioral targeting
so you can Target viewers based on their
search history the watched videos or the
website app and activities
you can also remarket people so you can
advertise you know you can show ads to
people who have visited your website so
if you have a website and somebody
visited a particular product page and
then left your website then you can
Target him on YouTube with an ad for
that particular product maybe doing a
promotion
you can look at Affinity audiences so
you can Target certain interests and
trades with specialized audiences and
you can look at similar audiences so you
have a particular audience selected and
then you can ask Google can you sort of
select a similar audience with similar
interests or behaviors so very extensive
targeting options and it is one of the
key benefits that you get out of YouTube
advertising
good
now now how then do I create a YouTube
ad to create a YouTube video ads you
have to go into Google ads yes so you
must have an account on Google ads you
just click sign in
and that will take you to your standard
dashboard for your all your activities
in Google ads
and you will find out you'll see that
Google you or just YouTube ads is just a
particular section of the Google ads so
what we're gonna do we're going to look
at the create so we're going to click on
the create button and we're going to
create a campaign
and as you will probably know with
um Google ads there is goal guidance yes
so you Google will advise you on the
type of goals that you can set for your
campaign and based on the goal that you
specify Google will automatically select
the type of channels it has available
for the advertising you can also decide
to do campaign creation without goals
guidance yes so what I'm going to do I'm
going to click brand awareness and reach
and here is immediately you can select
what type of ads what type of campaign
type you want to run do you want to do a
display ad or do you want to do a video
ads and obviously since we're talking
about video ads on YouTube then you
click here on video
so you're going to do a video Reach
campaign
yeah you can do an ad sequence by
showing ads in a particular sequence to
individual shoe viewers yes so that can
be really good to show viewers a series
of ads following the customer buying
cycle for instance or you can look at
people reach people in audience in audio
while they're listening on YouTube with
audio based ads so we're going to go for
a video Reach campaign and then here you
see the type of ads that you want to do
do you want to do the bumper ads or
skippable in stream yeah or a mix
yes so or do you want to do
non-skippable share your entire message
with up to 15 seconds and remember these
are the ads that we talked about in the
ad overview
so we're going for Bumper skippable in
stream or a mix
yep and then we click continue
so here is the campaign name will do
your budget let's say we're going to
spend 100 pounds a day you'll then have
your start date I'll put that a bit
further out
let's say the first of August we're
going to end in two weeks or select a
date
required let's say we're going to end in
two weeks
yeah so there is a 6.67 daily budget so
let's bump that up
I can also say yeah the daily budget
yeah so I'm going to do a daily budget
of 100 pounds
yeah and then here I have the locations
yeah so no and I can be very specific
with my location I can even do a let's
say rg4 I can just Target by
zip code as well
yes so and I can make that as advanced
as possible here so here you can see the
map even so if I want RG yeah so I want
rg7 you see how the map expands yeah RG
I can do rg40
or rg9 yes so here I see how that kind
of develops and how you can be very
specific with the targeting for your ads
and here you see an estimate estimated
number of Impressions that you would get
you can pick a language you can do
content exclusions remember we talked
about it where advertisers were not
happy with the um the videos where their
ads were shown so here you can say
content exclusion
and then here in the ads group you're
going to specify your segmentation
that's where you're going to specify
your targeting now I'm not going to go
into the details here but again these
are all the topics that we've sort of
discussed in the presentation
yep and then here of course what you
need is your video ads so here you're
going to specify the link or you're
going to basically add the link of the
video on that you have uploaded on
YouTube of your ads because of course
your video needs to be on YouTube
yep so that is one yeah so you create
your ads on every video creation
platform
yep and then you upload that video ad on
YouTube and then you have the YouTube
link and that's where you paste the link
of the YouTube ads
if you don't have an ad then you can
just create one in a few steps yeah and
YouTube actually has a video ad Builder
that you can use now where you can just
use templates how cool is this
yes so now of course you need to be
aware that if you use any of these
templates you're not the only one who
will be using those templates so it'll
make your
um campaign slightly more generic yeah
and maybe not as unique as you would
like but the fact that it's in there is
a big benefit yeah if you need to create
an ad from from scratch but there's lots
of other tools that you can use to
create your video ads yeah so let's just
go to YouTube
.com yeah and I will take a video let's
say from one of my clients so do
that this one how we made 2500 gets
happy yeah so I'm just gonna I guess I'm
just gonna take this link in my ad I'm
gonna paste the URL here
yep and then here you see how your ad is
going to be like yes so here is the
skippable you have your display URL and
your final URL when people click on it
remember that it's the same as with
Google advertising so you can use the
display advertise the display URL as
part of your promotion yeah so that
could be a solution
dot Co dot euk forward slash summer
campaign or something
yeah and then you can have your final
URL as well yeah and then you can add a
call to action in your ad yeah that can
be a headline and here you see how all
of that is going to sort of show on the
on the ad
yeah so lots of ways of adding your ad
here and then you set a bit for your ads
and then you basically create the
campaign and you're advertising your
YouTube ads is ready to be executed when
um based on the timings that you've set
and that is honestly that's how simple
it is to advertise on YouTube just go
into Google ads pick an objective that
has video ads as their one of their
channels then go through the campaign
setting go through the ad group settings
select your targeting and then link it
to the ad that you've uploaded on
YouTube as the ad that you want to use
for this campaign or use the YouTube
Tool to create your video ads in YouTube
good so that summarizes how you create a
YouTube ads and now let's close today's
session with giving you a few tips and
tricks on using YouTube ads so first of
all
keep it short and engaging short simple
and engaging because YouTubers have a
short attention span
yeah make sure you bring your message
across in the first few seconds of your
ads
try to summarize your ads right to use
storytelling tell a story that moves
your audience that builds an emotional
connection
yeah so think about storytelling
Concepts like there's a hero and there
is an uh there's an enemy so there is a
victory there is
um yeah there's lots of ways that you
can build storytelling elements into
your uh your YouTube ads don't forget to
add a call to action to your ads because
it encourages viewers to either go for
instance to your website or to buy a
product or to sign up for an event or to
register for something yes so make sure
that you use a call to action in your
your videos and even mention that call
to action in your videos as well use the
right target
um yeah so Target a Right audience so
you add reach the Right audience because
that will give you the best return on
investment on your ads
optimize your ads for mobile that is a
very important tip yes of course because
many people and we're talking probably
about 70 plus view YouTube on their
mobile phones so the ads will be seen on
their mobile phones and very simple yeah
so if you use for instance text on your
ads
yeah on desktop it will be easily
readable but on mobile it may be
unreadable so when you make an ad always
test it on your mobile device as well
and test and check the user experience
that people will get
and then of course continuously test and
optimize your ads to improve their
effectiveness maybe the description of
your YouTube ad or the description or
the title of your YouTube ad or the
thumbnail of your YouTube ads or the
opening of your ad so there may be
different ways test and optimize to make
sure you get the best return on
investment of on your ads if you think
about how bookmarking has traditionally
worked in the world of the web it's
text-based you know if you use the
bookmarks or the favorites that are
built into your browser you tend to end
up with big long lists and folders of
just all sorts of text links that we
really don't go back and end up using
that much later down the line because a
lot of times we don't take the time to
customize those descriptions and becomes
kind of difficult to remember why we
might have even put them in there in the
first place now with Pinterest on the
other hand because everything has a
visual context to it there's a much
higher level of recall it's much easier
to say if you know not just I'm looking
for that corn fritter recipe but here's
the specific corn fritter recipe I'm
looking at because I remember that image
behind it or when you're looking for
inspiration of what you might want to
have as an outdoor project this year or
maybe you're looking for that
infographic that had that data you
needed for your presentation it's much
easier to go back in and find it
visually than it is to go through again
the traditional text-based bookmarks
that most of us are used to working with
it's also a place to go for inspiration
and to gather new ideas not just to save
the ideas that you found other places on
the web but to browse through specific
topics and to spot those little pieces
of information that you say hey this has
value to me I want to save that and
categorize that as well finding
inspiration on those topics that you
enjoy and that you're interested in
to that extent it's made a lot of
changes in the way that we do idea
searching online and in fact we've even
started to see a little bit of changes
in the way Google and Bing start to
present some of their information
because of the influence that we see
Pinterest having on how people search so
if you think about going to Google or
going to Bing and running a search say
for Blackberry coddler the results that
you get back may have a couple ads here
and there they may have some images but
for the most part they're going to be
text-based descriptions that have maybe
the added credibility of a website you
recognize but you don't really know what
you're going to get on the other end
until you click that link go through to
the site and actually look on it now
when you run that same search on
Pinterest you're instantly getting a
visual representation of the content and
if you're looking for a specific type of
blackberry cobbler becomes a lot easier
to take a look and say oh wow that one
sounds wonderful but you're also reading
curated descriptions that are added by
human beings rather than the metadata or
the relevant content off the page that's
pulled by a search engine algorithm and
plugged into that space now Pinterest
also makes it very easy for you to
refine your search as you can see across
the top maybe you want an easy
blackberry cobbler recipe or maybe you
want a blackberry cobbler recipe with
oats they can take the user data and the
way you information is saved and
collected within Pinterest and help you
refine those searches further so it also
has a heavy impact again on the way that
people are now doing Discovery for
different ideas and Concepts
so it's important to be able to look at
Pinterest
in sort of the broader context of what
we're used to with social media so if
for example Pinterest is one of the
newer channels to you but maybe you're
familiar with Facebook because Facebook
is sort of the Behemoth of all things
social media having a little bit of
side-by-side comparison can be a helpful
way to put Pinterest under perspective
so when we look at monthly usage data
for the two sites
the average person spends about seven
hours a month on Facebook and about 90
minutes a month on Pinterest now at
surface that would seem like people are
way more invested in Facebook than they
are in Pinterest and to an extent that's
true again it has a higher usage rate it
has more frequent visit rate but it's
also important to understand the context
of how we use these two sites because
Facebook is a place that is a
destination rather than a starting point
we go to Facebook to participate in
conversations to see what people are
interested in and talking about and to a
great extent to have that conversation
and engagement on Facebook itself
Pinterest on the other hand is sort of a
strange hybrid of say a search engine
and a social media site because it's a
starting point it's the place that we go
to either build our collection to look
at other people's collections or for
inspiration so we're spending as much
time off-site as we are on site again
the same way that you might go to Google
20 times a day but not spend more than
10 or 15 minutes total during the day on
the site because you're using the site
to get yourself to another location
so where Facebook becomes that place
where you're engaging with your fans
Pinterest is the place where you're
attracting your fans researching them
and what their likes and what their
interests are so again Facebook is the
place where we're going and we're trying
to get people to stay and engage and
interact with us and sort of spread
things around but with Pinterest there's
sort of an understanding that you're
getting a touch point in front of them
and you're getting an interest point in
front of them but ideally they're
finding their way into your site into
your content again it's a launch Point
rather than the actual engagement
location there's still a lot of
misconceptions about the site who uses
it how they use it whether or not it's a
good fit for a particular business or
brand so I want to clear up some of the
misconceptions that a lot of marketers
and a lot of business owners still have
a lot of people still look at Pinterest
as sort of the way it originally
launched which was mostly about women
either planning their wedding or ones
who wish they were still planning their
wedding because suddenly they had all
these great ideas there's a little bit
of designers and Foodies mixed in and
maybe some men you know hiding in the
very very corners and edges of the
Pinterest universe but for the most part
Pinterest was originally all fashion
makeup Beauty food and Home Design now
we've seen a lot of changes in the
demographics over the last couple years
in fact there really is sort of a new
reality and we're seeing a continued
creep towards this new reality
So currently nearly a third of Pinterest
users are actually men 71 percent are
Women 29 are men
that accounts for about 13 of the male
internet population now having a
Pinterest account whereas 42 percent of
female internet users have an account
now when we look a little bit beyond
sort of just the male female demographic
the financial numbers they're pretty
good 64 nearly two-thirds of them make
more than 50 000 a year and a pretty
good percentage of them also make more
than a hundred thousand dollars a year
now one of the areas that Pinterest does
differ from some of the other channels
like Twitter is that it's a very
non-urban environment so if we look at a
channel like Twitter we see a very high
Urban population much higher adoption
rates there but with Pinterest we see a
lot more suburban and even way more
rural than we see on some of the other
channels again it's just a different
demographic that's checking in here so
it becomes a unique place to go and
reach some of the people that you might
have a more difficult type reaching on
some of the other platforms and channels
2014 was really a banner year for men on
Pinterest and we really by the end of
that year saw a lot of very significant
changes they accounted for 33 of all the
new signups coming in and if you go
outside of the United States that's
roughly 50 of this sign ups that are
happening so we saw a 73 percent
year-over-year growth in men registering
for the site I think women will probably
always be the dominant demographic
that's on the site but I think we're
going to continue to see the number of
men increase a little bit more until we
sort of reach a leveling off now an
important thing to note again when you
think about how you're getting in front
of your audience and whether or not it's
a worthwhile place to check out it's
very important to realize more men Now
read Pinterest each month than Sports
Illustrated and GQ combined so again
we're getting really good depth of
insight now when we look at Emerging
Markets Korea India China the numbers
are even better men make up half of all
users not half of sign ups you know not
half of growth it's literally a 50 50
split when we look at some of those
Emerging Markets so if you're doing a
lot of international marketing or if
you're primarily focused in
international marketing it becomes even
more important to look at Pinterest and
how you might work it into your Outreach
efforts now some of the top categories
for men because most people are very
familiar with which ones perform best
for women you know food home design you
know gardening fashion all of those
perform really well for women when we
look at the categories for men geek
tends to be the number one category so
anything you know technology geeky
oriented does really well cars and
motorcycles men's fashion does extremely
well gardening performs very well for
men architecture humor and health and
fitness tend to really be the places
where there's the most activity going on
but in this day and age you can also go
into foodie you can go into Outdoors
travel you can go into a variety of
different boards and you're still going
to see a lot of active pinning and
engagement and interaction by men now
with all of this discovery and with
growing demographics coming into the
site it also means that Pinterest has
some pretty impressive traffic potential
looking at some of the stats that have
come out pakora has done a great job of
sort of tracking to see how do people
engage with Pinterest you know what's
going on with the site we find that the
average pin drives two visits and six
page views it's also worth an average of
about 78 cents in sales now when we look
at this in terms of sort of virality we
see that the average pin also receives
11 repins now if you're a big Twitter
user you're familiar with the idea of
retweets so to give you a little
perspective on that
that makes the average pen roughly 100
times more viral than the average tweet
which receives what about 0.1 percent
repens or 0.01 percent repins so again
when we look at the potential for things
to spread and move around at a faster
Pace Pinterest has a lot of potential
but one of the other interesting things
about Pinterest is the latent nature of
traffic and purchases that come in from
it it's not uncommon for a PIN to go up
have a really big traffic Spike then it
sort of dies off and then someone else
discovers it you know because they're
running a search or they're looking
somewhere they pin it it gets back into
the feed nice and fresh traffic spikes
again or people pin content without
having visited the site to read it and
then they go back and review it later so
roughly half of all visits that come in
from Pinterest occur three months after
the original pin was released or the
original pin was made and about half of
all orders occur two months after which
again if people are researching
Christmas lists maybe putting together
other potential purchase lists for
things they're going to buy for their
house or for themselves it makes sense
that they would do their research do
their Gathering and then go back at a
later point to kind of dig in a little
bit more and make that final purchase
decision now Pinterest also has some
true e-commerce potential it's not just
about driving traffic we've also found
that Pinterest is very effective at
getting those actual conversions
so looking at some of the Pinterest
shopping stats 47 of online Shoppers
have made a purchase based on a
Pinterest recommendation and when we
look at e-commerce social sharing no not
social sharing in general but sharing of
products things you intend to buy
Pinterest holds 41 of e-commerce social
sharing now Facebook sits at 37 to give
you a little bit of perspective so again
far more e-commerce social sharing
taking place on the Pinterest platform
and then when we look at purchases
coming in you know I mentioned 78 cents
per pin is sort of the average but when
people actually do come in and convert
and buy we see an average purchase
amount of 179 dollars coming off of a
Pinterest referral if we compare that to
Facebook we get eighty dollars at
Facebook and 69 at Twitter so if we want
to do the math to put this in a little
more perspective that means that
Pinterest generates on average 27
percent more Revenue per click than
Facebook does and that it generates
roughly 400 percent more Revenue per
click than Twitter now this makes a lot
of sense if you think about it because
when people are on Twitter they're
usually checking to see what's the news
what's sort of the trending topics what
are people talking about they're not
necessarily in a shopping mindset when
they're on Facebook they're catching up
with friends and with the new sources
that they follow and kind of seeing you
know just what's the word what's
happening online but when people are on
Pinterest they're in that sort of
you know small child going to McDonald's
to get the latest Happy Meal toy you
know collect them all mode they're in
that mindset already of gathering and
acquiring and collecting and a lot of
times they're using it specifically as
part of their purchasing decisions so
they're already in a mental state or
mental mindset when they come into your
website to be prepared for purchase
they're also going to be more apt to use
something like Pinterest to research
higher ticket items so whether that's
you know your wedding dress instead of
maybe the you know the little favors
that you're going to buy from Michael's
or maybe it's you know the leather couch
that you're going to put in your living
room instead of the pillow that you're
going to pick up at Target it's a higher
end product that they're saving and
collecting so again you're going to have
a higher dollar amount when they
actually do come through and make that
purchase now I also want to touch on the
idea of Pinterest and how it has changed
the value of images because everyone
knows image marketing over the last
several years it's become really hot
there's a lot of focus on it and
Pinterest has really played a big role
in the development of that now if we
think back several years ago to the
earlier days of social media to YouTube
and how YouTube changed video marketing
what happened with YouTube is that we
had this explosion of consumer generated
content and that content was very well
received in fact when we looked at data
in way back in 2012 we could see that
user generated content and
professionally produced content that was
paired with user generated content
performed far better across the board
than professionally produced only
content in other words when it looked
like it came from a quote real person
rather than an advertising agency people
tend to relate to it better share it
more and have a more positive response
the trust factor is higher and that
became a really great thing for
businesses of All Size because you
didn't necessarily have to pour as much
you know money and planning and skill
set into every video you produced
there's still a place for professionally
produced video but it also meant it was
a little more acceptable to not be at
that rate so for small businesses in
particular this was like a godsend in
the marketing world now unfortunately
we've sort of seen the exact opposite
thing happen with Pinterest because with
Pinterest we see the quality of images
going up exponentially and thus we see a
need for that quality of images and
again when you think about the visual
context why we go to Pinterest what
we're looking for this makes sense very
quickly if you're going to Pinterest
because you're looking for a little
dinner inspiration what are you going to
make for dinner and you run across a
picture like this
you're not really going to be in a hurry
to run home and make that because what
is it and why would I want to eat it but
when you pair the same recipe with a
good quality image that lets you see oh
well you know that's an egg tart or it's
a frittata okay well that actually that
looks a little better that looks tastier
and this is what we're seeing happen
with Pinterest is we're seeing all of
these bloggers and all of these websites
that are producing amazing content an
amazing video you take a site like
Smitten Kitchen
she's operating out of a 42 square foot
Kitchen in New York City she doesn't
have staff there's no Production Studio
there she's not a trained chef but she
puts up the recipes that she makes and
she pairs it with gorgeous photos that
she takes herself and she's pulling in
millions of page views every single week
and probably a nice Chunk in advertising
Revenue as well but the same way that we
saw sort of amateurs dramatically change
the nature of video marketing by using
more amateurish content again we've seen
the exact opposite happen with images
because in an environment that you need
things to be so visually stimulating to
stand out on that Pinterest page the
best quality content is what's going to
rain Supreme and as you have people who
are willing to put the time and effort
in and who are creating better content
that's upping the bar for everyone else
so what it has meant for a lot of Brands
big and small is that relying so heavily
on stock photography like they used to
in the past it doesn't work so well
anymore not when you're competing with
really unique original relevant images
that people are taking of what they're
producing you know they're putting up
not just a blog post but a blog post
that has 20 amazing images to go with it
and so we've seen this sort of across
the board level of expectation that no
matter what size company you are you
need to learn how to properly operate a
camera how to put some good Lighting in
there and to really great get some great
imagery again Enterprise or small
business it's irrelevant at this point
the quality of your pictures must go up
on your website if you want to reap the
benefits and the rewards that come from
the increased traffic from a service
like Pinterest so before we get into the
next couple sets of videos for this
series I really want to sort of go back
and kind of summarize this idea of why
Pinterest is worth looking at if you're
not already Marketing in it or why you
might want to put some consideration
into some of the different ways you
might be able to leverage it really at
its core Pinterest is probably the
strongest site online in the social
media World playing off the impact of
imagery photos weigh incredibly heavily
they are the currency of Pinterest but
that allows for really fast concept
digestion so unlike on a Twitter or
unlike on Facebook where there's a lot
of reading as you're scrolling through
to figure out is this something I'm
interested in we can react to and
process images very quickly so so having
the opportunity to get your content into
that environment gives you a much better
chance to really capture someone's eyes
and get them to stop and take the time
to read the description and potentially
click through to the site there's also a
really low barrier to entry it Rivals
Twitter in terms of how quickly you can
get in there and set things up for a
base level Pinterest account you know
even getting your website verified
you're looking at five to ten minutes to
set up now if you're going to go a
little heavier Duty with things like
Rich pins which we'll talk about a
little later in this series there's
going to be a little bit more effort
there but it basically has a really
simple interface with minimal management
there's not a lot to it that is going to
take up a ton of time and effort
management wise
there's also the ability to look at this
as a chance for curation versus creation
we're going to talk a little more in
depth about that idea later in the
series as well but it basically gives
you the opportunity to have a channel
that you can play in without necessarily
having to create all original content
there are some very successful and
strategic ways to leverage Pinterest
with other people's content rather than
your own
and then finally the ability to have
content segmentation which is another
idea that we'll dig a little deeper into
gives you the chance to really Target
your consumers in a way that you can't
do on any other social media channel
because the idea that people can choose
which areas of your content they want to
follow that allows you to curate much
deeper into a topic than you would
normally be able to now there's tons of
potential here for big Brands we see big
companies Enterprise level businesses
really leveraging it very creatively one
of the examples that I've used almost
from the start with Pinterest is Chobani
because they have non-stop done an
amazing job of marketing and one of the
things that you know they've said is it
has really allowed them to show
different sides of their personality
again that idea of the content
segmentation and being able to dig a
Little Deeper it really lets people see
more about what the brand of Chobani is
and all the different ways that people
are using their products so whether
Chobani is leveraging it to find recipes
that they might want to send to their
Test Kitchen to see about you know
leveraging on their own blogs research
to see how customers are using their
product and from their end while they're
Gathering a lot of insight and data
again there's minimal engagement and
management going on they're not usually
in there commenting they don't have to
read through a lot of comments and
respond to them they're mostly just
curating and liking and re-pinning
content now for small Brands we see the
same things there's been a lot of
companies that have done a really great
job of leveraging Pinterest to get
exposure and artifact Uprising is a
great example of this one of those
companies that was a small teeny tiny
startup literally working out of
someone's basement and they had a single
product pin that generated almost 50 000
visitors into their site and in 18
months they went from basement startup
to multi-million dollar sales just
because they got the right pin in front
of the right person and got some really
great exposure so they've been using it
to do a lot of a b testing of products
that they're looking to launch before
they actually get them launched just to
see what the response is and what people
seem to be interested in and that's
really given them as a small company the
ability to gather a lot of really unique
can creative data that otherwise might
have cost them a lot of money to hire a
market research firm to put together so
there's lots of different ways the
companies of all sizes are really
working to leverage Pinterest so coming
up in the next part of our series we're
going to talk a little bit about setting
up a Pinterest account you know personal
accounts versus business accounts we'll
look at the various types of pin boards
understanding what they are and how to
use them and we're going to talk a
little more in depth about this idea of
content segmentation and the value
associated with that so if you've
watched part one of this series and you
don't already have a Pinterest account
and you're finding yourself saying okay
let's give this a try let's get set up
the question becomes how do you go in
and actually do it well the first
question you have to ask yourself is
whether or not it's in your best
interest to set up a business account or
a personal account and a lot of that's
going to depend on the size of your
company and what your goals are if
you're an interior designer or a
marketing consultant or someone that
really sort of is your own business
setting up is personal may make sense if
you or a company of any size or
Enterprise clearly you're going to want
to set up as a business if you're
setting up is personal when you go to
pinterest.com they're going to let you
sync it to your Facebook or set up an
email address and a password but if
you're a business or if you're an
individual who wants to set up as a
business you need to go to
business.pinterest.com and keep in mind
even if you are sort of a solopreneur or
you know a blogger someone like that you
probably want to give serious
consideration to setting up an account
is a business and not just as an
individual that's because as a business
you're going to have access to more
marketing tools to more options than you
would just going in through your
personal account now if on the other
hand you have already set up account but
you haven't really figured out how to
leverage it maybe you set up a personal
account way back when and you've never
done much with it it's important to note
that on the business account page you do
have an option to convert an existing
account from a personal account into a
business account
so you're going to want to make sure you
go with that option rather than just
setting up a duplicate so when you're
creating your business account it's
going to be fairly standard same thing
you do anyplace else you're going to put
in an email address and a password and
the name of the business and then
they're going to take you into sort of
your starting point and that's where
you're going to have the option to go in
and do a couple different things you
might want to create your first board
and start building some of those out you
might want to install the pin it button
or the follow me button on your blog now
we're going to talk about each of those
a little bit further down the line the
one I want to focus on first because the
one that I think it is most essential
for everyone to do when they're setting
up a business account is to take a
couple moments to verify your website
with Pinterest so that's going to be the
last option on the right there and when
you choose verify your website they're
going to give you a piece of code that
you basically take back to your website
and you're going to plug into the header
code so if you're someone that has
access to the site you can go do this in
a matter of a minute or two if not this
is just going to be a snippet of code
that you're going to need to send over
to your developer your website person
and say this needs to go into the header
section once you've done that you're
going to be able to go back over to the
site and you'll notice underneath your
profile you'll see a little red check
that shows up next to your url now what
that basically does is it tells
Pinterest that this is a website that
you do actually own you're not just
trying to associate yourself with it and
that's going to give you access down the
road to things like Pinterest analytics
and some promoted pins and some
additional marketing opportunities that
you won't have if you don't take the
time to make sure you put that
verification in order so you want to
make sure that you do that as part of
your business setup on Pinterest now
there's a couple things to note about
getting started with your account even
Beyond you know simple verification or
setting up your first boards one of
those is the knowledge that unlike a lot
of other social media channels you're
not currently going to have the ability
to sync all of your other social media
channels up and that's because on
Pinterest the only way to link over to
Facebook and sync up with Facebook is to
sync with your personal account so again
if you're going in as a business you're
probably not going to want to link
Pinterest to your Facebook because
there's not currently an option in place
to just enter the URL for your business
account on Facebook to let people jump
straight into that now you can sync up
your Twitter properly because you just
need to enter your Twitter username and
password but again because Facebook
tends to be associated with a personal
account that then has access to go into
business accounts it does not do the
sync very well at all
you're also going to want to plan to
clean out your news feed Pinterest will
not let you set up an account without
picking a certain number of topics that
you're interested in and then they sort
of Auto follow people on your behalf so
chances are when you first log in
there's going to be a lot of content in
your news feed that you might not
actually be interested in so you're
unfortunately either going to have to
learn to ignore it or take the time to
click into those boards and unfollow
those Pinterest users and those boards
so you can just clean it up a little bit
and then you want to take the time to
create just a handful of boards to start
you don't need to go in and create every
board for every topic you think you're
going to use it's far better in my
opinion to start with three to five
boards and flush them out with good
quality content first and then start to
see where your interests lie what seems
to be getting a response and start to
add inboards from there you've got
plenty of time to go broader and deeper
now there's four different types of
boards you need to know about some of
them can sort of be used in conjunction
with each other some of them there's a
little bit of nuances too so the primary
type of board is what's called a
category board so when you set up a
board on Pinterest and super simple to
do you're just clicking an add a board
button you're going to be asked to enter
a name for the board and a description
for the board and then there's going to
be a drop down option to choose a
category and that's again a category
board so whether it's related to health
and fitness or food or party planning
you're basically saying to Pinterest the
content that I put on this board has to
do with this specific topic so it's a
generalized board that's going to be
synced up with pinterest's existing
categories that means it's viewable to
all users people can choose to follow it
or not follow it and the content that
you put into that board has the
opportunity to be selected by Pinterest
is part of their broader category feeds
now there's another type of board that's
called a secret board and a secret board
functions in much the same way that a
category board does except for the fact
that it's not visible to anyone except
the board owner and approved Pinterest
users and by approved Pinterest users I
mean you have added those users to the
board and given them the right to also
post their content into it so it's
basically just a way to leverage
Pinterest and all the benefits of a
Pinterest board in an environment that
you have a little bit more control over
and we'll talk a little more in depth
later in the series about different ways
to leverage secret boards both for
marketing and content research and even
for things like PR and Pitch Outreach
now the next type of board is a places
board now you can have a category board
that's a places board you can also have
a secret board that's a places board so
again there's a little bit of
opportunity for overlap there and what a
places board does is it syncs up the
board itself with a map and it allows
you to put a geographical location in
for each of the pins that you put up now
that may be because you're literally
pinning locations in places or it may be
that you're making the choice to tie a
location to an image or to a concept or
to an idea that you've put in place but
when people click in to look at these
boards they're always going to see that
map associated with it they're going to
see the pins that are in the board
showing up on the map itself so they can
take a look and see sort of how things
are laid out geographically
and then the final type of board I want
to talk about today is a group board so
I mentioned this briefly on the secret
board page but it's basically a
collaborative board it allows you to
invite other Pinterest users by name to
come in and participate now you can have
a category board that is a group board
you can have a secret board that's a
group board you can have a secret places
board that's a group board again there's
a lot of opportunity for overlap here
and really all this does is allow you to
work in a collaborative manner with
people so that you're not the only
person that's putting pins in now
there's some challenges here because you
want to make sure you don't just add
anyone because again once you add them
you're giving them the ability to pin as
well so from the business perspective
you want to be a little bit careful on
this and who you put in and who you give
some editing access to because it's not
uncommon to see these types of boards
potentially get spammed by a new user so
again you want to make sure that these
are people that you're actually familiar
you're with that you have a measure of
trust in before you add them into a
group board so now that we have a basic
idea of what the different types of pin
boards are
good to get a walk through of what it
actually looks like to go through that
process of setting those up so when you
go into your Pinterest page sort of your
Pinterest profile you're always going to
see a create a board option that shows
up towards the top and on the left so
clicking that create board option is
going to launch a window that allows you
to do things like enter the name of the
board that you're putting together write
up a description of what it is choose a
category these are all things that we've
talked about doing you know saying there
here's the category in the topic that I
want to be associated with but then you
also have the opportunity to turn it
into a places board by adding a map or
leaving the map option turned off which
will make it just a regular standard
board now you can at any point in the
future turn something into a places
board without a problem
now you also have the option to make it
a secret board or not so for this
instance I have turned it into a secret
board because it's planning for a future
event it's important to note you can
take a board that has been made secret
and make it public but you cannot take a
public board and make it secret once
it's public it has to stay public so if
you think this is something that you may
want to be a secret board but maybe open
up later it's a good idea by default to
start with it a secret otherwise you'll
have to go back and build a new board
from scratch and re-pin everything into
that board
and then once you've decided if you're
going to make it a places board if
you're going to make it a secret board
you also have the option to type in
names and when you start typing those
names in they're going to pull up a list
of the fellow penners people with
accounts that match that name and you
have the ability to add
virtually as many people as you want
into the mix but you can say these are
the people that I want to have access
and click that create board button and
then you're going to see that option
show up now it's important to note the
people that you invite into the mix they
won't immediately show up it's not until
they have accepted your invitation that
they'll actually show up so just in case
you set a board up and you're trying to
figure out why everyone else isn't
showing up there now from that point you
can click add a pin and you can start
uploading pins or you can go out and use
Pinterest as you normally would you know
either clicking the repin button or
using the pin it button on a website and
this new board is going to show up as
one of your drop down options for
actually pinning content and getting it
online
now when we look at things like category
selection it's important to remember
that category selection is an important
part of what actually gets your content
out there into the mix so when you take
that original pin that you first put up
if it isn't associated with a category
if you pin it into a board that's not
associated with a category it's only
going to go out to your existing
followers so in this instance it was a
post by Kendall Jackson wines so they
have a little less than 2 000 followers
so it's going to broadcast out to some
of those 2000 followers based on the
algorithm and you're basically going to
get limited repens you know limited
opportunity for exposure
now when we look at
putting things into the category
now we have the opportunity that again
Pinterest may take that pin and
broadcast it out into the category area
which means you're not just getting the
exposure to the people who have opted to
follow your board but to the millions of
category viewers which means lots of
increased exposure cyclical repins and
the chance for your content to go much
further than it would have originally
now something else that's important to
understand when we look at things like
categories and you know we mentioned the
idea of getting our content out into
categories or even into home pages with
people who have chosen to follow your
content is that Pinterest has put
together an algorithm in much the same
way that Facebook has the news feed
algorithm or that Google has you know
their search engine algorithm so
Pinterest has what's known as the smart
feed and there's sort of three key
Concepts that go into the idea of the
smart feed and how Pinterest decides
what content is going to show up
originally when Pinterest was put
together it worked much like Twitter
does that content just showed up in the
order that it was pinned and if you had
good timing for logging in or for
getting your pins up there you were
going to show up in front of people but
now Pinterest is looking at mixing
different sources of pins together at
different rates so instead of having one
brand be able to come in and maybe take
over your news feed because they've
pinned you know 57
different versions of putting together
an outdoor patio now Pinterest is saying
well let's maybe pick the best of that
content and let's pair it with some of
the other content that maybe showed up a
couple hours ago but you know still new
since the last time they logged in
so the idea is that some pins should be
shown now while some are shown later so
there's a mix here that's a little
different from what we might see on
Facebook or on a search engine that
Pinterest isn't necessarily saying we're
going to take the Top Value and put
those in front of you now and toss the
rest out they're actively saying look we
know that a lot of activity around pins
is latent it doesn't always happen
immediately so if we take that pin that
someone you follow put up and we don't
show it to you for a week or two you're
probably still going to be interested in
it so there's a little bit of nuances
there in terms of understanding that
just because it doesn't show up
originally doesn't necessarily mean it
won't show up at all
but there's also the idea here that pins
have different value based on the source
and the topic so Pinterest is going to
be looking at the type of content that
you're pinning and putting together
they're going to look at the quality of
the pins and how other people have
responded to them they're going to use
that information to figure out which one
is going to be approved and actually
show up for you versus which ones might
not be the best fit and there's just no
reason to have it show up in your news
feed so it's going to take a lot of time
for this to really get sort of reverse
engineered and better understood have a
look at this amazing certification in
digital marketing which is postgraduate
program in digital marketing so don't
miss out on this incredible opportunity
take action today and enroll in our
course to unlock the secrets of digital
marketing success click the link in the
description box and embark on your
professional growth and achievement
Journey before we get into the tips and
tricks let's take a refresher and see
what exactly is social media marketing
social media marketing is one of the
most commonly used and lucrative forms
of digital marketing it's a methodology
that has Brands creating and sharing
content on social media
now if you've ever been on any form of
social media be it LinkedIn Facebook or
Instagram you've promptly been exposed
to some form of social media marketing
remember that Burger King video
advertising their new whopper or about a
marketing tool that can help you
visualize your team's workload better
than any other in the market right now
one of these are just some of the many
ways that you've been marketed to and
the objective when it comes to social
media marketing is to achieve the
Brand's marketing and branding goals now
this could be increased engagement more
clicks conversions and so on so how do
they do it with text and image updates
videos or any other form of content they
can attract the user's attention and can
drive engagement from them now alongside
publishing quality content it also
involves analyzing your data and running
social media advertisements
now some of the more popular social
media platforms right now are Facebook
Instagram Twitter LinkedIn and so on
next let's talk about some of the
advantages of social media marketing
first off social media marketing
provides great brand awareness now with
the help of interactions with people on
social media brands are able to build up
their reputation as businesses and with
each interaction each post each share
the brand is exposed to a larger network
of potential customers who might be
interested in the products or services
offered
next it gives you more traffic to your
website marketing your products or
services on social media will also
attract customers to your website
outside of your usual customer base
next it improves your Brand's search
engine rankings now although this isn't
the direct correlation social media
marketing does have a part to play and
it comes in helping your page rank
higher up in the search engine rankings
now if you start posting high quality
content people will start liking and
sharing it and this will in turn bring
it to the attention of influencers
within the industry who would be willing
to write about your business and then
this gives you backlinks which as you
know will help you improve your search
engine rankings
next it will give you improved
conversion rates and with your brand
being much more visible and interactive
on social media every text image video
or comment could potentially Drive users
to your website
social media also humanizes your brand
now this leads to more customers
trusting a brand and being more
interested in your products and services
and then we have improved customer
satisfaction when your customers
interact with your brand on social media
it provides you with an opportunity to
show compassion for your customers
personal messages to customers
addressing their concerns will be viewed
in a positive light and can go a long
way when it comes to humanizing your
brand
social media marketing is also cost
effective
compared to other forms of digital
marketing social media marketing offers
some of the most flexible and relatively
low-cost options available
now this opens up your budget for more
marketing and business expenditures and
if you do get into paid advertising a
good strategy will net you a great
return on your investment
and finally it will help you become
thought leaders with your high quality
posts communicating with your audience
sharing content and promoting your
Authority you can have your followers
look up to you and this will allow you
to become a figure of expertise in your
industry
now let's go into the social media
marketing tips and tricks
number one set up your goals
now what good will your actions do if
you don't have a goal in mind the goal
of your marketing strategy may be the
driving force behind every decision that
you make and this is exactly why setting
up goals is very important moreover your
marketing efforts have to align with the
goals of the organization
here are some things that you need to
keep in mind while setting up your goals
first of all your goals need to be
quantitative for example you need to
have a thousand conversions by the end
of the quarter or 5 000 followers on
Instagram by the end of the month and so
on
number two you need to stick to a
consistent deadline this gives weight
for each of your options and number
three make sure your goals are smart now
smart refers to specific measurable
attainable relevant and time-based
now let's go to number four like I
mentioned earlier your goals need to be
aligned with the marketing strategy
and alongside these goals there also
needs to be the North Star metric now
what is the North Star metric well this
represents a main goal or a fixed
reference point to ensure that your team
is on the right course this North Star
metric will also give your team Clarity
and focus
now let's have a look at some popular
North Stars there's increased engagement
greater conversion rates more leads
generated app downloads and so on
now let's go to number two understanding
your audience
social media allows you to interact
engage and build relationships with your
Audience by understanding what they need
want and desire you can deliver content
in a way that makes your product or
service the answer that they're looking
for
there are also other ways that you can
understand them better
this could be surveys to determine the
issues that bother them the age
demographics of Their audience
by conversing with them in forums
responding to their comments and blogs
and social media taking up their
feedbacks of suggestions into
consideration and acting on them and so
on
now here's an example of different
channels and the audiences that use them
now here well we've taken a personal
example here is simply learn now simply
learns audience is predominantly working
professionals and graduates
unacademy has high school graduates and
baiju app has high school students as
users
now let's go to number three determining
the right social media platform
foreign
social media marketing choosing the
right platform is really important
When selecting them you need to ask
questions like why you're using that
particular platform who you will reach
with this platform what content could
work best on the platform and is there
any content that was unique to that
platform like for example YouTube and
then there's the video
answering these questions will help you
zero in on a platform for you
and while there are several platforms
available for you to choose from let me
tell you about some of the major ones
there's LinkedIn Facebook Instagram and
Pinterest
now let's talk about the purpose of each
of these platforms
LinkedIn is a professional Network
that's best suited for B2B audiences
for Facebook well just about everyone
has an account on it
content that is related to news or
entertainment usually finds success on
Facebook and then we have Instagram well
visual content works best on Instagram
now although it works well for static
images and short form video It Doesn't
Really drive a lot of traffic to your
website
and then finally we have Pinterest
Pinterest is also limited to static
images however it's highly effective at
driving traffic to your blog
now let's go to number four setting up a
social media calendar
a social media calendar demands the
message you want to convey to your
audience it also consists of information
regarding the different kinds of content
that will go up on the social media
platform
let's have a look at some of the most
popular types of posts on social media
first off we have competitions now I'm
sure all of you have seen posts like tag
a friend who does this or comment or
like to win something and stuff like
that competitions like these provide
great opportunities for engagement with
the audience and they can be used to
increase your followers to share your
content it could also be for them to
create their own content along with the
predefined hashtag and competitions help
grow your presence on social media
then we have polls and surveys
polls can help you if you need a
collection that also encourages
followers to take action and interact
polls and surveys also provide
opportunities through which you can
learn from customers to understand what
they like about the product or service
or what they don't and to receive their
feedback and then we have videos and
live streams although we'll be covering
this in a little more detail further on
visual storytelling along with videos
and live streams goes a long way to
drive engagement among your audience
these will help get your followers
attention increase trust and credibility
and have a high response rate and has so
much more to offer live stream with its
live nature and having a human face
alongside your business humanizes your
brand and by extension helps increase
customer loyalty and trust and then
there is infographics articles and
images
so social media calendars are successful
because of their ability to increase
collaboration within the team help
understand what works and what doesn't
and in distributing resources in an
effective manner
next up we have number five using social
media marketing tools
social media marketing tools align to
the goals of your organization with it
you can create high quality content
attract new potential customers and
drive engagement and it also helps you
with the planning process you can plan
create and schedule posts on your social
calendar
now some of the more popular social
media tools include buffer HootSuite
buzzsumo if Triple T and much more
now these tools also help with
generating leads creating email lists
finding a relevant audience to show your
content
creating buyer personas providing you
insights on what works and what doesn't
and giving you templates for different
kinds of posts
now for number six visual storytelling
visual storytelling involves passing out
a lot of information in the simplest of
forms visually using pictures and videos
your followers are able to grasp the
message quickly and remember it for a
long time afterwards visual storytelling
is also not limited by language barriers
and this helps it become interesting and
entertaining to anyone watching it can
also help your audience stay interested
and engaged grab the attention of
potential clients and so much more
but it also has some other advantages it
helps you build a bond with your
audience the visual storytelling
connects with your audience methods like
live streaming help humanize your brand
and help grow customer loyalty and trust
it has the audience quickly grasp the
intended message thanks to its simple
nature and finally most importantly
content like images and videos are what
go viral with visual storytelling you
increase the chance for your content to
be seen by more potential customers
so have a look at some of our videos so
here's what is machine learning data
science in five minutes and AI in five
minutes now these are some of our most
viewed videos on our Channel and now you
know why visual storytelling if you guys
are interested in watching these videos
you can check them out on our Channel
homepage and we also have similar videos
on blockchain devops and Six Sigma but
now back to the list
let's go to number seven paying for
advertising
this is a method that helps you find a
Target and reach your audience with ease
it can greatly help with achieving your
organization's marketing goal
and this can help you improve your reach
and improve your Brand's visibility it's
pay-per-click model and shows cost
Effectiveness by providing great results
and return on investment it also helps
improve targeting by letting you control
who sees your ad you get to choose from
a number of different factors like
interests Hobbies personality types
alongside the basic user demographics
like age location gender and so on
now since most social media platforms
have native analytics you also get to
assess and Define the performance of
your ad campaigns
now as great as it sounds there are
certain pitfalls that come along with
peer advertising first of all your
audience could get exposed to your posts
too many times and tune out your content
disregarding it in the process
second it could get really expensive for
small businesses or startups to manage a
campaign to its maximum effectiveness
third people could pass off your content
as irrelevant or unimportant you also
have to deal with a lot of competition
smaller companies with lesser budgets
have more of an uphill battle to deal
with than better funded organizations
next we have number eight news jacking
newsjacking is a method that involves
using current events to promote your own
Brands products and services now it's a
popular method that's used to improve
brand awareness
newsjacking uses the popularity of
current events and drives it to your
brand it helps shine a spotlight on your
products and it also helps you show off
that you are up to date with current
events in the industry and that your
product is relevant and by extension it
also improves engagement and website
traffic
now for number nine a b testing
a b testing is a popular method for
comparing copies creatives and ctas or
call to actions of the posts that you
put on social media now since audiences
would react differently depending on the
content a b testing helps determine
which of the variants your audience
engaged with the most
a b testing can also be performed on
variations of location age gender
education your audience interests and so
on
and next up number 10 community and
influences
joining communities helps your brand
link up with like-minded people and
other companies belonging to your niche
it'll also help you establish your brand
as an authority within the industry
actively participating in these
communities can help create your own
audience of potential brand Advocates to
group up with
and on the other hand partnering up with
influencers helps promote your products
or services to a brand new audience
it helps provide an additional layer of
authenticity in YouTube which is also a
social media platform if you didn't know
here are some very very popular
influencers we have Marcus Brownlee
unbox therapy Mr who's the boss and
Linus Tech tips each of them with more
than 4 million subscribers
and finally we're at number 11.
measuring and analyzing results
accurately tracking and measuring your
marketing efforts are an important part
of the process it ensures that you're
making the most out of your campaigns
now it's really important that you find
key metrics that are crucial for your
brand and these metrics can be tracked
weekly monthly or on a quarterly basis
and based on these results appropriate
actions can be taken
so on Facebook you could look out for
reach and engagement on Twitter you
could look out for impressions
clicks and Impressions and interactions
on LinkedIn and likes comments and
mentions on Instagram and engagements
and Impressions on Pinterest
some of the most popular tools used for
this purpose are Sprout social buffer
HootSuite Google analytics and so on
and there you go that's our list here's
your reminder to subscribe to our
Channel and click on that Bell icon to
stay updated on tutorials lab sessions
and the latest Technologies and here's
some questions you might be asked in an
interview related to social media
marketing social media marketing is very
interactive a lot of people posting
information whether it be a tweet a post
a sharing liking engaging commenting I
mean a lot of things going on in social
media so some of it is going to probably
be good most of it's probably going to
be good but every once in a while you're
gonna get a negative comment so you're
probably going to be asked this question
how do you respond to negative comments
well very simple you got to be quick to
acknowledge okay don't sit on it you
know don't waste time him and ha how
you're gonna respond you really have to
acknowledge the comment and start the
process of constructive engagement to
turn the negative experience into a
positive one so let me just expand on
that for just a second we know you like
your brand we know you like your product
we know you're very proud we get that
I'm proud I like to defend sometimes my
beliefs however you got to put that
aside when it comes to social media why
because everybody is watching you and
everybody can read what you write so you
the spotlight is on you not necessarily
the consumer the customer who wrote the
negative comment so you really have to
be cognizant here and conscientious of
what you post in response so be quick
but be constructive because you want to
turn that negative into a positive
that's really what it's starting with so
how do you do that well how do you be
constructive well see it from the
customer's point of view take off your
ownership hat if you will your manager
hat and put on the customer's hat always
look at something from somebody else
else's perspective try to understand why
that person wrote that negative comment
and ask yourself how you can make it
right so if you're the customer and you
are your customer when you go to the
store and buy food you're the customer
when you go to the store and buy clothes
when you buy a car you're the customer
so ask yourself what you can do to make
it right why you're thinking in the
customer's perspective or looking
through their eyes if you will to me
it's it's not an easy thing to do but
it's something you have to do okay so
always look at it from a customer's
point of view and then take it out of
the spotlight so really because
everybody's looking at you waiting to
see how you respond and remember this
customer that wrote the negative comment
can certainly share your comments to the
world so you got to be really really
careful I mean how many times have we
seen on YouTube you know poor customer
experience going viral on on Via video
so you just gotta really be careful here
so take it out of the spotlight so I
offer to resolve the customers problems
in an appropriate form offer up your
phone number an email give them a link
to a feedback form or get their email or
phone number and call them these are the
best ways to really Bend this into a
more positive experience for the
customer I mean at the end of the day it
could be something really small and
silly but don't make a mountain out of a
molehill if it is something small and
silly how you respond could make it into
more than what it really is so be quick
be constructive look at it from the
customer's point of view and offer as
much support as you possibly can okay
that's how you want to respond if
somebody asks that question in an
interview some other comments here so
keep track although the issue might be
solved it doesn't necessarily mean the
commenter has gone away so follow up
with them if you resolved it follow up
with them a month later hey surprise
them two months later give them a
discount okay you'd be surprised
positivity goes a long way and it's
always nice when somebody actually
follows up with you after the fact just
to make sure they want to know that
you're taken care of and then don't feed
the social media trolls okay it's
ignoring trolls across social media will
make sure they don't enjoy the notoriety
it brings so don't even allow the
negativity to feed itself so that's why
you really have to stay quick
constructive you know look at it from a
customer's point of view and just turn
this whole experience into a positive
experience it's an opportunity for you
to hone your skills okay let's move on
to another question so if somebody may
ask you to give an example of a
successful social media campaign okay so
if you're going in to interview for
social media manager job you probably
want to do your homework in advance look
at what other people have done so here's
a good example Spotify you can see the
Spotify ad here with Ed Sheeran Spotify
mind the search and playlist data of its
user are based to develop a thematic
branded ad experience on billboards in
18 markets around the world first of all
let's just take this and break it down
Ed Sheeran's popular you can see here B
is loving as the person who put 48 Ed
Sheeran songs on their I love Ginger's
playlist so it messaging is everything
okay and then you can see what Spotify
did they mine the search and playlist
data of its user base okay so they try
to understand their audience going back
to email you got to understand your
audience okay then they use that to
develop a branded experience on
different markets around the world so
they took an audience and they really
marketed this around the world okay to
something that was really hot and trendy
I'd love to see how this thing actually
performed my guess is it did perform
fairly well because when you're Spotify
you're gonna pick something hot and
trendy to get people to react and so to
me this seems like just on the surface a
very successful social media campaign
here's some other things you can see
these ads more featured on the sides of
buildings Subway platforms along busy
streets so it wasn't just digital per se
I mean they really went full bore on the
Billboards and those Billboards were
everywhere on the sides of buildings
again in 18 different markets so you can
see it wasn't just necessarily Ed
Sheeran per se but you know they had
some good messaging and grow enjoy green
light at every red light that's pretty
cool I guess if you're stuck in traffic
in the middle of a city less fake news
more fake magic so they really took and
honed in the type of music put some good
message behind it and really put it out
there so it doesn't always necessarily
have to you know necessarily be digital
per se but they what they did was they
did post this on the sides of buildings
and Subway platforms and throughout
different city streets for maximum
visibility for their fans to upload to
their social media okay so do your
homework okay and on this next question
you certainly want to do your homework
so if your social media manager you're
probably going to be involved in some
Facebook advertising okay so this is a
basic straight up question what are some
of the different types of ads you can
run on Facebook you know you can do
single image ads most of us have
probably seen that can do multi-product
lead ads slideshows collection ads video
ads I mean you got all sorts of a
variety different ad formats here okay
so let's take a look at these ad formats
single image again most of us have seen
it okay it's just simply a single image
that you know has allows you to put some
text at the top a link at the bottom or
link to your website or your Facebook
page and a strong call to action okay so
Facebook has that built into their ad
platform okay so the ad images need to
be 1200 by 628 pixels it's a pretty nice
size image multiple product ads so
multi-product ads are represented in
Carousel form so basically it allows you
the end user to view the range of
products just by scrolling and notice
each one of these products has a call to
action so here you can see simply learn
offering up all the different courses
they have to offer so if you have a
customer that has multiple products this
is probably the way you want to go so
video ads are very popular on Facebook
so video ads usually range from a few
seconds all the way up to 120 minutes
and again video is very engaging if you
have video use the video okay because
they receive about 10 to 30 more views
than other forms of ads okay who doesn't
like engaging with video pretty simple
you have lead ads so lead ads allow you
to obtain user details like name phone
number email right in Facebook's
environment so it allows you to collect
information right then and there so lead
ads can be effective if you're trying to
get people to sign up for something
slideshow so we looked at those
multi-product ads where you had the
carousel slideshow simply just allows
you to rotate different creative with
nice imagery so the key here is nice
imagery okay you want to put your best
foot forward choose the right imagery
just like going back to the email
marketing you know going back to
pay-per-click you want to use some
effective ads here and images in the ads
okay you also have collection ads that's
another option on Facebook so collection
X ads combine video slideshow or product
images taken from your product catalog
so I would recommend this for users who
want to advertise several other products
at once okay again simply learn has a
lot of different courses a lot of
different thousands of courses so you
know collection ADS works for them you
can see here you got social media
certification you got PPC certification
SEO certification okay these are all
different certified education courses
you could take it simply learn and they
want to go ahead and promote all those
courses together so lo and behold
collection ads offers the best option
here so pay attention those different ad
formats on Facebook okay next question
how can you use the holiday season for
social media marketing well this is a
nice segue from the previous question
because you know you have on Facebook
all these different ad types so you
could change your ad placements to ones
lesser used by other advertisements you
can also set up clear simple and
compelling offers for your users the
holiday season you're likely going to
have some sales and again make sure your
images have under 20 percent of text
okay that's a standard across the board
but again you want to have nice imagery
so think about all these different ad
formats on Facebook think about the
hottie season and how you can accentuate
your ads here okay I'm thinking video
here I'm thinking a promotion in the
video I think in a collection ad where
you can run different products maybe
with a promotion with some nice imagery
during the holiday season so you
definitely have a plethora of options
not just on Facebook but across social
media for the holidays because normally
you're going to have promotions some
other things you can do to really
maximize the holiday season for social
media and that's make advertisements
emotionally resonate with your audience
the holiday season is a time really
where you reflect on the air you get
together with friends and family and
it's religious and you know it's a feel
good in some parts of the world the
weather changes so you want to resonate
on that okay you want to resonate on
that emotion okay you always holiday
season or not you want to monitor
reports to scale successful ad campaigns
and obviously the ones that aren't
performing you want to pause okay so
with the holiday season you're likely
going to have an uptick in traffic and
up second eyeballs so pay attention you
don't want to spend money for money's
sake so on Facebook it's a cost per
click model so you don't want to be
generating clicks without seeing any
results so go ahead and pay attention
maximize Those ads that are performing
and get rid of the ones that aren't okay
and then connect the holiday with your
products or services so again think
about which ones you're going to
accentuate which ones you're going to
make more prominent during the holiday
season again thinking back to the
Facebook ad types I'm thinking
carouseller collection ads if you can
really pump up some of your products and
have a nice promotion with them you can
run some nice collection ads on Facebook
Okay moving on to the next question so
somebody may ask you hey how do you make
content go viral okay I always wondered
that myself how does content go viral
it's a great question so really you're
not in necessarily in control but you
can certainly do some things to make it
more appealing for the Nu user to go
ahead and share it I mean that's what
going viral is right A lot of people
sharing it because the more people that
share the more people are going to look
and find it just as enticing and they're
going to turn around and share it so how
do you start that process really is what
it comes down to well create short form
content short form content is more
likely to go viral in other words a 10
minute video is probably not going to
resonate with somebody something cute
funny interesting unique out of this
world in 15 30 seconds is probably going
to go viral so what does that mean make
the visual content like images and video
it works better than bodies of text so
make sure those images and video are
really compelling and then run giveaways
to draw attention and generate brand
awareness and engagement so you can
always incentivize your users with a
giveaway or some type of promotion
that's going to maybe pique somebody's
interest you know share it with a
hundred friends and get 10 percent off
love as an example so these are some of
the things you can do to make it go
viral of course if you're trying to get
something to go viral you definitely
want to monitor behavior and then tweak
once you figure out how it's performing
okay you may have chosen the wrong
images you may have the wrong promotion
you may find that the content is a
little bit longer than you probably like
and you may want to cut it down some
other things you could do here is use
some trending hashtags and topics on
your posts so ride that wave if you will
for any Surfers in the audience hey two
people can ride the same wave so you got
a trending hashtag use that hashtag with
that video or post you can always ask
users to interact okay so you can always
ask them to like or share especially if
they're audience because when somebody
actually shares it that means they're
sharing it with somebody else who also
has an audience so that's a quick way to
get the ball going so to speak the ball
bouncing okay so next question which
Industries perform better with different
platforms great a question there's a lot
of different social media platforms you
got your most popular ones all the way
down to your least popular ones I mean
let's face it social media platforms are
also Geographic so some social media
platforms are more popular in say the
United States than say India or Russia
and vice versa we know China has a lot
of different social media platforms that
most Americans in the United States
don't even use so you got to keep that
in mind but we're not talking about
geography we're talking about industry
so you gotta also think about industry
here so generally in Facebook it's
usually food and beverage news and media
e-commerce those are the types of
industries that you might tend to see on
Facebook when we talk about e-commerce
you know it could be clothing it could
be you know restaurant okay selling or
could be a a food company selling you
know foods and beverages you also have
Instagram so Instagram tends to be more
Beauty food and beverage e-commerce so
when we talk about beauty we're talking
about clothes we're talking about makeup
you know maybe shoes dresses unique
Styles I see a lot of that on Instagram
and then LinkedIn for example generally
works with you know for me I look at
LinkedIn as B2B okay so anything you
know interesting in a specific industry
you're probably going to see some news
items and updates on that tips and best
practices and of course jobs a lot of
Recruiters on LinkedIn so linkedin's a
good place for you to really put
yourself out there to find that job you
seek that social media manager job okay
so here's a breakdown if you will of the
top five again in the United States you
know for those users who are watching
this from another country you know you
may find I'll be interesting if you
could get some feedback here you know in
the comment section of the video go
ahead and put you know the social media
platform you use in your country and
generally what do you see on that
platform do you see food and beverage do
you see gaming or entertainment do you
see e-commerce so share your thoughts
and knowledge with the rest of us so
next question how would you measure
social media marketing success of an
organization and this is a likely
question a question you're likely going
to get okay how do you measure success
and that's across the board not just
social but PPC email marketing display
affiliate so really you're always going
to have the right answer if you talk and
think about conversion so with
conversions about tracking content
downloads or sales or registrations or
Legion or form submissions anything
where you're going to get something in
return okay so to me that's the general
answer here you know how do we measure
success well it always depends on
strategy but if you're trying to get a
sale from Instagram based on your beauty
product or you got a promotion you're
running on Facebook and you're running
in a Elite Form type ad okay are you
getting people to enter in that enter in
details on the forms Mission so we
always want to track conversions from
that perspective okay you also have
engagement okay so your strategy may not
be conversion maybe your strategy is
simply brand awareness and engagement
you want to know how many people
participate in the conversation for
example you may post something that's
really you know hot Trend it's trending
it's it's political it could be business
it could be a world Affair you want to
be able to measure how many people react
how many people comment reply Repose
retweet share like Etc so engagement
metrics vary across different social
media platforms but basically when it
comes to engagement you can measure it
just has to align with the right
strategy you also have awareness again
if you're just simply in it for brand
awareness okay it's all about how many
people are actually looking at it the
total volume of people okay and how
widely your message is spreading okay
what's the reach it could also be just
simply traffic to your website so we can
certainly track traffic to websites by
clicks or shares so it doesn't always
have to be about conversion or
engagement it can simply hey we want to
drive traffic to the website it's a 37
what are some things to focus on when
advertising on Twitter okay you can
advertise on Twitter whether you knew
that or not now you know Twitter is a
platform where you can pay for
advertising so what do you want to focus
on when you do advertise on Twitter well
you want to emphasize urgency to make
sure users take immediate action you
want to express discounts and
percentages why well because you're
limited in what you can say on Twitter
you want to avoid using hashtags that
don't pertain to your brand and product
I know that may sound like common sense
but remember you're advertising in here
so you got to be really really really
careful because you're paying you're
paying for somebody to either look at
that ad or click on that ad so some
other things you want to keep focus on
is your ad copy it's got to be short and
to the point and then make sure your ads
are mobile friendly again just like most
social media platforms Twitter is no
different people are looking at Twitter
on their mobile phones so video ads
should have subtitles images and the
proper ratio so you always want to think
mobile mobile mobile because most people
are using mobile on their mobile phones
whether that be in the browser or via
app okay next question how can you use
social media to promote your event okay
so you got an event coming up I want to
promote it so you're going to turn to
social media and the first thing you do
is have Affiliates fans and attendees
share resources about the event okay use
leverage your community in other words
okay you can remarket the event to
potential attendees using Facebook ads
so you can do remarketing and
remarketing is basically hey somebody
who's seen in it or been there or done
that you're retargeting those people you
can use photos of attendees and social
updates so depending on the event you
can have some really high profile
attendees speaking of the event or just
attending the event so use photos to
drive excitement about the event okay
you can create a uniform hashtag that
can be shared across multiple channels
you can mention the event all social
media bios so don't just limit it to one
you know cross promote it on Twitter
LinkedIn Etc and what you could do is if
you run other events in the past create
a highlight rail from prior events you
know show people hey your events are the
events you must attend they're the go-to
events because they're popular they're
successful good attendees usually good
attendance and then some other things
you could do here share behind the
screens visual content and again you can
share pictures of guest speakers along
with their quotes Okay so you want to do
everything possible at your are at your
disposal especially on social media to
really pump up the event next question
how can you perform a b testing on your
ads so for those of you that listen
intently on the email marketing fart
remember e a b testing is key with email
marketing what do we test at an email
we're testing subject lines for testing
layout we're testing call to action so
the same thing here on social media you
want to do continuous a b testing to
figure out what works and doesn't work
it's very simple the great thing about
Facebook is they got an A B test feature
built in so you can certainly test
different ads great thing about Facebook
I like is that you can simply start out
with an ad by running an A B test you
could simply test the imagery it could
be a male versus a female you could test
the call to action a lot of things you
could test so things you can change are
again color of the elements you could
change the positioning you could change
the audience you're targeting the call
to action I mean everything everything
because the whole point is you want to
see which one works which one doesn't
work so testing can be done initially on
broader elements and then smaller finer
details like statements in your ad copy
so you could start out big just by
testing the imagery and so if the female
tends to work better than male then you
know what works in terms of imagery
we'll take the next step and start
honing it on say the message and then
once you figure out what message works
then you can move to the next element
like CTA some interesting questions you
may get include what are some things to
focus on when setting up your ad
creative this goes back almost to the a
b testing you want to use ad creative
that's a tension grabbing and relevant
for your business so use a primary but
bold color scheme so you also want to
stay away from clip art okay so again
align your imagery really is important
on social media don't you do some basic
cheap clip art you don't necessarily
always have to use stock imagery either
I mean it could be imagery you took
that's very relevant and unique to your
product but if you do that don't use low
resolution pixelated images use images
that are well lit so decide on the
aesthetic you want for your creative
clean and minimal or colorful and
vibrant it really depends on you know
the advertisement what it is you're
trying to promote so some other things
to focus on here to create attention
grabbing ads show images of people
benefiting from your product Coca-Cola's
done this forever when have you never
seen a Coca-Cola commercial with
somebody with a smile on your face
drinking a bottle of coke I don't think
I've ever seen an advertisement so when
it comes to food you should always have
somebody in there enjoying the food if
it comes to clothes should have somebody
looking like they really enjoy wearing
these clothes and they look great in
them you want to accentuate that with
you know some nice coloring sticking
with your brand guidelines okay so
imagery really is important here so you
do need to make sure the ad works for
your brand without requiring explanatory
copy the image should basically speak
for itself so here we wrap up basics in
social media marketing if you like this
video consider subscribing to our
Channel and
updates if you have any questions put
down in the comment section our experts
will be happy to answer your questions
stay tuned with simply learn till we
meet again thanks for watching
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here